Hello everyone, it is I, no longer Doki Bird.
I am Depressor Bird right now.
I actually was, I almost cried.
I'm not gonna lie.
You know how like you cried in so hard and then it didn't matter.
I actually I actually wanted to cry the games were so guys clover pit took off why did I play clover pit it took off and the worst teammates of my life I was so I was so close every time I was so close and then I lose so much and then I so much that I love I'm going crazy I'm fucking going crazy
quantum thank you for the gift oh my god how many did you gift it quite thank you for the 20 gifted subs thank you thank you I really appreciate need this guys I oh I forgot to turn it give me a sec I forgot to turn it off because now my thingy it goes red and and not red okay so so the games let's just say the games have been really really rough it's been so bad god so thank you again for the five gifts and subs thank you thank you now i'm at the point where i just i just i'm throwing my i'm donating my elo away what happens happens now I didn't get like,
okay, so I'll show you guys.
Queen, thank you for the five kisses.
So, thank you.
Thank you.
I was like, wait, things are okay.
Things are going okay.
It's so sad.
I'm like, oh my God, Wait, I think I'm doing it, guys.
I'm doing it.
Things written back.
Not okay.
I almost had that feeling where I wanted to cry.
And I was like, I need a stream.
I need my emotional support dragoons right now.
Because I was this close to crying.
The reason why is that girl is always just imagine.
It's just points.
It's just like, you know.
What?
why is he barking i think you heard someone outside so um he heard he's hearing people outside close the door all right so actually no because what if he wants to no why are you not barking no you hear someone outside at like three in the morning so it's like what are you doing it's four it's it's 343 okay so basically um you guys are like oh it's just rake numbers Why are you so sad?
It's because I spent so much time playing.
That's the thing.
I was so close so many times.
And then the thing is, like, not sleeping and playing ranked.
So I'm like, I can do it.
I think I can actually do it.
Because, like, at first I was just playing just to play.
Because, like, I was running away from my responsibilities, like, right now.
But I was like, wait, wait, I'm getting closer.
Wait, I think I can actually do it.
and then and then it made me so sad because i was like oh i spent so much time i spent so much time but i can't do it you know i have two i can't there's no way i don't think i can i need to get celestial two but it has to be a high celestial like okay this is me i'm celestial three i'm like I this is okay and then the cutoff is Celestio 2 so I don't I don't think I'm gonna make it I never never have hope never have hope I had hope for I don't know why I had to have hope never have hope so that's I was like really sad because I was like oh I could have used that time to work Oh my gosh,
there's only one thing that can make me feel a little better, too.
So I was like, oh, there's like, oh my gosh.
I could have used that time to, like, do work stuff instead.
I need this.
That's my backdrop, obviously.
I could have used this time to do work stuff instead of playing.
Tokyo, why did it?
And then instead of doing work stuff, I decided to stream Rivals instead.
I stopped posting my schedule for today, technically.
I was like, I'm just going to stream right now.
I need this.
You don't understand.
I need this right now.
I need my emotional support dragons right now to like give me strength.
Because I think like, I think if I didn't stream today, if I didn't stream, like after me accepting that was a top 500, I think I would have crashed out really, really hard.
I was crashing.
I was already crashing out.
But like, I would have crashed out.
even harder
so that's why I was like oh my god no that's tomorrow that's on Thursday sponsors at Thursday so that's why I'm like I'll queue and just whatever happens happens who cares if I derank and I keep deranking okay what grinds my queue is that I can't find anyone to play with me at this time because it's so degenerate time but it's like like people scrim they scrim and then like but and then when they're done scrimming i stream and like i'm streaming something else that's not marvel ribos and then when i'm done streaming my stuff they're done they're done playing people i know start playing rank or like they can only play a little bit and then it'll be like too late but it's like this is the only time i can play this is the only time I have like a very,
and then like, oh my god, people will only play if I'm streaming, but I want to play off stream too.
So it's very lonely.
It's very lonely up here.
So that's what grabs my gears.
DK, thank you for the five.
Give the toes.
Thank you, thank you.
Warfarin, thank you for the five.
Give the toes.
Thank you, thank you.
Quentin, thank you for the dear ones.
success so yeah um I'm just gonna cue my sorrows away maybe I'll make new friends I don't know I maybe I'll make new friends zero out of 76 people online not a single not a single person online.
Jen, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I hope you had a good stream.
I'm so lonely, Mr. Lonely.
They sensed the doom queue.
But yeah, I'm ready.
I'm ready to queue my life away.
I mean, it is as I had three people online when I was queuing.
There were only three people online when I was queuing earlier.
It's so rough.
But yes, that is why I'm streaming.
So I had to vent.
I had to vent a little bit there because I was very, very sad when I, like, I accepted, you know, like, when you fully accepted that, like, I've hit my acceptance stage, you in denial at first and then anger i was very i went through the five stages of grief i'm at the acceptance stage i don't know what comes up i think that's the last stage right because i got angry i got very angry i was so angry bro i had a team that yelled at us for playing triple support and we lost fucking,
I don't know, we lost because the other team was doing 2-2 and then we lost because we had triple support and they're like, oh my god, you guys are so scummy and I was like, I broke my silence because our team actually only had three support players.
Like we, all three of us were only support mains.
So we had, it's not like we wanted to run triple support.
We couldn't play anything else.
So I was like, bro, like all our support means.
What do you want us to do?
Play Dank or DPS?
All three of us are support players.
Because they kept blaming us for playing triple support.
And I was like, bro, what's up?
Because we got several.
We actually had three support players for once.
Coincidentally, we had three people that actually could only play support.
So...
so i i was like i like broke my i like it broke the straw i was just like you because they kept blaming us for playing triple support
no i went through a lot of really shitty support players today it's okay venom can bring me joy
but thank you yeah triple support is good but we had bad support players on triple support i hate we had we just didn't have really good players on triple support uh doge thank you for the tier one sub thank you thank you um i really appreciate it herb thank you for the hundred bitties thank you thank you uh yeah he shakes his he's shaking his me for emotional support um i this stream is preventing me from fully crashing out oh we're just like oh why haven't you slept because i i fucked up my sleep schedule a lot i think i might have to reset it today i'm gonna try i'm gonna try to stay up and fully reset my schedule because i do have a sponsor stream on thursday guys we might not have okay so i was gonna announce this later but i got invited to do it i can't say what it is at the moment i'll announce it um later but i i got invited to do a business trip um so i will be traveling later this week um so no there will be a stream tomorrow there will be a stream i'm just trying to try my
best and reset my schedule today uh so i got invited to a business trip thing later this week it's not twitchcon i know like twitchcon's next week it's not twitchcon um it's something else um it was so last minute i literally booked my tickets uh this week that's how last minute it was um so yeah maybe i'll make new friends along the way any new friends Maybe I should put it,
maybe I should put it on my stream looking for someone to doom queue with me.
So I can drag them down with me.
So we're like, oh, weren't you playing with Gomez earlier?
Yeah, but apparently he hasn't slept.
Like, he barely slept at all the last two days.
So I freed him.
he's no longer chained in my basement I was like you can go now I was like you can go now
you're be free
so um so that's I so that's I it's just I'm it's just me wallowing in my sorrows.
I was like, that was probably like, it's not gonna work.
It's not gonna happen anymore.
You are now freed.
I no longer, I will no longer chain you there with just, with just water.
Alright.
Free Willy.
Oh my god, we didn't pass Torch.
why the did we not span torch oh okay that's fine that's fine that's fine surrender now am i just thinking i'm just done i just surrender now
oh why am i lagging what the when this happens because it's like no no no no because it was fine earlier.
What the fuck?
It was fine earlier.
What's wrong with you?
I was thinking.
Okay.
Uh...
This sucks.
Wait, no, I did limit it.
Watch.
Match.
Oh, wait.
What?
What the fuck?
When did it got reset?
This was limited before.
Oh my god, this sucks.
I don't know.
I don't know why I'm lagging.
Oh my god, fucking curse.
We didn't ban torch them.
We didn't have a torch player.
See, this is my, these have been my games.
These have been, it's just RNG.
These have actually, these has been my games.
It's literally, literally, yeah.
Oh, there's the torch.
Yay.
Oh fucking curse, we don't have the actual torch.
Forge player.
Okay, nice.
It's fine.
He got res.
That's fine.
I wanted to play.
I've been, like, playing mostly Luna lately.
Just because, like, I just can't be bothered.
Not Luna.
Uh, Invis.
Invis is just, it makes me feel happier.
Because it's, like, less pressure.
That's weird.
Usually, uh...
Oh.
Ha ha ha you fucked up.
Ha ha you fucked up bitch.
Oh, I wasted my clap though.
I fucked up Oh, some of those who don't know this auto-pusher so you don't have to actually You don't actually have to touch it.
Oh, he's so dead.
What the fuck is he doing?
He is so dead though.
Yeah I knew he ain't coming home See like rocket does not have to stand there, but I don't know.
He's just a little quirky like that
Yeah, it all you literally don't have to you just have to go there at the last second Like when it crosses the the the cave area.
That's when you have to What the fuck?
Oh my god, four Maybe oh I did it.
I helped I helped goodbye four.
Well, goodbye.
Hey guys.
It's all right.
I can push a little bit don't need me oh nice let's go okay our our rocket's pushing it a little so i can i can participate a little bit oh i don't know why maybe i should have restarted my game maybe i should yeah i should restart my pc i'll fix it after this i can do it i'll restart my my i'll look through my settings after this Holy shit!
Some fucking football action right there.
Hello, hello.
Okay, goodbye.
We're gonna have a little early, but I knew I was gonna die.
I knew I was gonna... Oh!
Hello, Mag!
Hello!
He held it.
Oh!
That's unlucky.
I don't... We're just gonna die.
Let's just die together.
Well, that was a useless, useless ult.
Right there.
Maybe I'll do...
Oh my gosh.
I would like to do not 240, maybe 160.
Hello, Spider-Man.
Your friendly neighborhood, Spider-Man.
I don't want to play Invis, but we have a Spider-Man.
Invis is so much less stressful.
I just push people away.
And it's, like, much more relaxing, you know?
Goodbye.
I'm a hero!
Remember me!
There you go.
I'm a hero.
Remember what I did.
No!
Why me?
Oh, thank God he's back.
He's back.
Yay!
He's back!
It's okay, he's back, guys.
He's back.
It's okay, he's back.
It's like nothing bad happens.
Scary.
That was scary.
It's okay, but he's back.
He's back.
Nothing to worry about.
Oh my gosh.
If I knew he was going to hook that, I would...
Okay, we got to help him, but...
we couldn't finalize anything it's okay it'll be fine right oh i i should let rocket rocket you have all right rocket a whole rock okay i'll just stay here we'll just have rocket all at first there's no reason for me to all first this is better to engage.
Mine's is, like, defensive.
There you go.
See?
Oh, my God.
He lives.
Oh, goodbye.
Here you go.
You should be able to hit him, right?
I was going to be like, bro, that was a sick-ass freeze.
You should be able to hit that guy, right?
Rocket, please!
Rocket, I'm waiting for you!
How many people must we kill?
Oh, no.
I see.
He doesn't know I'm here, so I live.
Alright.
Oh, where is she?
Where did she go?
Oh, they're running name more.
Those whores.
They're desperate to win, just like I'm not anymore.
I'm not.
I have a code for my crosshair.
Maybe.
When I'm not sad anymore, maybe I'll feel generous.
No!
It's fine, it's still winnable.
You might have Wolverine up, but it's fine.
It depends on how less sad I am.
If I'm to be generous, I'm dead.
Oh wait, no, I'm not dead.
I mean, we should just leave, honestly.
I just want... I'm just going to farm up from this guy.
Goodbye.
You're my alt battery.
Alright.
That sucks.
We should have fully cap that.
Okay, this Hulk is getting hard, buddy, though.
For sure.
Alright.
It's fine.
I'll take the squid on.
Who is over there?
Oh my, why?
How did he get over there?
First off, how did he fucking get over there?
All right, we're so...
Okay, I'm gonna save our...
I'm saving our health real fast.
All right, nice.
At least we got him out of the way.
All right, let's go back in again.
And you get a web and you get...
Oh, he is alive.
Oh, and I am not a- I'm live too.
No, he has a- he definitely has a- Oh,
I fucked up.
Don't wait!
Don't wait, Rekko!
We got- see, I am actually such a team player.
There we go.
There he is.
Bro, I am such a team- look at that!
This is how you appeal!
People don't fucking peel sometimes, and it pisses me off.
Oh.
People don't fucking peel in this yellow sometimes.
Okay, let me fix this real quick.
Oh!
I hate it when that happens.
What is it?
Nate.
Okay, let me...
Actually, let me check.
Where am I at?
Yeah, my CPU...
And my memory is all low, so I don't know why I'm lagging a little.
It's so annoying sometimes.
It really is.
Let's see.
I don't know why sometimes does it.
No, it's because we're not playing yet.
When we're playing, it starts doing it.
Round two.
Go!
Or maybe it's fixed.
I don't fucking know.
Let me see.
Alright.
Maybe it's better now.
Does that, maybe I has a memory leak.
Honestly, I might restart my game.
I've been playing for a very long time.
It's crazy right now.
Why does, that's always like, the snow, why does she stop?
Like, I've been, I've been like, waiting for a very long time.
I actually, I've never, I've never done any type of like, like weed or whatever.
I've never, it's actually, people, I, say that and people are like, are you sure?
It's like, I'm never.
Oh,
wait.
Oh, okay.
We have a star lord.
This fucking Hulk sucks.
Their Hulk is so bad.
I'm gonna say that and he's gonna beat the shit out of me.
Oh, shit.
He's gonna beat the shit out of me in the moment after I say that.
I have a feeling.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'm safe in my little hidey hole.
Okay, I needed to give it to the starlet.
Okay, oh, it's fixed now.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, I thought that would...
Oh, I'm scared.
I talk shit and I don't want to get hit.
It's a legitimate... I think that's a legitimate fear.
You don't talk shit and you don't want to get hit.
Whoa.
I go here.
Oh, I don't want to go there.
Bro, get out!
Get out!
Oh, that's unlucky.
Can we even cap?
Nah.
Oh, I'm missing my friezes now.
I'm trying to fucking...
Oh, my God.
What is he doing?
He's...
You're crazy.
crazy man so silly oh goodbye oh goodbye i'm gonna save our mag i decided to pick my mag that's fine
all right oh wait he's alive
oh my god he's so low too oh damn it i am ready to put up okay i score Oh, goodbye.
It's fine, right?
I'm not living that.
I knew if I...
Oh, it doesn't matter.
I knew.
It didn't matter.
I didn't...
That's why I didn't ult that.
We would have died regardless if I ulted or not.
Oh my god, go rocket.
Go.
Go be the rocket you've always wanted to beat.
Come on.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I thought he was going to ult that when, you know, Bucky did the get down, but it's okay.
She's over here!
Get him!
Oh, she missed.
It's okay.
Sometimes you just miss.
Oh, I leave now.
I don't want...
Okay, there you go.
Oh, Star Lord, please don't...
Please don't die.
There we go.
Oh, I'm not lagging anymore.
Yay.
I fixed it.
I don't know what I did.
It just fixed itself, just like that.
I don't know what happened.
Hello.
I would like a little bit of heal.
It's, you know, it's ideal.
Just a little suggestion.
Really?
Like, I guess...
Oh!
I would like a little bit of heal right here too.
Oh, it would've been so cool if I hit that.
If I hit that...
Oh my god!
Thank you!
Okay, I'm...
I'm okay with that.
Like, he actually got me closer to my team.
Like, that's actually quite ideal.
He, like, took me closer to my...
Oh!
Goodbye, Starlord.
Like, thank god- Oh!
Um, I hope Eels first, really.
Oh, we're even right now.
It's not too bad.
It's not too bad, we're even.
Oh!
Now we're up!
Alright, as long as we fight for two more minutes.
Should be five.
We don't question it exactly.
I almost have out two.
I am a...
Oh my god, that is a lot of us.
Guys, I think...
I think maybe we might have overdone...
Okay, that's fine.
We're all...
Whoa!
Who cares about alt management?
Am I right?
It's okay.
Our star lord.
Our star lord's gonna clutch this.
I believe it's okay.
Our star lord, our star lord.
It's gonna do so much Goodbye, oh my god.
We still alive.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh goodbye.
It was it was a good show Good show good show good show It's true
All right, that's fine.
I'll just use my life first.
It's okay I know we had a little system going in.
Oh, wait.
Only I have a...
I don't know why.
I thought there's a reason.
I...
Are you serious?
Guys, why did no...
Guys, he was one!
Why did no one help me?
He was one!
Oh, my God.
This one!
Oh my god, we're so close!
Oh my god.
I think... I don't know if we can.
Oh wait, we can't.
He just might be dead though.
He is so dead.
I have to die on card.
He is dead.
Oh!
I'm so sad.
I could have...
I thought my rocket was with me to kill the cloak but sadly sometimes sometimes things ain't like that guys sometimes they do be like that okay all right i'm giving this to the mag so he lives a little bit nice where was that i was like where did he go where the where the What the fuck did this guy go?
Okay, this is bad.
Because...
It's fine.
Okay, it's not fine anymore.
It's not fine anymore.
It's fine.
It's still fine.
You're so fucking stupid.
You're so bad.
You have Ava and you shot at the Starlord.
You...
Imagine having aimbutt and shooting at the guy.
Okay, never mind, he said.
Shooting at the guy with the snowflake.
You're so stupid.
You're so fucking stupid.
Like, holy shit.
Oh, God.
I thought I could fight.
Yeah.
It's okay.
One, four, three, two.
Hello, you're so dumb.
Oh my god, you're so stupid Get out of here.
I'm playing.
I'm playing I'm doing queuing don't think I can't handle you.
I've seen it all
You think you can make me sad?
How are we down in the pits right now?
another epic victory yay I don't de-rank today well I did de-rank but I don't de-rank for this game do not yeah do not mess with a doom queuing dokey yeah they can't push me down when I'm already rock a bottom I've already seen the depths of hell and And then I look back at myself.
I'm here.
Yeah, you can't make me sad.
I'm here because I am sad.
It's too late.
It's too late for me.
What the fuck are these people?
Who the fuck is Apollo?
Who is this guy?
Alright.
Wait, who was?
Was he in my team?
Who is this guy?
Oh, they were on the enemy team.
They fucked me up.
I was like, new friend?
Wait, I don't know who this guy is.
I've never heard of this guy before.
I mean, he's top 500 right now.
I could take him out of top 500.
Is that fucked up?
I could do.
I could take him out of top 500.
What the fuck, though, for V to say?
Is that...
Is that a little...
True.
If I can't get top 500, no one can.
He's...
Yeah, he's asking for it.
He can't.
I'll accept it.
If he invites me, I'll join.
is that the way to start a friendship I see that you were your top 500 I guess I guess enjoy it before it's gone when you take yeah I see someone top 500 I play with them and then they lose top 500 and then i swapped those until i've and then if i bring everyone out of top 500 eventually it'll be low enough for me to get in yeah that's the strat guys that's the strat if i yeah if they if i can't have it they can't have it too true
No problem with this strat.
I don't even know who this guy is.
I see that they're top 500.
I accept.
Exactly.
I'm already sad.
I drag people down with me.
I don't understand why it's so high now.
I got a...
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
Like, okay, look at what...
Last season was not that high.
Last season...
it was like not this one sorry 3.0 it was oh it was still celestial one never mind i lied i was so what the fuck i just everyone wants the dragon the dragon is so cool
the dragon is so cool i mean like look at it everyone wants it it's so cool look at this tiny ass thing i have this is my it but then look look at this dragon so sad look at it don't you can see this you can see it you can it's so cool it even has smoke blowing out everyone wants it including me they got me they know they know they know i hope badly i won it they've got me They clutched me.
They hook up me by the shoulders and it can't let go.
In fact, I just want, I want it.
I don't care.
That's okay.
You know what would cheer me up?
You know what will exactly cheer me up right now?
Some good old-fashioned role play.
No one plays Venom anymore in the RP servers.
It makes me so sad.
Like, everyone forgot the class.
sick.
How do I get out of here?
I'll fucking see how to leave this area too.
This is a fucking maze.
Give me a sec.
I gotta figure out how to get out of this town.
Okay, there's here.
And then...
Um...
Okay, right here.
His ass is not outdated!
He's forever!
Where are they?
Where are the role players?
That's forever young hello hello ladies and the raccoon are you ready for a show oh yes you are get over here yes you are ahead are you ready did i hear it's someone's a birthday that's right oh my i'm ready for it that's right i'm ready for the bachelorette party let's go whoa bro i love hey it's about me ma'am not no no no no no get get no no no no no me yeah yeah that's right that's right that's what i like that here ma'am in fact here's a little bonus no extra charge no oh oh she's gone all right hey is your is your special day you know what Fuck it,
now that I'm here, you might as well.
Hey, hey, why are you backing up?
Why are you wearing that?
That's right.
Oh, now it's a party.
What competitive...
I need this, guys.
I need this so much.
Bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada.
Also, these queues are fucking...
Oh, there.
Never mind.
I love these cues.
It's not harassment if they enjoyed it.
You saw her.
She gave me a slap in the ass.
I'm broken.
I am.
I'm a shell.
I'm a husk of person I once was.
Alright.
What do I play?
Let's see.
Oh.
This is a great...
Oh, a mom.
I heard this guy is Someone his name is like billions or some shit.
I'm sorry.
I don't mean your shit.
I just I'm just
I'm just saying that this is somebody.
This is a like a semi pro or something
All right All right, it's okay.
They banned torch for me.
It's fine.
She banned Adam Adam Yeah, that's fine.
I don't have the word like triple with support what would you want to burn inside why am i an ultra um i don't know i don't know anybody not gonna lie the only thing i the only people i know is if they have if they have a liquipedia then i know blade is actually decent if you can add like um it's decent if you know how to use in like certain situations if they're just playing blade if they're one trick and they don't swap off blade if they get hard counter then like that's that's when it sucks but blade is like super situational yes jeff is meta triple support is meta and jeff is meta in certain maps um it's just hell honestly it's just it's just a living hell i as a support player i hate triple support it's not my favorite
I don't know how to do his all I'm so fucking bad I know how to heal on Jeff I just I'm so bad at his all I always like I always fuck it up is because it's just so difficult for me yeah no this is metacomp well I mean except for the blade it's almost perfect Just give this a bit.
Apparently Daredevil is like super hard to play.
Like he has such a high.
He has a really high glass ceiling.
Like not glass ceiling.
He has a really high learning curve in ceiling.
I'm Celestial 3 right now.
Top 500 is...
Top 500 is Celestial 2.
That ain't me though.
I'm crying.
through my tears i'm laughing through my tears right now
jesus i need reload so i'm sorry if you die it's not me it's called reloading reload oh my god they have ultra we why didn't we battle tron oh my god why didn't we battle tron stupid are we stupid or something we are we're so dumb
oh my god we're so dumb we did a bad ultra we laugh through the page oh my god i should have used my team up now might be a good time to start i should have used my team up i i don't know i'm in my head i thought i'd be okay, but I was obviously not we would have died regardless I think I need to remember,
oh never mind, I guess, yes I don't have to remember yay
I wasted my clap but it's alright, I don't really care the joy of aww see, these are Alright, see these are those moments where you sort of, you know, you know when, oh, goodbye.
It's fine.
These are the moments where you sort of need to know when to swap off blade.
So yeah.
Goodbye.
We just have nothing.
goodbye it's gg it's just unfortunate it really is it's just it's just unfortunate i don't think we can stop them they said we can but like i have a feeling that this is not the time to stop him i did i saved his life you're welcome don't need to thank me I am a hero.
Oh.
What the fuck was he doing over there?
Goodbye, Bucky.
Goodbye.
It's okay.
I had a great time with all of you.
I'll see you again in another life.
You heal me, I heal you.
And then I heal him.
And then I heal you.
And then we die.
Oh, shit.
I'm alive.
And then I do this, I guess.
Okay.
Okay, I did not expect it.
I actually did not expect that.
Hey, guys.
If we...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
You heal me and then I heal you.
Oh.
Okay.
Um.
Oh, this is a little awkward.
Oh.
Yes, I have.
Whoa.
Hey, do you have bubbles?
Yes, you do.
And then Star Lord Ulx.
Wow, it's like, I predicted that perfectly.
I predicted that so perfectly.
Wow.
Guys, it's cool, guys.
We, it was not a full four minutes.
And that's all that matters.
Guys, as long as...
We should, we should surrender.
We should very much surrender.
Just like clockies.
The way you did, Urs.
This team is just...
We were cooked from the start.
It was just unfortunate.
This team was just...
Just a team diff.
That is this...
It is actually just a team dip.
Because, like, Starlo- Mantis- Mantis, Luna does not do enough heals at all.
Wait, is our Scythe-Log Zero?
You play Mantis?
One of you?
Zero-five?
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Are we trying now?
Wow.
That's nice to know.
That's...
30 seconds before you attack.
Wow.
That's nice to know.
That's cool.
When can I play Envis?
Sucks.
I've actually been playing a lot of Envis for this season.
I've been avoiding Luna.
It's like...
I'm just tired of Luna.
The battle starts in five.
Four, three, two, Things will change, right?
It'll be different this time.
I believe...
I root.
Alright, let's see.
All I need to do is just...
Jesus, no one can heal you.
Not even God himself can save your life.
Oh my god.
It was so like...
Alright.
Eh, well, I didn't really need that bubble, but thanks for thinking about me, I guess.
I can't believe we didn't fucking ban Ultron.
Why did we ban all these other supports?
Like, but Ultron wasn't your first fake?
Oh my god.
Like, how can you ban so many supports, but yet you forget Ultron?
That's actually crazy.
We...
Ultron just sucks to play against.
I rather play against a Jeff than an Ultron.
Because, like, a good Ultron can be so oppressive.
So it's, like, not fun.
Um...
Yeah.
Oh.
Me too.
Okay.
These two shitty ass e-daters on my team.
You get your dog shit.
Yeah, for sure, man.
Oh, bro.
What if they live together?
You can't just assume.
What if they're...
Maybe they're not in it.
Can I assume that everybody's in it?
Yay!
And it could be like, it could live together.
Hey, I got you, buddy.
That's funny though.
That's crazy.
No!
Why are we winning now?
We...
No!
Oh,
they got it.
Goodbye.
Why couldn't Armag do what he did?
Oh, I'm back.
Alright, it's cool.
No, don't.
No, stop.
Don't cap.
Stop.
No.
Wait, what the fuck is?
Okay, yeah, they are definitely not trying to cap.
No.
There we go.
No, stop.
Whoa.
No, stop, guys.
I was just trying to cap.
Everyone, stop!
Guys, come on!
Stop!
Why is no one stealing the raccoon?
Oh, he's fucked.
Oh, this is where it ends, Ashley.
Oh, yeah, this is where it ends for me.
There's still hope.
Stop hoping.
I had no util for that.
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man!
Final score!
No, Amano isn't shit.
Amano is actually a good player.
He's apparently used to be on Hundred Thieves.
Like, this is all to count from what I'm told.
But he just... he left Hundred Thieves because he was...
I think his name is Billions or something?
And he left a Hundred Thieves because he just didn't want to play pro play anymore.
Which is understandable.
Um, who was the blade?
Oh, the e-daters?
There's a hundred thieves off.
Dude, didn't they win?
They weren't they champions?
No, they're currently good, apparently.
Um, what is it?
Alright, let's see.
Okay, yeah, I'm avoiding.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, I'm avoiding.
I saw that.
I was like, no, it's all out.
Get out.
I saw your peak.
Get out of my lobby.
No, no.
The games have been, I had so much hope at first from here.
Wait.
Here.
This was when I started having hope again.
And then, and then the game was like, no.
And then I was like, wait a minute.
Wait, I can bring this back.
I can bring this back.
And then this is when I, This is when I was like, okay, I quit.
I quit.
It's not reachable anymore.
It's not.
Apollo got off.
You got off?
Oh my, how am I supposed to bring anyone down to my level?
It's rough up there.
It ends in two days.
one day at 20 hours I can't believe it Adamie just deflects his top five see it's like it's so it's so much bigger than look at that like you could see his top five look at my tiny look at this stupid ass crest versus this top 500 crest look at how big the fucking top 500 crests compared to my tiny ass beta test shit Like,
that means you're, it looks so good!
I'm sorry, above average.
This is above average.
That's not fair.
Can't even make other people miserable.
Like, what's the point?
Why can't I just...
make other people lose top 500 that is the only thing that will make me happy well i did make gomez lose top 500 so that made me happy um but but i want more people to lose their top 500 i that's evil but what's the fun of it if it's just one person why can't i sabotage every person not one exactly it's not enough i need at least 500 of these people to lose their top 500.
it is it's toxic positivity but you know and so these other streamers give you negative toxic um give you a negative toxic uh uh was it was it was a positive mental attitude i'm here to give you a positive toxic mental attitude is that what pma is positive mental attitude that's what pma is right i'm giving you a tf t pma this is exactly why you don't you rank the last week i haven't i'm playing rake every day okay almost every day
so close so i was at one point three matches from securing top 500 i was three matches of securing top 500 and then i lost seven games in a row and now i'm in the trenches i literally got hit like touched top 500 and i was that close i touched top 500 i'm so sad it was like right there i have
oh my god did i forget to save it no i forgot to save the no i did have proof i i forgot to save it no i forgot to save the screenshot oh why is everything not gold for dokey I'm so sad I forgot to save it the one time now no one will believe me oh forgot to save it I thought I did the proof is lost forever Wow,
who am I gonna banish from this match?
That's God.
Just like my happiness.
God.
Forever.
It's okay.
Oh my God.
I...
Thank God that guy.
I couldn't tab in fast enough.
I was trying to grab something real quick.
I'm banning ammo.
Oh.
Harbors, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I realized what was making me lag.
It's because when I tab out, when I tab out and I don't tab back in to VTube Studios, it lags.
Which is pretty stupid, but like whatever.
Like, whatever.
It does what it wants.
Hey, Ruben.
No, it's over.
I've accepted my fate.
I've accepted.
can do now is just hoping that whenever I lose a game someone else is losing their top 500 that's that's the only thing that that's bringing me joy right now I'm hoping I'm hoping that whenever I lose someone else is also losing
That I fucked up there.
Top 500 securement.
That's what I'm hoping for.
And it...
That is the joy.
That is the one thing that's giving me so much joy right now.
Real.
Hey, Rigsie.
Alright.
This is my only thing that keeps me going.
Hoping that I fucked up.
I made their day.
I miserable.
Okay, I'm still playing the best I can.
Like, I'm playing, I'm still trying, but like, even when I try and lose, if I try and lose, at least like, knowing that I'm not the only one losing.
I swear to God, I'm also trying.
I'm not, I'm not throwing.
Please don't report me.
Oh my God, we're all losers playing triple support.
It's okay.
we all it's the last two days it's like goats please can we go triple sword please i'm like
please guys bro please i'm so close to top back can we go triple support that's okay i understand guys i understand what the fuck who where is your fucking extermination there it is.
Here you go.
Here's your double.
There we go.
Come on, let's kill him.
Oh, shit.
Let's JK.
I guess you can kill him.
JK.
There you go.
Let's go.
I'm not healing, though.
Like, I'm not getting a lot of all charge.
I'm just damage boosting my friends.
Oh, my God, you crazy.
Oh, my God.
He's dead.
He's so dead.
What the fuck?
You fucking freak.
There you go.
Where is he?
No!
I couldn't damage!
I couldn't give him the mega damage boost!
I can't do it.
No!
I threw that.
I tunnel vision him.
That's my bad.
everything.
Sorry, that was my bad tunnel vision that if I live we win that.
All right, focus up.
I haven't played Mantis in a bit.
So that is also my bad.
Don't brush me, don't brush me.
There we go.
Goodbye.
Here we go.
There we go.
Here we go, we did it.
Oh, so many.
Thank you for giving me tier one sub to Riggsian.
Ruben, thank you.
For Mantis, I have to actually focus up because I don't like I have to actually fucking aim.
I can't like fucking cruise.
I also haven't played Mantis.
I usually, oh my god, that's not my fault.
Oh, unlucky.
Jesus Christ Oh my god Okay I'm mad to scenario Oh my god He's so low That's it We go in
Kill him We go in Fucking I can kill him!
I know they didn't have ults.
I am pro-locked.
Run them over!
That's the only thing I had.
I knew they didn't have support ults for that, so.
I don't know if you're fucking stupid or something.
I don't fucking know.
I hope the other guys...
Okay, guys, um...
Alright, I'll... I guess I'll...
Okay.
Alright, I'll come back.
Oh, Luna doesn't know it.
That's fine.
No, it mixed... Oh my god.
That was an accident.
I did not mean to...
wait oh my god please please oh my god oh my god i'm so scared i'm so scared jesus christ oh i knew it i knew this is weird i knew it
That was scary.
I hate triple support.
It's so boring.
It actually is so boring.
It makes me so sad to play.
I don't know, it's just so boring to play in general.
Okay, there you go.
Can you double my attention?
Oh.
Well, here you go.
Alright.
Oh Luna Luna Luna Luna Luna All right after this whoa Okay
Oh my god, okay, we didn't shoot it but that's my Luna Nice Oh my god Don't worry, I got you All right, they res born again It's okay.
I got you all try.
Oh, you needed heals, but it's okay.
I got you for real
Oh, I thought I miscounted that it's fine.
It's fine.
We're still on point.
Oh, we're all here Oh shit Where did he come from?
That's fine.
I didn't know where exactly he was.
All right.
There you go I ain't scared I ain't scared.
I ain't scared.
Holy shit, you're fucking crazy.
Oh, goodbye.
Good bye.
I gave you everything I own.
Holy shit.
All right, goodbye.
That was, yeah, no doubt.
Okay, I'm gonna get him.
All right, that's fine.
Watch this.
Oh shit, I was so close.
It was so close.
It almost worked.
Oh, unlucky.
I almost got her.
Okay.
I'm going back.
Please.
Just a little bit.
Nice.
Wait.
um strange and point that's fine oh he's still not killed how is he oh my god whoa how strange killing us wait where is he where the fuck is strange oh shit there he is oh my god he's one please i okay i i hit her but i can't be the only and i didn't uh Oh my god.
Thank god.
We did it.
Yay!
We did it!
Time to switch things up.
Including which side draw.
We're doing it.
We're not...
We're still doing it, but we're doing it.
Yeah!
Trying to keep damage boosted on me.
Who's that guy?
What if I come back in for heals?
Cool.
I could get a pick pretty easily.
I will do that.
They don't play enough at all.
Understood.
I'm communicating.
I'm doing it.
I'm being a team player.
NPC I might as well be an NPC I might as well I feel like an NPC this back and forth this fucking up back and forth with I feel like I should damage boost my phoenix but I'm like no ultran only bros gotta support's gotta stick together I feel like I'm not damage boosted by um I'm definitely not Not damage boosted by Phoenix at all.
There you go.
Get your stupid fucking damage boost, I guess.
Support stick together!
How dare they request for it?
Uh, yeah.
Oh my god.
Is he okay?
He's okay.
He's so okay.
He's so, he's so okay.
Oh my gosh, please.
I don't have, I don't have a lot of kills.
Alright.
There we go.
You got damage boost.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
Zzz.
There we go.
That's also why I damage boost Ultron a lot because I want him to have all of it.
Yeah.
Get all that damage boost you want, baby.
All right, here you go.
I could heal him, but then that's not as fun.
I'm gonna run out of them.
Oh, shit!
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
That's fine.
All right, nice.
I need these games.
After that last game I had, I'd play...
All right.
I have one leaf.
One whole leaf.
I know he had.
Oh, all right.
Goodbye.
Wait, what?
Oh shit.
That's fine.
Um, where am I?
Oh, where am I?
Oh my god.
Oh!
Holy shit.
I couldn't.
It's okay.
They don't need me.
did i go how did i how did i get to there it's only me it's only me i'm still like how did i get there i was literally i tp through their spotters oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa he's so i can touch harder and make them back up oh my god i could have i feel like from where i got you oh that's unlucky oh i have point i'm playing they have to back up for me okay back that's fine we have you guys have myself we have we can tp it's okay we have all right watch this
oh that's a little scary we do this where the fuck are we okay it's fine it's fine we're here i do this and then I go up here and then I do this and they can't do anything to me I'm on high ground I'm in dangerous look at that I'm helping oh shit I need goodbye goodbye that's unlucky it's okay I'm helping It's okay.
I'm hoping he doesn't know.
No.
They don't.
No, they're so dumb.
Who needs help?
Come back.
There they are.
Look at that.
It's that easy.
It's just that.
It's just that easy.
Look at that.
Yay!
Peek gameplay.
And then- Holds time.
Gamers don't look up!
Gamers just don't look up!
I'm just that good!
Riveting gameplay.
Look at that.
Oh wait, top tier, oh boy.
Hamakawa.
What the fuck was he playing?
Oh, it's Saloon.
What did she do wrong?
I don't even know what she was doing.
Oh, the strange.
Real ass fuck.
Jesus.
Alright.
Yay.
Okay, I guess I'll listen.
I'm just a sheet.
Yay.
No, boy.
Alright.
Yippee.
I play.
I...
Wait, what in all my games after?
the avoid you're so grandmaster sorry that's toxic uh that oh shit he's just like me right here
you know i'm the real trenches i'm gonna say that and i'm gonna derank to i i swear to god i can feel it i can feel myself deranking um deranking to uh grandmaster i can feel it right now it's gonna happen today on the stream i'm resetting my sleep schedule i need to reset it honestly it's so bad now it's so bad i have to fix it
get people to avoid good players oh yeah i should like before i like i should be like oh yeah avoid this cat he's so bad no but for real i have to fix it for real this time yeah i didn't i didn't eat one meal today i did order food um but i haven't really eaten it i ordered food like an hour ago like it's not really sitting there but it's not like it's just a sandwich
just a sandwich it's a bami just my bami sandwich um with the cold cuts I like cold cuts they're my favorite I also ordered a Vietnamese um chicken salad too mm-hmm
I love by me I do too Thanks for being here Dragon's It really means a lot I was feeling so down That's really so sad Because I really wanted the Top 500 badge for this season Because like I didn't really care for a while But then I saw the season's badge And I was like Oh I really want it It's like Lucky dragon Oh we not really Dragons aren't lucky But I have some experience,
but
but I was like, because I haven't, because I haven't, my year has been pretty fucked up because I have, I think like anything that could happen to me, happened to me this year in terms of like the wildest, craziest shit.
I've been actually thinking about go into a temple to cleanse my spirit.
Because like, because like things were fucking, you know, like the whole, you know, like the getting sick a lot, getting back to back sick.
And then also like flying through like crazy weather where I was like, being like, oh my God, am I gonna die?
Because I flew through like the big, the fucking hardest rain, like storm ever.
And also like we passed by a volcanic eruption and everything.
I'm like oh my god do I need to cleanse my spirit and I got scammed on my um um what is this my I got scammed out of my fucking CPU and got like some fucking random CPU card like not even a CPU I got I got scammed from my CPU and everything too so I'm like maybe this maybe if I get this badge my luck will change
But Gambo was not on my side.
It truly wasn't.
The game was like, let me give you all the worst possible teammates you could ever have.
I was like, okay.
That's okay.
Sure.
I guess I don't want...
I guess I don't want to have 500.
that's so stupid oh like right now like right now like right now just like this lobby oh just like this lobby
truly is beautiful
it was they cut up a piece of motherboard and it was like some fucking motherboard made from Venezuela with the chips still like it was like the the fucking seat like thing was still attached to the motherboard like
it was like literally they cut cut a piece of motherboard and then just put it in a CP in the official or it's like Costa Rica sorry Costa Rica not Venezuela Costa Rica sorry I was reading something up oh my god a bad Luna and Ultron fucking freaks Actual freaks.
That's like, I can play Invisible Woman.
Alright, here we go.
Actual freaks.
Oh my god.
And I get a magic?
Please, how much more do you want me?
They're like, how much more do you want?
Oh, wait.
Triple support?
You know you want to...
Um...
You know you want to play Adam!
Come on.
Oh my god, alright, never mind.
There's no triple support.
world still hasn't gotten old oh man it's fine i guess he don't want to he didn't want to
it's okay i won last game so it means like next game was supposed this game is supposed to be a loss oh okay i'm a good guy i'm solo support time.
It's solo support time.
It truly is pain.
Oh, nice.
All right.
Let's go.
Oh, yeah.
Learn how to B-hop in this game.
You know how to do it?
Just buy.
Oh, my God.
A pro.
I can't stop that.
That's actually Crazy.
Okay, maybe I can't.
Yeah.
Bro, I literally just...
Um, what do I do?
Okay, I come back.
I'm like, I brought literally crossed the fucking Nile.
Oh, my God.
They have...
They have fucking Widow.
I, like, crossed the Nile for this person.
And then he came back.
Yeah, it's the same way to B-hop in.
It's literally the same way.
same way oh you like see you can do it for it's like you just buy and scroll wheel and i realized i forgot to buy and scroll wheel oh my god what is our oh good luck what is our comp this comp fucking sucks hello hey guys oh nice no greens
i hope okay she is okay that's good i'm gonna say i hope the cloak is doing the rent oh my i jumped away and it still hit me where fuck me i guess i even jumped away i'm so sad i'm so sad i jumped away for that too oh nice we're running triple support Will triple support save us from this?
Will it?
Oh, we're about to find out.
Oh my god, our strange staggered so hard.
Alright, good luck.
You can have this shield.
Okay, don't peek my shield.
I won't use my shield as a shield, I guess.
The shield is optional, apparently.
Shield is optional.
Oh, guys!
Guys!
Guys, I-I-I cannot stop you at this point.
Let's go.
Get out.
I thought we were about to- You know what?
Fuck it.
Here, here, here, here.
Come on, come on.
We're in- Okay, um, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's okay.
Like, in our stream, just walks past my thing.
All right.
Nope, she's doing the bad thing.
Okay.
Let's go.
No, Loki fucking sucks.
It's- he's such a bad character to play now.
And so you're just like, whoa, Loki is so bad now.
It's working for them because they actually have a DPS that's just carrying.
them.
They have a DPS that's carrying them right now.
Like, I'm too scared to speak.
Like, we have what...
If we had Mag, it'd be different.
Like, look at what...
Look at what our Strange is doing.
Like, he's wasting...
He's wasting shields.
For some reason.
I'm gonna ult them here.
Like, I don't...
Bro.
Oh, my God.
No!
I'm Strange!
What?
Our strange doesn't play our strange does not play tank.
I Our strange doesn't play tank.
There's no way.
There's no way
What the fuck was that?
Why are you playing you're our only?
You're literally our only Oh my and he's very special guys oh my god okay that's fine
no i legitimately think this is not winnable it is not oh my god he was why was he flanking he was our he was our only front line
Oh, but not enough.
This is why I want to have a duo right now.
So I have more of Void Slots, honestly.
Oh.
There's nothing.
I winneth and I lose if they give if and take if wins away from me.
No, like everyone thinks that was fucking...
That was fucking weird.
Not playing this.
I'm playing Adam.
Fuck this.
It's not enough heals, but whatever.
It's absolutely not enough heals, but whatever.
If what I'm going to tank, I can play Invis or Cloak.
Buddy, I ain't tanking.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Alright, let's go.
Why?
No.
Oh, I guess both works.
Alright.
that's okay we literally you know what will work if we actually if we just have a venom that's it venom or ultra that's it oh okay nothing can save you okay there you go nothing can save us this is the hell we created.
Yeah, but we can easily...
All we need is just...
We just need, like, someone to...
We need someone to dive, the widow.
But we don't have anyone to dive.
Because they have so...
Their support lineup fucking sucks.
But we don't have enough damage.
There we go.
We don't have... There we go.
We live, look at us.
We're alive.
You're welcome.
We live a little longer.
We just don't have enough...
Okay, I'm fine with that.
I'm back in the bag.
He's still in the bag.
We just don't have enough damage to like...
We don't have enough damage output to kill them.
Because literally they're all...
I need to play this.
They don't have a lot of heals.
Loki's heals is so fucking garbage too.
All right.
That's cool.
That's cool too.
Hello everybody.
I'm not standing grouping up with you guys.
Hello, guys.
Wow.
Unfortunate.
It's okay.
You know what?
Good game.
Let's just stand here.
Look at that.
Look, I brought them all in here.
Oh, I'm dead.
I have no friends.
I don't.
It's a lonely world up here.
No friends.
Very lonely in this elo.
Literally, we just need someone to play.
Dive.
No friends online right now.
Nah.
It's just unfortunate.
You know what I'm gonna do?
Oh wait, I- yeah, I gotta avoid this guy too, the X-Men guy.
They- he gave it and take it away from me.
Oh yeah, we got boy.
What's his name?
This guy.
Also, oh my god.
Why are you in my elo?
Why are you here?
Get out.
uh i know one thing that always cheers me up though the one thing that brings me joy in this dark times is the fat friend family friendly role play
the family friendly role play will give me something Alright
Don't worry everyone Wait are they gamers?
Are they gaming?
Hello everyone Would you like to role play with me?
Hey guys Come on Hey Stop fighting everyone Yay
Stop fighting!
Alright, this is like the peace zone.
Hello, everyone.
Are we...
Did we all come here for peace?
Alright.
I'm here to bring peace to the world.
That's right.
I'm here.
Whoa!
Guys, what happened to peace and love?
Peace and love, everyone.
Don't worry.
Happy...
Was it... Happy birthday, Mr. President?
What was that song that Marilyn Monroe sang?
How does that song go again, chat?
When she...
Popped out...
Popped out of the cake?
that but with venom you know i'm pulling it up i gotta give oh look spider-man's joining in i'll give them a show whoa whoa whoa hey that was my health pack that's all that's my pay no no hey that's my pay that's my pay i worked so hard for that help pack all right here you go there you go gotta grab this hello don't worry i'm back she's back too she's like oh i'm back as well
oh nice there you go yeah
Yeah!
Oh shit!
Thank you.
I want it.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
It's a dinner and a show, everyone.
Dinner.
I still got it.
There we go.
Everyone gets a turn.
This is my favorite part about Marvel Rivals.
Where's the food?
It's Venom!
Because he's a snack!
I'm so tired.
Oh my god, we have a...
We have Spotty, man.
Shut up.
He's lunch, dinner, and dessert, exactly.
I need to fix my sleep schedule, so I'm just pulling on a liner.
I'm not going to stream all day, like, all, like, the whole night, or fucking morning.
I'll do a YouTube stream later, too.
I don't know what to stream on YouTube.
Maybe Silk Song.
I don't know.
I'll think about it.
Maybe I'll just do more Silk Song later today.
Or maybe I just keep streaming rivals who knows I know it's like the last it's the last day Of Marvel rivals so a lot of people are still Desperate right oh my god clear Thank you for the red Thank you thank you I hope you had a great stream For those who don't know me my name is Doki Bray I am currently doom queuing right now Because I've lost all hope in life And I've accepted that I can't make it to top 500.
So I'm hoping that I will ruin other people's chances of making it to top 500
But I'm still trying though, I'm still I'm still trying I'm just if I lose and they can't get top 500 Well, oopsie for them too bad for them, I guess After all these years 30 seconds before you attack That's the only thing that'll make me happy right now.
Knowing that other people are failing too.
Okay.
It's alright.
We're doing it.
I'm playing my absolute hard out.
Just if I lose, it's not my fault.
Like, I'm trying so hard.
I'm so many thank you for that gifted thank you for gifting us up It's just unfortunate, you know if we lose and they don't secure top 500 because now they know how I feel when I couldn't fucking secure top 500 despite trying so hard
Jesus Christ what the fuck is he okay?
All right, I think I can oh my god bro chill oh my god chill where's my other tank where did he go where did my other tank go holy oh there he is how did you get down here bro i'm confused how oh my god guys how are we still contesting this one area Here we go You know what?
Fuck this it weren't Fuck this Oh my god, I don't know how the fuck There we go.
Oh shit.
I don't know why she's all the way there too.
How are we struck?
Oh my god.
We don't have enough damage All right, I'm fucking I'm zooming out All right, it's fine.
We got that up I don't know how our luna was so was like on the right side oh that is a bm portal right there what they bubbled it they don't like how they actually this might be where we die i know i think
all right all right goodbye you know what would be cool we're right next to spot And so, you don't have to worry about anything.
Jesus, this is unfortunate.
I think maybe...
Guys, remember when I was like, Haha, there's...
Guys, I might derank.
I might actually derank.
There might be a chance that I might derank.
Goodbye.
It's the only way for me.
my team to win.
Oh my god.
Like, I'm...
Fuck this.
Get over here.
Walk into this.
Walk forward.
Oh, that's bad.
That sucks for me.
He was smart.
He used the invas to fucking all through.
Uh, no.
Y'all, they have the better players.
Oh, and then our...
They just have the better players.
It just truly is just one of those times.
They just, unfortunately, have better players than...
It's just a team diff.
There's, like, nothing we can do.
At least we...
Hey, we pushed it so far, though.
Okay, there you go.
Oh.
Oh, I got the shield.
Let's go.
Let's be through the shield.
Oh, that's fine.
I got you.
Oh, that's not fine.
Where is the hell?
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, it might be... Oh, never mind.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
But I have to be here.
I'm sorry I have to use this for it please I have to use it for this guy I'm sorry I don't know where he is where did he come from oh he flew up he flew up
yeah it's ring Celestial 3 which is one rank below top 500 but there is a chance that i might derank there's a very close possibility um that i might derank out of celestia i did sleep and it's well i woke up at 5 30 p.m and that's why i'm resetting my sleep schedule
What the fuck is going on in my chat right now?
Yeah, there's no hope of climbing.
But I'm here as long as other people...
As long as other people are also losing hope, that makes me...
That brings me joy.
I'm hoping I could drag someone that is top 500 right now and take them out of time.
That's my only wish.
I don't want much in life.
But with that, I would like very much.
I am an ELO terrorist today.
I'm still playing, I'm trying.
It's just, there's no luck by my side.
There's no luck on my side right now.
Four, three, two, one.
I have become a government agent.
That's fine.
It's just an...
Bro, okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I don't know how they live, but okay, it's working.
It's working, possibly.
Oh, never mind.
He's opening a portal.
Oh.
What?
Oh!
Hey, everyone.
Are we all having a grand old time?
Oh, goodbye.
Not for him, no.
It's okay.
I have one res.
One goodbye.
I have zero res.
It's okay.
I have now have zero res.
How do we not built anything out of that?
Oh, let's hope he lives.
Hello.
Can you kill one venom?
Oh my god, he lives.
He lives.
Oh.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, wait.
I want to rock it for you.
I'm rocket man for you.
What the fuck?
I went rockin' man, though.
Maybe?
I don't fucking know.
This is, like, the dumbest fucking...
You know what?
Fuck it.
Yep.
Okay, that was actually smart.
Okay, now it's gone.
Okay.
Stop my machine.
machine gun going.
Oh, there you go.
It worked.
I love false hope.
I love...
They just need to do one good all and we're fucked.
We're just fucked with one good all that's over.
It's so over.
There's no way they see this, right?
Oh, yeah, no, they do.
They absolutely
It's fine.
We we have Luna all at least.
Luna died first so she should have her out now.
Yeah
That's very unfortunate.
Hey, but at least we have Luna all right There was oh my god, that's funny.
She's fucking stupid Oh my god, okay, hey um Alright.
Hello.
I tried.
There are Luna and I have what?
Oh, she did not.
There was no hope.
He just slowly walking over.
It's never been...
Oh, hey, there's a portal.
That's fine.
I knew it was over here.
I didn't even realize there was a portal.
I didn't know there was a portal!
What the fuck?
I went back!
I touched the point for us.
I went to touch the point.
Like, what do you...
What do I do?
Nobody told me that we were portaling.
I literally was like...
I'm the only one that didn't die.
How is that my fault?
I didn't even realize we were portaling.
There were three of us up front.
And I was like, why aren't we touching the point?
All right, I touched the point.
Oh, no, I gave up.
It's fine.
He'll just avoid me.
I fucked up.
Like, I fucked up that entire game.
I was not the problem.
Oh, I made one mistake not knowing we were poorling.
Because nobody was communicating.
Like, I...
No one was communicating.
I was like, well, guess I have to touch the point now.
But, oh.
Because I didn't...
die and I was up front.
Finding someone, finding everything.
Like just one mistake.
Just because zero people talked.
And like, okay, wait.
Let's see.
Let's see here.
How the fuck did I have more?
Okay.
I'm not, I won't question it.
I will question it.
I'm like, how the fuck do I have more damage?
I was rocked for an entire round.
I was rocked for an entire fucking round.
But, oh, I'm the problem.
I have more heals.
No, it's because I was Invis.
Invis, you get more heals in general.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
or so, whenever you're ready, Yixie.
Are you on?
Alright.
Wait, what rank are you right now?
We're all in the trenches.
No, where she's not carrying.
Did she just saw what I saw, guys?
Did you not just see what I saw?
He's not carrying shit.
We're both gonna be suffering today.
We live in a society.
At least I'm doing win-loss, win-loss.
Also, yeah, you can do EUQ if you want.
I don't really care.
It doesn't really matter to me.
Don't worry.
I got some cash on hand.
Will anyone want him?
Hello.
Would you like to dance for me?
have dance emote.
Whoa!
Give me a heal.
Does she have dance emote?
Hello.
Do you have dance emote?
Where's my dance emote?
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Mama likes.
Yes!
Dance!
Oh my god!
Bleak!
Yeah, okay, I need heals.
This chip is gonna kill me.
I'm gonna grab some heals real quick.
And then...
Hello.
Alright.
Let's go back.
Let's go back to the real content.
I brought coins to the club.
That's right.
Wait, it should be here.
Yeah!
That's right!
Whoa!
It's not allowed!
Black Panther was like, no.
Not in my PG Christian server.
That was the pouncy.
I didn't even touch it!
I just, there's some coins!
That's not even touching!
Bro, no.
I didn't even touch!
He's like no fun.
Oh, is it this guy?
Get him out of here!
Get this guy out of here!
He shouldn't be here in this lobby.
I was respecting the dancers!
Hello.
Hello, ma'am.
There we go.
She knows what...
She does!
She sees me and then she just starts dancing.
I'm respectfully throwing the cash.
The fact that she instantly was like, Oh, yep.
I know what you want.
She was ready.
I told her to do what.
I just asked her to do.
Do you have the dance emote?
And every time she sees me, she knew.
She understood.
What, Chiro, do you think you want to be today?
That's a good dancer.
She wants that bag.
She knew I was carrying that bag.
She saw it.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
She a smart one.
She's a hard worker.
She works very hard.
Look, she could have not danced.
It was her choice.
And then she could have stopped.
She didn't have to keep dancing when she saw me.
But she still kept dancing.
So who's...
It's not my fault.
I'm just giving her what she wanted.
He's just trying to make it through college.
And I'm helping her.
I'm helping her get her degree.
Chat.
I'm so kind and generous.
Mm-hmm.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Yeah.
It's very selfish of me if I don't give her money.
I'll consider it.
I know.
I truly am.
Such a good person.
god damn cloak all right we all have lord surely
yeah it's yeah it's worse if i don't help someone in me are you really gonna have she'll drop out if it wasn't for my contribution to the club someone's gotta make a living wait did they ban jeff oh we did that we ban jeff okay i'm a console I truly am.
I'm ready to drive.
Oh yeah, when you are, you can do like very fast pehopping because of the momentum from her own.
So you can be like and like hop backwards and everything.
It's pretty neat.
Not gonna lie.
Fucking neat.
And I'll give him damage boost.
Oh, that's nice.
That's good.
Oh, that was so close.
Whoa!
Shit!
Oh my god, I almost got out.
I almost got out.
I did not think I was gonna get hooked.
That's unlucky.
Oh my, that's so unlucky that got hooked there.
There we go.
Oh, nice.
Oh,
he got lost.
That Hulk got lost.
Oh, my God.
Our Emma got lost.
Where's my star, Lord?
Where the fuck is my star, Lord?
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh, he died.
That's what happened to him.
Okay.
Okay, let's go.
Okay, let's not go.
Let's not go anymore.
It's damage boost!
Okay.
There we go.
Let's go.
I love it when I drive.
When I do the Mantis drive by.
Can I...
Kobe it?
I did!
Oh shit that actually worked I didn't think that would work, but I'll take it the fucking Kobe drive Kobe Oh shit Okay
Oh my god, I'm fucking backing up.
I'm not hitting headshots right now Their heads are too tiny
Nice Come on.
Let me add it.
Go in.
Oh my god.
Don't go in.
Don't go.
I went to win.
Oh my god.
He wants to grab me.
I'm scared.
There you go.
Go in.
I'm damage boosting.
Keep going!
It doesn't stop!
Boom!
I need that all charge.
Alright.
Am I?
Oh my god, he's gonna exile me, isn't he?
He's gonna... Nope!
Didn't exile me!
Alright.
Double.
Okay, I need...
Okay.
Oh, they're running double-triple support now.
They know.
They know it's our crutch.
They know we need this.
We need this so bad.
Oh, he has all doesn't he?
Um, it's okay.
It's not okay anymore.
They know.
We're on our triple support crutch.
How did they know?
It's like, yeah, I'm going in with my ult.
I don't understand.
How did they know?
Oh, my God.
Stupid.
That's fine.
Oh, my God.
He's so low.
Let's do this.
Oh, wait.
We can't.
We can't do it, JK.
Let's do this when our tanks are here.
All right.
Let's do this.
This is the bunny hop that I was talking about.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Oh yeah, no, he's dead.
No, he's still dead.
Oh my god, it's over.
They're going triple support.
They know.
We have the word.
The thing is...
Please, please, please shoot this.
Oh, thank God.
I'm trying.
You just know.
There you go.
Oh my God.
I gotta leave.
Oh, no!
I got...
Oh, nice.
Hello.
There you go.
Don't I got you!
Got you!
Nice.
We did it.
I told you I got her.
I told you!
I told you I got it.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
I'm just saying I'm just here.
I'm just here.
I just see red.
Just like the real mantis.
I just go.
I just see.
I just want to shoot.
I just go bam, bam.
Whop, whop.
Yeah, you see the button hop or the momentum after you're up?
You just go.
But you just find scroll wheel down for a jump.
That's it.
That's how you go so fast.
You can do it backwards too.
You can do this with all...
Yeah, it's literally just like Apex.
You just go...
And that's really it.
It makes you go so fast.
That's why I like...
That's why I run so fast.
Are they T?
Maybe.
What the fuck?
Do I hear?
just hear something you need to stop where the fuck is talking yeah who am I hearing is that rigsy it didn't show up in my thing what the fuck I don't think I can recall the voices why am I here I'm so confused I'm so confused why am i hearing voices right now i have nothing to run on i've been grinding oh my god is he open mic right now and vc is bugged like oh no we cannot we don't do enough damage our rocket died oh my god our rocket dc'd wait i do not have wait he's talking oh my god doom queue got me no my rocket i can't have good things anymore i have to swap off the worst part is that i have to swap off mantis oh my god oh he's back he's back
it's fine That's fine.
What is...
See how fast I go?
You see that?
Oh my god, I go too fast sometimes.
Oh my god.
You see that?
Yeah!
That's how fast you can go.
Yeah, you see that bunny hop?
Yeah, that's how fast I go.
Oh my god.
This looks big.
Oh, why isn't anybody walking?
Why isn't anybody walking?
That is a good question.
And then I leave.
Oh my god, I leave.
I can't leave.
all right that's fine we should have rocket out soon we can reset that's so weird that was so weird I like basically I hear racy talking to himself like I heard all voices and I got scared oh he just got back up there's like nothing we can do like they're just bear stuffing us like there's literally nothing we can do okay i can help him
hello now i come back down all right if we don't grab any kill we do where is this born again though play
there you go we have to do this there we go it was worth it It was worth it.
Don't worry.
We'll have Cloak soon.
So, Reggie, can I have my ace back?
Like, that'd be cool if you could let me have it.
You're an ace back.
I want to win back!
Oh, my God.
Who cares about an ace?
We want to win.
Oh, my God.
Just try to farm the headshots off this cat.
There you go.
Oh, look at that.
I got it back.
Okay, that's fine.
You heard that he's spinning!
Okay.
Look at him.
I already gave you enough.
Oh, my God.
You had so many leaves.
We got him.
Hey, look at that, Ricky.
Look at that.
It's just that easy.
For how long though?
That sound pressure.
I'm going to die.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Wait, me next.
I'll go.
I'll go, go, go.
Oh shit!
Look at him in the corner.
There you go.
We used everything.
Okay, we did not.
I don't know why we used everything.
I was like, I got this.
They're done.
Alright, it's fine.
Nice.
It's okay.
I got you all the leaves you want, baby.
Okay, goodbye.
She did not die.
I was lied to.
I was lied to and then I also got shot.
I got slapped.
Oh my god, thank you.
Oh my god.
My tanks are so dead.
You know what?
I'll die here.
I farm.
Oh shit!
No!
Oh, get me out of here.
Get me out of here!
Get me out!
I did not expect myself to be there.
Do we have anything?
At all?
Okay.
Don't worry, I got you.
Here we go.
Oh no, not boring again.
Wait, are we?
Is this winnable?
I don't think it's winnable.
It's not winnable.
It was definitely not winnable.
Wait, I had to tab out real quick.
Alright, there you go.
It's fine.
I still have my...
Wait, what?
Why?
Groot?
Groot, why?
It's fine.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we don't have to all of this.
Oh, yeah, we don't have to.
Oh.
Yeah, I was gonna say, we definitely don't have to use anything.
Okay, it's fine.
Double!
Alright.
Never surrender!
Okay, okay.
He...
I'm a little worried about her.
But that's okay.
It's fine.
We'll do this.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
You're crazy.
Oh, you guys are all fucking crazy.
I would like you guys to do.
Oh, we should have saved that.
They have lucky y'all now.
We needed to save that.
There was no...
Oh, oh, no.
I cloaked.
die oh no okay i could have died that's bad okay i gotta focus up now i have focus up i can't around
oh i'm dead nope he has all that's okay yeah he had all okay
we have we can't okay I gotta save it okay oh my god I don't think I can build all the time I knew oh my god nice all right focusing up now all right Yay!
Locked in!
I locked in.
I locked in for that.
I don't remember your name.
As long as you're not changing.
No, it's rank.
It's crazy to say that this is the second highest form of ELO.
Because it's right below top 500, I think.
That's the saddest part.
This is...
It is literally right below type 500.
It's like top a thousand, I think.
Yeah.
54 assists?
I mean, we all got a lot.
Look, see, 42, 46.
We all contributed.
Yeah, I made five.
No, I made six people drop you, though.
That's the best part.
Wait, let's see.
Let's see if anyone do rank.
today we should avoid this person okay what about you what about you let's see oh you're not you're not securing top 500 my friend You ain't securing shit.
I'm not.
This guy's trying to secure it right now.
You ain't securing top 500 today.
Alright.
I'm at you.
Oh, he's just been screaming.
Look at this nerd.
Alright.
Nice.
We're all here to suffer.
oh my god this was a gm lobby what the how the hell am i in i just realized we're in the gm lobby except for that one guy that's trying to get top 500 all right oh i got it's time i gotta fund my lifestyle it's crazy marvel rivals rivals just wait where are they where are the friends hello hello wait are we all fighting oh my god we're all having a bra right now
See, I did it.
Peace established.
I did it, guys.
I brought world peace.
I did it, everyone.
I solved it.
This dance, the power of dance.
Dancers in the background of old fighting games.
Yeah.
I deserve a Nobel Peace Prize.
They stopped dancing the moment.
But they're about to be removed.
I was like, what?
I just got in.
Now I'm about to be removed from the game.
I don't understand.
We have a penny.
We have...
So we have no front line.
I got it.
They give us and take us.
I'm about to be removed for being a goddamn free.
Sorry, guys.
I'm an invisible woman.
Sure.
Or Angela.
Thank you very much.
That's fine.
Oh shit, this is EU.
Fuck, okay.
But very much, very, very much.
Okay, we're in EU lobbies right now.
I did say I'm okay with EU lobbies.
I did say that, I know.
What about Emma?
They already banned Torch, so it's fine.
Really nothing we have to worry about.
um what we're gonna run triple support guess with luna um oh i guess guys all right let's try all right let's see if i can do mantis with 160 ping i've never done it before so it's gonna be a fun time
come on come on do something Pick a support.
Come on.
Do something.
Do you want to play Mantis?
Come on.
All right, I don't fucking care.
All right.
What the fuck?
rocket oh my god we're not getting healed all right let's hope we kill them faster all right is jeff open yeah no um our adam should be it we need we need uh mantis over jeff oh that's true okay if all hells fails i'll play jeff if i realize i can't hit anything which most likely would It might be the case.
Yeah, personally, I think one doom is way more than enough.
Where are we?
Oh.
Yeah, I think I'm going to be the one that can't hit shit.
Oh, my God.
This is hell.
Okay, I'm going to go Jeff.
Actually, I can't.
Fuck, I can't even go Jeff because...
Oh, my God.
This is hard dive.
Oh my god, ring around the rosy Ashes, ashes, ashes, we all fall down
Oh my god, oh this is hell No, we got rid of Invis too Holy fuck, okay I have to play cloak, I cannot I can't play Mantis against that.
That's too much.
That's actually too much.
There's a slight Lipsy, you think?
No, there isn't.
Okay.
Oh, no, Rigsie.
Alright, the fact that we got rid of Envis lets them a fucking strong-ass dive so that's like the only issue dive is very very scary right now
all right
good luck to us good luck holy fuck
Oh my god.
I don't know how I got here.
But hello everyone.
Hello.
Okay, there we go.
I...
That was stressful.
That was very stressful.
That was incredibly stressful.
I got to make another beacon.
I...
That was not fun.
Guys, I don't think we're winning this.
I legitimately don't think so.
Because of how unfun that is.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, we're dead.
I'm dead.
sorry let me be more specific i'm dead okay at least a good thing is that um is that we're running triple support we're running zero support we're oh shit he took it he took the heels he took the heels that i needed okay how adam bro okay Okay, how Adam got zero kills?
This is hell.
It is absolute hell to play against.
It actually is.
Oh my god.
It's like your new cat.
There's nothing.
It's actually absolute hell to play against this.
That's how.
Oh my god, I'm trying.
Don't worry, Rigsie.
I am absolutely trying.
You're right now.
Do you not see what we're going through?
Okay.
The whole team is diving.
Exactly.
Okay.
I am hoping...
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
I hope that our Adam plays for Rez.
Because it will be a very unfortunate if our Adam does not...
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Alright, Adam's dead.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please tell me.
Can you just tell me there's a...
Oh my god, I'm still here!
Control lost, but our jeff has spirit.
No, this is absolute hell.
There's like four divers.
what was that adam res he did not play for res i don't know how he doesn't know how to play for res i i don't understand i really all he has to do is no we need that penny that penny was clutch like three people were just running at us i should have went to the rocket but to be fair we were like super split up there that was uh like we should not split up but like we were like not okay the support backline was so fucked up because we don't have an invisible to push the thing is we bad invisible women for the angela and because we bad the invisible women we don't have like a good dive counter got it so we did it for her and it fucked us over
yeah no he should have swapped off a long time ago oh i mean running to i mean they're running to to as well and so the only issue is that okay i need him i'm just gonna i'm gonna be here i'm gonna be here i'm the mines are my safe place i shall i shall live in the mines
Like, if I see them diving, this is where I'll live.
Like, they don't have frontline, but they're so...
Like, we don't have peel.
Yeah, that's the thing.
It's just...
They don't have frontline, we don't have peel.
It's just unfortunate.
It's just the best of...
The worst of both worlds.
Jesus Christ.
Wait, what happened to the mines?
Please tell me I can't risk No I don't Mr. Broken Bond Thank you for the Five Gifts and Sows Thank you Thank you I didn't even know I didn't know He was back there But I'm coming over That's so unfortunate I was getting like Shot in the back And what can the rocket do Absolutely Are you serious?
Oh my...
Like, where do I go?
Can't
go anywhere!
I can't!
Okay.
Literally nothing I could do.
I was just trying to heal our penny as much as I can.
My time to shine.
Oh my, that's smart.
That's so smart, though.
I mean, I can go in with my love.
I gotta wait for our penny.
Oh, never mind.
We don't go in with the other.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Are we still...
Are we still in it?
We're still in it.
We're not in it anymore.
We're not in it.
It's just...
This is just hell.
I don't know what to do.
It's just hell.
Like, what do we do?
Alright.
I think we have to play.
We have to play, Jeff.
There's nothing I can do.
Like, I'm literally just getting touched.
I don't like it.
My name's Jeff
The stuff we do Oh my god Oh my god please Oh
I forgot they have panther I forgot they have panther Oh my god that's like my only counter That's actually so that sucks I legitimately Oh
That's literally my counter.
I forgot they have Jeff.
Because...
I'm not Jeff.
I forgot they have a Panther.
Panther counters, Jeff.
Jesus Christ.
That's unlucky.
They were just hard countering us.
I can't live as Cloak because there's just...
as Luna because three people were running at me.
It's because we banned invisible women for Angela.
If we didn't ban Invis, this wouldn't have been so hard.
That's our only problem.
We banned invisible women.
Invis would have saved us because Invis is a good dive counter.
We've got Invis.
Like I could just up here what the fuck how did it get here what the fuck why did it instantly put me in doom i didn't click anything how did i get here oh my god it's a ghost how the fuck did i get here
i sent got sent back to the homeland oh i didn't have it god damn Oh, it's because Rigsie sent me here.
Oh, there's a duo.
Oh, my God.
Everybody's fighting.
I didn't want to play.
I thought I had to watch the sensory deprivation chamber.
Whoa.
Hey, I'm peaceful.
Why are Europeans not peaceful?
What?
In the NA lobbies.
Everyone was so nice.
guys why did the europeans hate peace they hate it what happened to peace and love
mine is just like a bunch of oh my god look it's the boys
did you see that that's crazy it's a gang and it's a fucking gang fight right now three black panthers versus versus one angela oh my god
that's the boys are like me and my boys
best god must fear hello are we peaceful i don't think that guy is peaceful that i'm gonna steal a kill
my kill god that ping is crazy hello does anyone have a dance emote because i've got some money to spend whoa i've got some money i got paid today.
PuffBuy!
Thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you!
Alright, what server?
I think...
Is this...
No, this is NA.
No, this is EU.
Never mind.
I don't know why I saw Chinese characters.
I'm like, I'm an NA.
I don't know!
I was just like, I'm like, what are you doing here in Europe?
Another Angela?
Now, who am I gonna banish from this match?
that's fine i'm putting support so it's doable
i'm not banning it we have a hello player
just i yes and no i'm glad i needed a lot of angeles need you yeah for sure i mean i just get if you if you were actually i just pretty good you actually know how to play but like i said situational too with angela and shit incredibly situational to play um tab out real quick yeah here we go here we go
the right heroes could make all right
working okay what if i'll go luna like the moon this is a stupid top rocket jeff i don't think rocket does enough healing i don't know i mean it would be ideal if i play mantis but i just don't think there's enough healing in lunar jail i'm just gonna put it on oh never mind oh warp if we lose it's just well i'm yay i'm gm guys i did that we're climbing but backwards i did say today's doom queue hours so this is the moment of truth guys this is this is the moment Minotrute.
We made it to GM.
If we lose this.
We're running out.
Oh my god, we have no front line.
We have the perfect support cop.
I think you're probably going.
I'll fucking bubble you in shit.
Oh yeah.
You're trying to take it.
No more, no more, no more.
Speak your ass.
Whatever you did.
You're huge.
This is hell.
This is actually hell.
This is...
Bro!
There isn't no more!
This is hell!
No bubble.
You need to chase them.
Oh my god.
This is hell to heal.
How about Adam?
Okay, it's fine.
It's not fine.
i'm gonna die no front line is actually so it's so hard it's actually so hard uh not having a front line i can we can touch for a bit what the happened i need to go touch and then i can come on i'm back
Wait, what happened to the Jeff?
Okay.
Oh.
One field, one field, one field.
I don't think he's one HP anymore.
Oh my god.
The no front line is very, very high.
Oh my god, I might die.
Oh my god, please shadow.
Whoa!
Get me out of here.
Give me up.
Do we have front line now?
Do we have front line?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
No, we don't.
We still do not have front line.
This is so hard though.
Like, it's fine if it's attacked, but we're in defense right now.
So this is a very scary.
This is very...
Jesus Christ.
I guess I dropped down too.
I'm stalling him so I can't fight.
Oh, how now.
Oh my god, I can't do it.
anything oh my god it's fine it's fine it's fine i come back i couldn't press q oh my god
that's unlucky
oh that's unlucky three more times i think it's gonna work
I think she has remote control over the key.
Oh, I would love to have like a shield, you know?
That would be cool.
Okay.
I'm here to save.
Don't worry.
I'm a...
I'm no longer a hero.
Don't worry.
I'm no longer... I'm fucking play...
I'm not playing Luna into this.
This is...
This is too hard.
This is too hard to play Luna into this cap.
This guy's... GM is looking mighty and...
It's just mighty tempting right now.
GM sure is looking at...
Oh gosh.
I can't do anything.
Oh.
There's just no front line.
I can't play Luna into this.
I'm just gonna play I freeze them, but it doesn't matter Pick those to play here.
I'll be honest
Like I we have oh man That's unlucky like legitimately it's just the fact that We have the DPS line The DPS line the tank the support line We just we just don't have the one thing that matters the most the tank line
you know what can bubble that mag
a mag can bubble that i have a when you're gonna shuffle so i can like actually try to bubble it you wouldn't see me again Oh my god, the mag would, I just think we just don't have.
All right, here we go.
All right.
No more close, no more close.
He's beating.
You need to chase him.
I guess next.
One of you, one of you.
They're down through, they're down.
Start over here.
Oh my god.
This is, okay.
No more, no more, no more.
I have to use that to stabilize too.
That's the worst part.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Get me out of this hell.
I tried.
Yeah, no, this is a doom queue.
True, you cool out that you do that.
The current score is 0, 2, 3.
All I'm going to say, they are trying so hard.
I mean, this is a perfect cop for attack.
But this is a terrible cop.
know that you're gonna hold that this is a terrible cop for defense there's no way
there's no fucking way what did i do wrong excuse me i froze the captain four times for us oh sorry maybe i should have frozen every time they dive us bro what the is wrong you should not you don't deserve the name you You don't deserve this twilight name.
You actually don't deserve it.
30 seconds before the attack.
Jeff, do you have a microphone?
No,
the thing is, he is a support player blaming me.
Even though, yeah, I didn't queue that one fight because I didn't think we would need it.
Yeah, because it was just me and him.
Why the fuck would I sew the wall for us too?
When you could, you know, fucking just peel.
That's fine.
It's fine.
He's playing because he won't stop 500, and I'm denying that from him, and I'm fine with that.
I'm fine denying that.
I'm fine.
You probably like fucking kill me.
That's five.
No, I can't play it again.
I don't think any one of us can play it again.
I'm gonna die.
I'm not gonna spend the rest.
Jesus, guys.
I feel like if we just go name more, then maybe it'll work.
Look, I'm belong.
What's the fucking DPS of white?
Nice, walk, walk, walk, I'm going, I'm going.
All right.
We walk, I guess.
I mean, fucking, nice.
Go, Lord.
Walk one.
Walk literally one, hold literally one.
Hold literally one.
All right.
I wish we could get him for you, bro.
I don't have both.
What am I doing?
Oh, my.
What the fuck?
Where is that whale?
Clear the way.
Alright.
There we go.
Goodbye.
It's okay.
Then I can feel the joy of ranking it back to Celestia.
At least I can feel the joy, you know, of coming back to Celestia.
It's okay.
For like 30 seconds.
You know.
Everyone look up.
No cooldowns.
Bro, please.
If we do not kill him after that.
Go this guy.
This guy really wants to win.
He doesn't know.
Oh, man.
Wait, why?
What the fuck is that?
He went like...
Holy shit, where did I go?
No, I might be.
I might be a bastard.
I might be a bastard for that.
What happened?
Did he jump off the map?
Oh, man.
Oh, guys, I just don't think I think it's just over no i think this entire team was just
goodbye i think it's just
i need to know what he's fucking huffing right now i don't want to know what he's smoking i i need Yo, what the fuck is he smoking?
That is the highest form of copium I've ever had.
That appeared cop at this point.
It doesn't have a hat to do that.
He will cope right now.
No, no, no, no, no.
I beg, please.
It's over.
This is pure passion.
Actual passion right now.
Holy shit, that's some good ass tracking.
Jump up, jump up, jump up.
I don't get up so easily.
Bro, bro, really wants bro he's scoping so high he really is oh my god and we fucking oh my god how did he know how did he know damn hey guys what the hell is this game i might be gm i just have a door on my team title to deny now and then we'll come back to gm It's like I never lived.
Yes, boy.
What the fuck?
How do I win these games?
He's crashing out!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, he's crashing out.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't think he's happy.
I don't think he's happy.
Wait, he's...
get sick.
I think...
He's actually crashing out.
That was me.
That was me before my stream.
Well, it wasn't...
I don't even... Oh my god, we already been... Oh my god, it's been three hours?
This does not feel like three hours.
Holy shit.
I didn't... This does not feel like three hours.
I told you.
I told you it was your doom queue out.
I don't know what else to do.
Oh my god.
These games are cursed for.
He's not okay.
It does not feel like three days or three hours.
I'm having a good time.
I don't know about my duo partner, but I'm having a good time.
I don't know what to play.
Why?
Actually, I do know what to play.
This is the life of the Doomers.
Yeah, just wish.
Hey guys.
I felt like I have an impact.
But I don't know what to do.
To make a difference.
Wait, come on.
Oh, hey, you want to...
Hey, Jeff.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Freak!
That's right, you freak.
That's right.
Eat ass, skate fast.
And the Thor was like, fast!
That's right!
Yeah!
The Thor was like...
No!
Bad dog!
Because you don't have infinite fucking healing there.
What the fuck is Rix?
He's still going at it is he fast eat ass cake fast that's the thing right is that what isn't that this is that the thing all right hello there sir hello there there hello there whoa that's fuck bro that's Alright, whoa!
That sword's my bouncer.
He's my bouncer.
Hey there.
Bro, bro.
Hey.
I need my bouncer.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Pop, pop, pop.
Maybe it... Okay, if I find Orixie's the only Celestial 2 now.
Maybe the games would be easier.
Do you think you would be today?
Maybe the game...
Oh!
Maybe go back to NA.
I think the EU games are...
I think the EU games...
I think EU games are more cursed than NA right now.
Maybe we should go back to NA.
I think the worst games I...
got were you right now
no no definitely definitely I think I got worse NA team costs were not as bad as this
but yes if anyone else wants to play with me any other high rankers and you're like almost top 500 or you're like there I am willing today's the day today's the day you want to play with me and you're almost top 500 or you're there today's your lucky day you're very lucky day
oh no sh sh you will have fun well i will have Have fun.
Sorry, correction.
I will have fun.
I won't play this.
I won't play it.
Oh, fuck.
I should play Nuna for the Black Panther.
Do not fall for the Elo assassin trap.
What are you guys talking about?
It's their lucky, lucky day.
Superpowers are amazing.
Any solo cures?
looking for a duo?
I've already I've already ruined two duos in the span of 24 hours.
I don't mind adding another.
Oh no, Gomez crashed out too.
I have like freedom from his chains.
All you need to do is Capture the mission area.
Got it?
Today's your lucky day.
I'm looking for new duos.
He was top 500.
It was a good...
Good effort.
There
you go.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
I mean, I got the freeze, though.
So, like, I did my job.
Wait, how do we not have what?
Oh, that's bad.
I don't smoke.
Alright.
The only thing that sucks is that...
Oh, my God.
It's that they're running.
Never mind.
They're running triple support.
That's pretty bad.
Oh, wait.
Iron Man?
Okay.
That's fine.
I was gonna sit.
Oh my god, thank god.
I literally just started my...
Oh, hello.
Nippy.
Oh my god, hello again.
Alright, let's just dance, I guess.
Oh my god.
There was no way I can fix that.
What the fuck?
How did he...
Alright, it's fine.
Wait, there's a sidewalk there.
It's okay.
The top 500 rank?
I can fix that.
The badge is not that cool anyway.
You don't need that badge.
Come on It's not as cool as you think you guys
You know what sucks is because I fucked up a little bit because
Because Goodbye hello yeah Okay, I have plaque now
I have clap now.
I was going to say they have sila.
Oh, and I don't have clap.
I was worried.
I can't use clap because, like...
Oh, wait, I can use clap.
JK!
Oh, Sherpa doesn't even play, right?
Can he play rivals anymore?
He only plays when he's sponsored.
He's a deadlock the gamer now he's back on the deadlock grind okay
I'll try to cloak off okay just oh I'll just say oh I tried to kill cloak all okay sure yeah apparently they did a huge update on deadlock so everyone's playing that again.
I don't need it.
What do I just get the next?
I'll just get the next one.
That one's shaped like an ass.
And then people will say, oh my god.
A little bit of encouragement before the game, you know?
Damn, Europeans are fucking freaky.
I use clap, we're gonna die.
We're so fucked.
Oh, I jump over fire.
We're okay.
I don't know how he lives, but we're okay.
I thought he said he didn't kill it.
He lied.
Let's go.
He fucking lied.
We used three.
Oh, okay.
We used a lot.
We used four else.
He lied.
He told me he could do it.
Where was my all the where was my cloak kill?
What was your point?
I mean, at least they wasted it.
I'm in danger.
I'm in an og.
You know?
That's the little things in life.
Alright, fuck it.
I want all charged.
Fuck it.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Thanks for the shield.
I don't have to be center stage.
Jesus Christ, I have to reload.
I like, he's like, killed me.
And I'm like, bro, you're up top.
How am I supposed to heal that?
Are they high ground?
What are they doing?
What is their plan?
My guy's been like chilling for a while.
Oh my god, this is bad.
This is bad.
This is so bad.
This is okay.
Oh my god, where am I?
Where am I?
what happened okay it's fine at least I got all charge oh my god he survived good for him okay I have all here that's good I think they have cloak up so I'm gonna be careful here oh yeah no they absolutely have cloak up now He knows I clap too.
He knows I clap my hands.
There it is.
Alright.
Are we gonna...
Are we gonna kill this?
There we go.
Can we kill this guy?
Okay, wait.
Do you live?
Wait, we let her live?
Holy fuck.
We actually let her live.
Did I have a TP?
Oh, yeah, I have a TP.
Is he gonna stop it?
Oh my god!
Legend!
He didn't stop it.
It's a good effort.
Hello.
I'm in here.
Yay!
Where did he go?
There we go.
Oh, we win.
JK, we win.
We can keep EU.
We win.
EU stays.
Oh my god, the great dumbass.
Thank you for...
for the hundred and fifty dollars donation thank you thank you i really appreciate it thank you so much bye doki okay what did he play okay bye bye i don't know what the do i say okay
uh less paying out from eu frankfurt or warsaw all right let's see uh oh yeah it's mid-autumn festival yeah it's like a long break for everyone um frankfurt 154 frankfurt is the lowest there you go i have tried deadlock i'm just dumb i'm not too dumb for it because you have to oh the issue is it about it is that you have to like change your builds and everything um depending on the situation and i'm too stupid for that i can like you know i'm a hero shooter type of person so like you know i don't mind you know like i just swap oh this character counters that character but then for builds it's so much more complicated because there's so much like so many different items and everything and even though you have like this little guide and stuff like it's still like so complicated to like understand um but it's just i never played a moba before like deadlock was my very first technical technically deadlock was my very first moba to learn but even then i was just like so confused even with
the guides in it Like with the little, like, you know, like the, the builds that you can follow.
And I was just like, I don't fucking know how to do builds.
Like, I don't know when to swap my items or sell my items.
And also, also the one thing I hate about MOBAs is that the, the fucking beginning part of the MOBA is so boring.
You just look at each other and shoot at creep.
Like for like 20 plus minutes.
I'm just I just I just so boring.
It's just so The laning phase I just I'm so I'm just it's so slow.
It's a very slow It felt it feels like when you get to the actual action when you get your build like you know You can finally kill people.
It's fun.
I because I played deadlock I did I tried it out and it's fun But then when you're in the laning phase and you just stare at each other and you just like, I can't kill you yet.
Hello, sir, sir.
Hi there, sir.
We can't kill each other yet.
So let's just look at each other and be like, Tee-hee, what if I steal your creed?
And then you can't do anything about it because I have better ping than you.
Ha-ha-ha.
And that's just so fucking stupid.
I hate it.
I fucking hate it.
Oh, you try to get closer to me?
Let me stand behind my little tower because I'm a bitch boy.
Because I'm a fucking coward little pussy boy.
Like if you do one damage to the enemy team during the lane phase, they fucking hide behind a stupid fucking tower.
And it's so boring.
It's so goddamn boring.
yeah i'm that's why that's why deadlock is uh not for me i don't i don't know maybe in the future uh but like for now i just the laning phase is just oh the laning phase is oh i'm too fucking i i cannot i don't have enough patience for it i really don't and also like apparently changed a lot of stuff um because i found out like if you played it before the big update um and then try to play again they keep you at the same rank so like if you don't know like the new because like apparently they changed a lot of stuff so like a lot of characters have new alts and like different abilities and everything and um and so but you still keep your rank from before the big change
It's like You could get absolutely fucked If you come back And you're like, I forgot to play Because there's no quick play It's just ranked Oh no, there's no I know there isn't DK Because Because like One of my friends played it again And then they got put into like And before they were like the third The fourth ranked though two of my friends two of my friends one was like the third highest rank and the other one was the fourth highest rank and they recently downloaded the game to play again and they were put in that same lobby like it did not decay so I was like oh it sucks to be you I guess it sucks to be both of you because I was watching one of my friends play it and they were like they used to be the third or fourth highest rank and they were getting yelled at non-stop by their teammates because they were like
They were, because they're like, why are you in this ELO?
And then my boyfriend was like, I don't understand.
I can't kill anything.
Everything is so different.
They're like, I'm fucking, I don't remember what they were playing.
Blah, blah, blah.
It's feeding his ass out.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Oh, maybe I should have taken you out.
I don't know This doesn't seem ideal Because oh there you go We have a tank player I was gonna say
Remove EU from the rankings From the From the server I was gonna be like This looks scary
Uh Akam Akam Thank you for the tier 1 sub Thank you Thank you, monster.
Thank you for the tier one so thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much
All right, it's time It's time Charles would be proud Eric you've come so far Bum bum bum bum
the battle starts in five four three two one all right let's go
all right come on i got you luna oh my god who's got the rest of that team
oh my god is everybody okay god i hate I am Groot.
I am Groot.
Jesus Christ, how did he get here?
Is everybody okay over there?
There you go.
Use this.
Oh, I missed the pull.
I thought I got it.
What the fuck?
Oh shit!
Oh!
I did not expect them to show up.
I was like, what's that?
Oh.
That's fine.
We're so safe.
I.
No, we were so close.
I'll just stay here
Oh wait
Oh wait Oh shit I fucked up I fucked up I fucked up I was about to push it Mission failed Oh I fucked up there
Mission failed My fingers was lagging behind My brain That would have been funny if I got it though That would be pretty fun It's okay We'll get him next time
Oh my god Yeah I knew he Yeah I knew he
Okay.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I almost got it.
I was trying to save him.
I tried my best to save him.
Hello?
I died!
Oh, man.
I wish someone stole hella from him.
That's such a good name.
That's actually such a good name though.
Oh my god.
I almost killed my buddy
I want to ult this so badly, but I know that Jesus Christ like
The least Where is the dark chat There you go
I couldn't figure out where it was!
I was like, where could it be?
Oh my, I'm so sad.
I'm so sad.
I was like trying to put a shield.
It's like, I'm safe.
Don't worry, sweet child.
I'm safe now.
I was not safe.
Unfortunately, sweet child was not safe.
Okay, they have grew up.
I'm gonna try and oh wait, I don't know if My Okay, I know they have grew up though.
Let's see if I am ready to go back on go How the fuck did it?
Oh Good luck everyone I'm very scared about that grew up.
Oh wait, never mind.
I guess I'm very scared about
Oh My It's five holy shit.
It's okay There's still a group out though
Oh, I'm sorry, buddy There's nothing out.
Oh Oh my god What do I do?
Guys, please!
I'm so scared.
Where do I even go at this point?
Like, guys, where are we fighting?
Oh my god, that was nice.
Okay, we can finally push up.
We can finally push up.
Thank god.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna let our Luna build all now.
Because I know...
I know.
I know there's gonna be a Groot ult.
But not today!
Not today!
I'm gonna let my...
Okay.
Maybe they can't shoot that.
Who knows?
I'll push the card.
I want my Luna to build up.
See, I'm a team player.
The moment the Groot...
The moment the Groot ults us and then the Iron Man ults too, they're fucked, but that's okay.
At least I pushed the point know yeah i'm doing there they go don't worry i'm i'm shooting it there we go
this is where i know oh oh oh oh oh where he i'm a hero i don't know who i oh oh Shit!
Oh my god, she's still alive!
Holy shit, she's still alive.
Guys, please don't stand next to the gruel.
Oh my, oh my god.
Okay, I did it.
I don't know how.
I don't.
Oh my god.
I farmed so much all charge.
okay okay i almost have alt again that's crazy that's how much alt charge i i farm
okay oh my i'm gonna use it i'm gonna use it here the moment i get it the moment i'm oh my god let's go where am i
That's right.
Where am I?
Yeah, I'm on a user risk because I'm doing them in U-player.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the back.
Good.
Now you see me.
Now you don't.
That's right.
You see that mag?
He's like, where did she go?
The mag was trying so hard to find me.
She's like, where did she go?
She was just there.
That's right.
This is how I like invisible woman wear.
I feel like more freedom playing her compared to the other supports.
I just feel...
It's just...
I don't know.
I can try less, I guess.
I think that's it.
I don't have to really aim.
Playing Invisible Women.
Because Luna, you gotta hit like all the freezes.
You gotta hit all the freezes.
You gotta clap.
You gotta save your clap for important.
Me just go.
He, he, he.
I, I left click.
And then he, he, he.
I press shift on, cool down.
He, he.
I put that he he and then when people know I go I put shield up it's just so much easier it's just a lot easier to handle and then I know so let me just oh I know oh my god okay this is bad does that look at that so easy oh look at that and then who's shooting at us and then i pull her back see it's just that easy and eliminated god has a worthy sorcerer luna's too much work i'm lazy now
I'm so lazy now.
Sorry, I used to be Celestia.
I peaked Celestia 2 in this season.
I actually, I peaked one of above all, but not.
Oh my god, oh he is.
Oh my god, it's okay.
We go in!
Let's go!
Oh my god, I didn't think she also had a...
Oh my god.
Look at that.
See?
Just you just just like that just like that Yeah, more effort than rocket
This meter has a person that would bottom 500 player What do you mean?
I am not that toxic I don't say anything in VC I We're so dead.
We're so dead.
We're so Goodbye, friends.
It was nice knowing all of you.
I don't say it to their faces.
If they check back the bot, that's on them.
That's on them.
If they check the bots.
But, like, look, it's like our own, you know, it's our own private time, you know?
Like, oh my god.
Oh, what did my lord do?
Oh my god, we both died.
Okay.
I thought my Luna was with me.
Oh, that sucks.
We're not here.
Can't touch.
Oh, we fucked up the pre-contest.
We can't touch.
I don't think so.
I don't think we're touching now.
Yeah.
Goodbye, everybody.
You guys can go the long...
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I was gonna leave them.
We all came...
Okay.
because they have the combo.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Do we...
Do we kill anyone?
Oh my god.
They killed our Luna.
Oh my...
Guys, I'm scared.
I don't know how to get out of here.
I...
I don't...
Alright.
Yeah, both of us just got snapped.
I want to let our...
Luna build up, but I don't know where our Luna is.
Oh, she's here.
Okay.
I'll just top her off.
Oh, yeah, they definitely do.
The only thing we can do is we don't group up, but, like, this is very hard.
Alright, this is what we do.
Okay, I might have ulted early, but I got very scared.
I heard the dark child.
Where did the dark child go?
Jesus Christ that's he's looking for it.
He is.
Oh, that's the dark child was there.
I see him.
I see him He doesn't know I'm here He doesn't know they don't know See it's so easy
Hey guys, I'm a little scared here okay our Luna's struggling right now but like like it's understandable like I I can't like let her heal more because like there's the screw and the screw is scaring me like like look at my look at my teammate look at my team like the moment I stopped healing like they're so low so fast so I'm trying okay now I can heal now I can heal okay oh that was up for a minute oh shit okay um okay that's good oh that is not good oh my god oh my i almost got out i was so close oh that's so unlucky if i got out okay wait i do have a this is winnable this is winnable i do have a we can touch it We can touch it.
We can touch it.
I have a...
Okay.
We got him.
Okay, we're dead though.
Oh!
He found me!
How did he find me?
I... Oh, what?
She just wasn't even looking at me.
This is bad.
This is actually...
lose a book because of the magic and the group okay they're they're building a lot of well this
is actually pretty loseable I'm just gonna I'm healing bottom I assume that yeah I need all the charge too girl we're competing
Arluna!
Oh, that's unlucky.
I don't even know what happened to me.
Like, what the fuck?
Okay, I have a...
Where is she?
Okay, I have to use this to stabilize.
But the only issue is that Groot absolutely has all that after.
Woo-hoo-hoo!
Woo-hoo!
I live.
I don't know.
We'll live this.
No, we're not.
We will not live this now.
The best thing I can do is perhaps keep each other alive.
Oh my god!
Oh, I almost killed the Luna!
Oh!
Oh, we're stacked.
We're so staggered now.
Oh, that sucks.
I almost killed our Luna What the fuck?
Oh So close.
This is actually a lot scarier now
I Think our Luna Alted that way too soon I was hoping my alt I used my alt as an engagement Hoping that we could grab kills, but we couldn't do it.
I don't know why our Luna ulted.
I think we didn't need need to use that.
Wolverine open too.
But I don't think any one of us can play wall.
That sucks.
Oh well.
I think.
Okay.
I think I have to play.
Rocket.
I think so.
The damage.
Hmm.
actually i don't know i don't know ah i think the res would be important i think that's the res i'm gonna grab i'm gonna bet on the res the res would be clutch i think the res will be clutch we need that res also rocket's getting mega fucking buffed apparently uh next patch so i should have to practice raccoon even though like you don't really need practice no because i look hasn't been meta for so long and now but people can like climb with him because he's so easy to climb with okay it's fine I have res but like all right that doesn't matter though that doesn't matter it's okay our Luna got res though our Luna got res so I also have another res now Ouch.
I know.
I didn't think...
If I was Invis, I think she'd live.
Actually, no.
She has...
Magic has a new one-shot combo.
Or not new, but this season.
It's a one-shot combo.
So I don't think she would have lived even if I...
What?
Oh my god.
Did I actually have to play?
I should have played Invis.
I didn't think everyone would have been feeding so hard.
Everyone is feeding.
Oh my god.
Why are you all feeding?
Oh my god!
Okay, I'll go in this.
I did this for the res.
Everyone's feeding.
Uh, they're so used to my...
50!
Okay, everyone was so used to my heals.
Yeah.
Oh my god, my team is...
my team was so used to my heals being like so strong i think because invis heals does do more
because i have clutch heals a lot but i literally didn't think they would my team would feel like this
okay i don't know if this is winner but guys but I will try my best please oh this is bad this is so bad yeah no it's not winnable I can build my own I'm gonna build my own game as fast as I We...
No!
Why would you on?!
Holy shit!
That's good!
Oh my god, this TP is so bad.
This TP is so bad.
Oh no!
Of course they mooned that too!
That was such a bad...
Why would you put it there?
Oh my god.
This really is doom queuing.
It is.
Like, what?
Oh my.
That's unfortunate.
They actually...
Like, you know what?
Groot is actually so...
So easy.
Like...
This is so dumb.
Groot is so easily.
Literally, you know what you need to play?
All you have to play is...
Hey, yeah.
Yeah, you want to share some health too?
Clearly all you have to play is Punisher and Wolf.
And none of us played Punisher Or wolf.
Time to switch things up.
So like, oh so dad's awake now.
He's awake and he's hungry.
You'll need a top notch team to win this one.
Your audit blocked it.
Use Jim.
I'm sorry.
I mean he's right.
Hello.
He's hungry now.
I don't remember this guy, my friends.
I'm sorry if you're watching this stream.
You don't remember.
He's up.
I was like, who's this messaging me?
No, it's too early.
It's 7 in the morning.
It's way too early.
Oh!
Jimbo.
Oh, it's because it's been so long.
Okay.
it's been so long oh he is watching stream sniper no I'm West Coast it's seven the more I live in the West it's too early I'm letting him bark just oh my god he got closer
See, this is why I play, oh my god, oh my god, it's so loud.
Oh my god, please, I'm fucking trying to play.
Well, it's like this game got...
Go away, go away, go away.
Go away.
Oh my god, I'm not looking at the screen right now.
Oh shit, oh shit.
Oh my god, I got him.
This is bad though, because we have no combos technically for...
Oh my god, Dad, please!
Please, please, please, I can't think.
I can't think, please.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
He's so hungry.
I can't think and he's so hungry.
Okay, we reached the checkpoint.
He's so hungry.
I can't think
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
He sounds don't he no Okay, the only issue is we will die to moon night up because we have someone has to sign on the card He is cheering for you Oh my god, we don't have, oh my god, oh my god, this point almost, oh my god, my team so, they almost see nine because they all left me on the point,
and then I went invisible, I have to continuously melee,
please, don't leave me, there's too much responsibility to keep them, oh my god, we'll see nine again, I should not be Oh my god.
Oh my god, I just...
Oh my god, they almost seen that.
They almost...
Please, please, please.
Oh my god, please!
Please!
Goodbye, everybody.
Goodbye.
I gotta feed my dog.
Give me a second.
Oh, my God.
Also, I gotta pee.
I could be right back.
I'm gonna make sure that it's so cute.
All right, I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Was this she?
No, you wanna, I was Celestia 2.
I was Celestia 2.
I was three games off from securing top 500.
And then I lost 7.
in a row and now i'm in gm1 and i've given up i'm gonna get oh it's even worse oh that was off stream though i lost them in a row off stream and then i was like it's fixable this i can fix this and then i got further and further away and then i knew i was at the acceptance stage and i turned on stream because i knew it was over i i knew it wasn't coming back i i i did not fix it um so so that's why we're here today and i need to reset my sleep schedule um doing trying to get top 500 um this season really fucked up my sleep schedule and it sucks because like that's why i was like crashing out before stream i wanted to cry before stream so i was like that's why i decided stream because stream for you guys always cheers me up a lot But like before stream,
I was so sad because like I felt like I wasted so much time, you know, doing that grind Because I was like every day I was like I can fix I was getting closer and closer And it had one bad day one bad day and then it ruined the entire grind
It ruined the entire grind and then I gave up uh sumi thank you for the five dollars thank you thank you when is the next dynasty warriors origin stream i don't know actually i don't know because i do another one will be on twitch for sure yeah um but yeah that's why we're here today maybe i can get rigsy to do rank as well he's close he's getting there
oh we're on na now because rush i know i recognize the name rush Oh, what?
EU?
Wait, Russia's European?
I thought he was...
He's European?
I thought he was NA.
I guess he was apparently European.
Oh, yeah, I was gonna say.
No, he's just...
No, he is NA.
He's also a secret Elo terrorist.
He's an Elo terrorist just like me.
Here to ruin other people's games and different servers.
Let's go.
We're here to ruin the experience.
Also, like, I don't...
There's so many, like, serve.
Like, I realize all the best, like, game servers are on the East Coast.
I don't understand why.
I feel like like everyone just queues East Coast these days.
No, but, like...
But, like...
But like a lot, not just that, but it's still like majority of my games I play for rivals is on the East Coast server, because majority of the players on the East Coast for some fucking reason.
Also I think like most of the servers are there too.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Gotta give the husbando his, uh, the husbando his shields.
let's go I realize nobody uses the there nobody uses the wedding outfits anymore the fucking e-couple skin being happy with your significant other fucking go to your go to your room get a room disgusting matching names and profile picture cheers gross god damn people don't deserve to be that happy e-daters in my shooting game i am here to doom kill how dare you be happy
how fucking no there's no there's some in oh my god funny story okay wait i'll tell this after because like i sort of want to okay i want to win but like i i shouldn't i shouldn't hoping is for I should never hope I remember that let me let me just play the game oh my oh please all right guess I won't get healed okay let me actually focus up hoping is for winners yeah i'm not a winner today hey wait ricksy the ranks we can three stack and then
is that fun oh my god why maybe e you love these archers and then i can bring three people down with me i think that's even cooler you know what's better than two people hello hello hi
okay okay i didn't i didn't get hit once i
okay all right
Just destroyed you last game.
Oh my god.
Guys, maybe.
Maybe we should leave you soon.
Are you serious?
Guys, I told you.
Never hope.
Okay.
Remember?
I swear.
I know you have a...
because i know he's trying to kill her oh my god
i mean we got hell unleashed right here but we're in our little safe bubble doesn't really matter we're gonna lose this but ice did he clap did she clap at she clapped at the star lord didn't she she clapped at the star clapped at the starlord instead of at me oh my god she okay okay it's fine it's it's it's it's fine it's i'm i'm fine it's fine so the thing is what you're supposed to do i take take care of my luna and she looks at me because like we can out heal the damage we can out heal the damage but But like...
She fucking okay.
She did not do any of that.
No, whatever.
Whatever.
Oh, Jeff is bad.
Never mind.
Eh.
I mean...
Alright.
Here we go.
Yet here you are.
Fighting for the good of all.
Okay, he is not a support player.
Alright, that's good to know.
They're not a support player.
This is why I'm dune queuing, guys.
Okay, alright.
I guess.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
Wait, we have...
Okay.
That's interesting.
Alright, here we go.
Now I'm fine with surrendering.
These games are so bad.
like this hello we can see it look at and that's how you peel
that's what you have to do and then we peel what the fuck where did the venom go
there you go and that's how you peel That guy knows what's up.
That... what?
Come on, one left side.
Oh, nice.
Please see field now.
Okay.
I hope...
I'm just hoping that he heals first, not me.
I hope she's... he's okay over there.
I hope so.
Yeah, I...
I got He doesn't know where I am.
Oh shit There you go My god, okay, it's fine.
Oh my no no no no no no we got to heal each other we have to heal each other If we heal each other we can protect each Look at that look That's a Luna player!
That's a Luna player right there!
You saw that?
We protected each other!
That's a Luna player right there!
Now you see why I was like, this guy does not play Luna.
This guy actually does not play support.
You can tell.
You can fucking tell.
Because like, you're supposed to peel each other.
Did he do anything?
Jesus Christ.
Where?
Oh, hello.
Hello.
There you go.
That's a fucking Luna player.
Where's he coming from?
Oh my god, that's where he came from.
Okay.
Alright, he walks off.
Yeah.
So yeah.
I peaked top 100 I think that was that was like season one and then I stopped dang and I recently came I stopped taking it seriously but then there was a dragon badge for this season and I really and I didn't get it I didn't I I mean there's still two days but I know it's not possible I I've accepted it I came back to play again I relapsed hard the dragon badge the top 500 badge for this season is a dragon and it looks so cool i have two top 500 badges but they were like season zero and season one so it's like old school old school because that's when i wanted to that's when i was like best time get it it is the ass badge is next season i don't know it's not as cool as the dragon yes it's a peach and it's shaped like a butt but it's not as cool yeah it's a I fell off.
I did.
I became a variety streamer.
I want to alt early.
We got nobody.
Let's go.
Okay, we...
Let's go, I guess.
Where am I?
I'm so lost.
I'm gonna use this.
I don't know.
I feel so lost.
Okay, I don't know if we should have used two odds, but I was so confused.
I felt like we needed it.
Maybe we shouldn't have used both support odds.
All right.
All right, it's fine.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we died.
It's okay.
We didn't have patty cake.
That's fine.
We still win this.
We didn't... She didn't have...
She didn't have...
There's a... The shift.
Clap.
If she had clap, we'd live.
But she didn't have it.
That's all she needed.
Because I healed as much as I could.
But she needed the extra heal.
if we stacked, I think if we stacked, we could have lived, though, for sure.
We just didn't stack.
Oh, my god.
Oh, oh, oh, I don't know where I am.
Oh, my god, he's dead.
Didn't know where I am.
Peek-a-boo.
Oh, yeah.
I got it.
Oh, well, she got it.
There you go.
Four hours It does not feel like 4-Has.
I just love streaming Ravos.
I love streaming Rink.
I think if I was playing any other Rink and I'm like super into it, if you guys knew me from like peak Apex, I could stream Apex for like 10 hours.
TP, TP, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P, P.
I could really, you don't understand.
That's how much...
Ah!
Ah, and again!
Okay.
See, that's a natural Luna play.
Oh, I fucked up the push.
I almost pushed him.
Did he get him?
Toby!
Into the hole you go.
Another epic victory.
Two for two.
Wolfie.
What's this?
GG's.
Hope all of you know.
Nobody wants to kill us all of you.
Best Invis with me?
Me!
Wait, unless he's talking about Akari.
Is he talking about me?
That's me!
who yes glazed me I typed who please respond me
I know it's me I just want him to say it I know it glaze me i need all i can get fishing for compliments i've been dupe queuing i need this self-esteem boost right now literally the game two games before one of them called me a shitter and said i can't be real and i need this win two games before another player yelled at me
I need this I need it my own she is real yay I need a double dip glaze yay he said I'm good BFB I don't even know what I did I guess like I peeled I think it's because I peeled for my Luna.
See, that's what you know.
That other support actually plays support.
Like, we both actually peeled for each other.
And everything.
Like, the other Luna did not fucking care about my life.
She was like, you die?
I guess you die.
Yeah.
And then the support, we both actually looked at each other and healed each other.
But I've been that push.
I mean, it's like, usual.
invisible thing like women that's why i like playing invisible women you do you do less but you have more of an impact
like like you do less but you but you are like worth more to the team e-o-m-m final boss but like when i play azuna i feel like i could do so many things and we still lose.
It's just, and then when you're invisible woman, you can get away.
You can like get away, you can like get away with mistakes easier.
But when you're playing Luna, like you make one mistake and then it's over.
As invisible woman, if I misposition myself, I can just go invisible.
That, I disappear.
That's it.
I don't even need to stand in my arm.
I literally just...
No, she took him...
No!
She took invisible woman.
But yeah, I literally just placed the ult in front of me and I just go invisible.
So I don't have...
Because like when...
That's the thing that sucks.
When you're Luna and you ult and then the mag tries to ult you, you have to rely on your tanks to shield you.
But as invisible woman, I could just place my ult down and just disappear from the game.
And then that's it.
And then I live.
Oh
yeah, no.
Yeah, no.
Loki is so...
It's...
Loki is like not viable anymore.
Oh my god.
Luna jail.
Back into...
Back into Luna jail.
Demon Shark, thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Thank you.
No, he is high key bad.
He's only good in triple support in certain circumstances
He's like high-key bad.
I'd never see low-key players anymore except for low-key one tricks Those fuckers Those fuckers invading my game But there's like I don't even know like two of them.
I've only bumped into two low-key one tricks or one actually.
It's just one guy
Oh you love about Luna?
Oh Um, I used to like Luna a lot back then, because, like, back then, um, um, she was a lot more fun to play, and then, like, some, like, I guess, like, when they introduced Invisible Woman, her impact in the, like, game got, like, less and less.
I mean, she still has a high impact, but it's just more frustrating to play as her.
It's just more too frustrating to play here.
Because, like I said, I could do, like, so many things.
correct?
Like, look, I freeze him and everything.
Oh, he's still alive.
Oh, he still gets to live.
Oh, that sucks.
Oh, I guess he's alive.
Like, I hit that freeze and everything, but we let her live.
Oh, oh, I hit it again.
Why are you running away?
Okay.
There you go There we go I hit that freeze also froggy.
Thank you for the for the raid.
Thank you.
Thank you Oh, you had a great stream.
Hello, everybody coming from Froggy stream Oh my god, that's unlucky.
Eve got to pour it up Where am I?
Where oh my god.
Oh My god, I got oh that sucked me and the invasions got chucked in the air that sucks oh we're in east coast now okay god damn it we got we got like chucked in the air so it confused me it sucks i didn't think there was a spider man i was so confused i was like spider man when the fuck did spider man showed up it like confused the shit out of me oh my god bye i heal her and then that heals my phoenix what did she say did she say me first did she say her or me see look i missed that one the one oh oh oh okay
all right see it's not fun It's not fun anymore.
I don't know if she said her first or me first, because I was waiting for her.
Yeah, we got Spider-Man's.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, okay.
It's fine.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh my god, here I go!
All right, here we go.
I'm just alting this because I don't trust my team to be alive.
And then the Spider-Man is going to be like, you don't miss me Spider-Man.
Or this.
Oh.
There we go.
All right.
God.
That was hard
That was hard Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Are you fucking worse?
Wait, where did my invis go?
Where oh my god, where I was I didn't realize she was right there Okay, here's another fucking freeze.
Oh my god.
I love freezing Here's another one.
How many more freezes do I do?
I should have saved the collab.
I'm just, I'm not playing autopilot right now.
I should have saved it.
All right.
Oh, am I going to get another dive?
Oh my god.
Oh, is he going to?
What the?
Please.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
Please tell me.
It doesn't matter.
It is definitely not good.
Okay, there we go.
I told you, it doesn't matter how many times I freeze someone!
It fucking sucks!
Fucking sucks playing, Nuna.
It's not fun.
Oh, at least you all did.
I knew he was gonna have it.
I should have I should have healed my My invis more there.
I think if I healed.
Oh There we go.
Here we go again Here we go.
I peeled I did it Wait, did she save me or her?
Okay, all right, that's five That's five It's fine, he got no one How did our spotty die?
How did she die?
Ready?
Oh, mom, never mind Guess not I missed it Thank you.
All right.
He's coming back in.
He's going to jump back in.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Thank.
Oh, there you go.
I did another freeze.
Here's another one.
How many times was I frozen that guy?
All right.
There is another freeze.
My PC fucking explodes.
It's okay.
He actually... Wow!
He actually died.
That's crazy.
I was not...
Alright.
There we go!
I did it yet again.
Okay.
Alright.
This is where we die.
this is where we died there's nothing you could do there was nothing I could do maybe I hit the fucking oh my god I fell down maybe I hit the craziest freeze of my life oh well I guess I'm here now my support stop playing so far I can come back and feel what do you mean we were at like two inches away from the point up i saw the caro i literally jumped back you guys are farther than i might jump back you're here
and we said the animals on point so why are you guys right where you're standing right now oh nice okay that's good that's good that's good that was in the sky man
There he is.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I had to use it.
I'm gonna.
I'm going here.
Hello everyone.
Hello.
Come on, let me go.
You get a weapon.
Okay.
Alright, I wanted, I was scared.
I ulted that because I was so scared.
i was so scared i was so you don't understand i was so scared i felt like i felt like if i didn't
oh my god this is not good for me i don't know if i should have just died there but like i felt like i felt like i felt like the me if I didn't oh that you were so I know I was like we're on the payload like I was like what like the moon me and the imps were on the payload how what like baby you're the one that's so far back
I'm tempted to just play Rocket, but I know my Invis will fucking die.
I can tell she would actually die if I don't play Luna.
Like,
I don't really want to play Luna, right?
I can I can tell Maybe I can give this to our spotted man And then run back There you go Because then Rocket is like Like you play Rocket so that they can't dive you They'll just dive the Invis But I know Like because I'm literally freezing him Nine out of ten times
Okay That's fine Oh I use my clap though, which is bad.
Like the moment I got hit, I used my clap because I got so scared.
Jesus Christ, I hate this.
Look at that.
I got it.
I got it against.
Look at that.
All right.
Literally, if I don't freeze him, it'd be like GG's.
Where did my, where did she go?
Where did she go?
I think, bro, I think their Spider-Man is better than my Spider-Man.
I honestly, I honestly do.
I don't think, I think their Spider-Man's better.
You need to stop that vehicle in its tracks.
Because it's like, I don't understand.
Oh, it's because they have venom.
It's, yeah, never mind.
We have Hulk, and we don't have a name for it.
Look at that.
Oh, there we go again.
There we go again.
Use my clap.
Oh.
There we go.
You're going to go.
I kept on something.
There's something.
Bro, can you just go Gamma?
I don't understand.
Why are you playing Phoenix?
What is Phoenix gonna do, bro?
You're not even killing the fucking Spider-Man.
Just go Gamma.
Oh, there you go!
There it is again!
Okay, sorry, I have to go over here.
I have to go here.
I'm sorry.
If you die.
Oh, I'll die.
Don't worry.
It's gonna be me I can't I can't I'm sorry.
I'm sorry you're gonna you're bluff Like yeah, I can't do that there This is actual hell
Okay Like I can't do this here.
I know she'll have It'll be worse.
I was so close.
I like...
How many freezes do I have to...
Oh my... Like, I'm saying!
I'll put 100% more effort into this character to win a game versus Invis.
I literally can autopilot on Invis.
Oh my god.
It's terrible.
It truly is so...
I can't fucking hit him.
Good luck.
I can't hit him.
Here we go.
Here.
I did it.
I did it for us.
I can hit all my freezes, but it'll never matter.
Oh my god!
The one freeze I miss, it's over!
They double now.
They did it just double?
Uh, we.
I can feel it.
I don't know if it's in the back of the tunnel.
I'm coming.
I can feel it.
I can feel the spider metal.
I'm so, I'm not.
i'm not happy this is why i stopped the luna surely a dps will help out with the dive right i was like the ones the one freeze i missed from the venom i was like it's over like we might as well be dead now i'm letting our invis heal because there's no reason i don't want to damage i'm just kidding with you guys right I'm not dead.
I only heal when I need to help our...
Oh, whoa!
Please.
Please, I used my clap.
Alright.
I don't have clap, it's over.
I'm trying to, like, let my Invis do the healing.
There you go.
Did you flake our Spider-Man?
I did.
I can heal you.
Trying to lift.
Whoa!
Here we go!
Oh.
Get over here, girl!
There we go.
All right, one last fight for the run.
I'll just heal that, heal that a little bit.
Why do I even try for pigs?
Jesus Christ.
Did he stop the TP or not?
I don't even know if he stopped it.
Nope, he's so dead.
Unless...
I know.
This just might be...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he actually did it.
Oh my god, I'm so proud of her.
Oh my god, I'm full!
That's okay.
Hoolies.
Give me it.
Oh my god, I missed it.
Oh, it's too late.
Okay, cheat.
Thank god.
It's over.
It's taking over.
It's actually over.
I let me out of this game.
Let me get out of it.
Freedom.
Freedom from hell.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
I felt like I hated that game.
I hated that game so much.
I can rest now.
I think I missed like I missed three freezes out of like I don't know a hundred that I had to do yeah no I'm back to GM I was I was like two games away from losing it anyway yeah one more yeah I told you you'll be like in this I'm like la la la la she
I remember my other Luna did not during the last game um she did not freeze the fucking uh venom as much as I fucking just did I'm just like Jesus fucking Christ I do not want to deal with that shit no Spider-Man yeah it has 11k damage but that's Spider-Man like Spider-Man all you don't need a lot of uh damage to get kills because you know they're not farming damage you're literally there to do combos and stuff no i just want to play until i'm tired because i already set my sleep schedule i'm trying to stay up the whole day today um because like i don't want to because like i'm gonna be like way too awake um if i try to sleep like uh because i'm too awake now so i'm to i'm trying trying to like stay up the whole day because i fucked up my sleep schedule because of this stupid game yeah bro no but fuck that game bro this is why i hate playing luna now like It's like that's insane.
I think that's why now remember when dive became a thing When when hard dive became a thing I can't just sit in the back line be like la la la Clap clap clap clap clap all teammates low clap clap now I have to like be aware of 800 million things around me Do you think you want to be today?
Now I just have to be like, oh there, oh, okay, we have...
We have three support players.
Let's hope these two can take.
Yeah, now I have to...
Yeah, and then Invis, I can play half the concentration.
Like, try half as hard on Invis and then get the same result.
That's all I want in life.
hands if only if only i get that if only that were true i don't get that privilege anymore
bottom all right i don't know about this scheme i don't know this game already seems a little rough
Oh, yeah.
Um.
Ah, that's alright.
This that we have.
The Angela.
Hmm.
I don't want cloak, Jeff.
Uh, let's fuck it.
Let's try it.
Burn this.
That doesn't work.
I'll go Invis.
I really don't want to play Luna.
I really, really don't want to play Luna.
I want to... I need a break.
I need a break.
I...
I can't.
Oh yeah, no, the upcoming changes I heard with Daredevil and Venom is going to be a lot worse for supports with that.
Because it's just so intrusive.
But you have already proven your worth.
If this battle is to be won.
No, in this, you know, good Angela is like so scary.
But like, no, I shouldn't shake it.
I just play Invis.
many good Angeles just because I play Invis.
Like, literally, I just go push, and then they can't do shit.
Then we get, like, one one to two grabs, and then I go Invis, and then they get nothing and swap off.
It's great.
It makes me so happy knowing that I made them have an extra bad day in ring.
Just because I take a counter.
Alright, let's see what they're playing.
Oh, where did he go?
Jesus Christ Oh, he was diamond for him That's my bet
Okay, nice Whoa Not nice Oh my god, it's just dive I think I have to swap I need a swap We actually don't have enough heals right now I know it's crazy because we're on triple support, but they're hard diving us.
Why don't we swap our starlord?
I just don't have a good feeling about it.
Yeah, no, this...
I may have...
Oh, Rixie!
My fault.
No, you're right.
Rixie!
My fault.
You're right.
Are we all here?
Let's go.
Damn.
Alright, goodbye.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Where?
I'm just like, what's going on?
Oh my god, he's so fucked.
Oh my god, I'm trying my best.
I got so many headshots.
Yeah.
What is going?
God, I'm not playing this character.
Oh my god, Jeff is a controller player.
Oh, one HP.
That's okay.
We're all here.
Is he okay?
I don't think so.
Maybe I can push him off.
Guys, please.
Guys, I don't have enough.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
Guys, please.
I don't have...
Thank God.
God, I'll kill that.
We just had...
Oh, God.
There's so much damage.
Oh, my God.
Holy fuck.
What do we...
Dude...
No, one would...
One HP.
Nice.
That's okay, we'll be on this point.
It's fine.
I- I- I- What- what's going on?
Please!
What the fuck?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
We live for another day.
I, I, okay.
Okay.
That was crazy.
Oh my god.
Why?
Out of everyone.
I'm so scared.
Oh, shit.
Goodbye.
Use my jump.
It's over for me.
Three, two.
No!
I just need one more second.
Oh, my God.
Have I had my jump for one more second?
That's so unlucky.
We'll have to keep fighting until we have a winner.
tp or oh no one's off go
go oh i almost ran in oh wait doesn't dokey play dps what no wait did i it feels good to step outside my bubble every now and then Maybe like the main DPS for all Bro I've been playing support and rivals for too long to swap back to to try DPS Not in this ELO.
I'm fucking playing DPS with this ELO Maybe in the lower ELO's bro.
Fuck that shit Location but with the best silo can I don't know T is in the wrong time
But I knew what it was gonna be like play mag here or probably okay but sure would have been nice to have you back on board the milana the battle starts in five four three two one no you gotta be like super high to get rid of jeff the jeff jump up but even then like the timing is like really hard because you just go invisible and just fucking book it
I don't know I don't know what it is that if maybe a lab would have changed anything
Okay All right
All right, he's so far from us.
He's so far from us now
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh The map change!
The
map change is crazy.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my, there's nothing.
I just got my luck.
I just got it.
Oh, thanks.
Oh.
Okay, the Hulk is on the plate there.
Alright, here we go.
I had the whole fight.
Jesus, it's so disordained.
I didn't even realize that's my bad.
Jesus Christ.
That was my bad.
I might throw an F-client.
I thought, like, I didn't have my...
To be fair, it was a lot going on.
To be fair.
It was a lot.
It really...
It really was so much going on there.
That's...
No worries.
I've got your back.
It was crazy.
I want to hurt all at first.
I'll be like, you all at first.
All right.
Maybe she'll do it.
I ran out of shields first only because, like, I'm so scared, you know?
It seems me.
Okay, maybe I should have ults at first.
I got to...
There's nothing to do to save me.
I actually was unsavable.
There
you go.
There you go.
Alright, let's use this.
I'll push up.
Goodbye, everyone.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Oh, goodbye, everyone.
It's okay.
Sometimes life do be like that.
Oh my god.
I don't want to play.
I don't want to play Luna.
Don't make me play Luna.
That's it.
I refuse to play Luna.
You have two people.
Did you love it?
Oh, we're doing our...
I'm sorry I'm sorry wait I got an idea it's time it's time they won't load they won't load they won't know they won't know they won't know they don't see it they saw it they saw it oh this is bad they saw it they saw my wrist I thought it was so in it I I really die I hit it so well you know oh this is bad this is so bad this is so bad I'm trying my best to keep it up I'm trying so hard oh my god oh my god oh come on come on come on come
I got it.
I got... No!
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
I can't do anything about it.
I climbed so much.
All I did...
All I did was I just kept...
I just kept climbing.
I kept climbing and I kept climbing.
When do I stop climbing?
That's over here.
All I did was climb.
GG.
I kept climbing.
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
Barry, get it off.
Damn.
Is she a cloak one trick?
she wasn't that doing that bad it's just cloak is just so bad it's just cloak is just bad
not like uh not a good character to play at all i'm there's no objective i'm just doom queuing at this point i've like reached my objective i'm
I've reached it.
How bad did they nerf Cloak?
She's just not meta.
That's it.
She's so easily counterable by Mag.
Because Mag is a hard meta pick for Tank.
So, um...
So, like, there's no reason to play Cloak.
Because there's just so many counters to her.
And a good DPS player will just hook you off of your Cloak alt and delete you.
Yeah, Mag is just too good of a Tank.
It's just almost like almost all tank players will know how to play mag in the silo.
So like there's no point.
Um, and like literally the best support comp is triple support and cloak is not in triple support.
Like triple support is the best support comp.
But like if you play cloak people angie, including me because we're in triple support.
I was angie.
I was, you know, I should actually avoid her.
I'm like, because like.
If she was anything else If she was Invis Or Luna Or Mantis It would have worked But she was cloak So it didn't work
Yeah Now the reason why I didn't stay high ground was because The The sidewalk was following me So I had to move around I had to fucking run around the point Because the siloac was hunting me down So I was just like I had to get back I had to just run around And then I got scared Because I still had to heal the Hulk So I was like Oh no Hulk Guess I'll die with you
Bye Hulk
Because the Hulk and I were contesting the point for so long.
I was like, I swear this is my last time.
I'm not grinding anymore.
I'm doom queuing.
I lost.
But yeah.
I'm not even trying anymore.
I'm just doom queuing.
I've accepted that I can't make it this season.
There's two days left.
Wait, I avoided.
Oh.
Oh, I forgot to ask him to re-queue.
I forgot to ask for the re-queue.
I was like, wait a minute.
All right, we have...
Okay, we have Mantis Cloak.
Fuck!
Okay.
All right, I forgot to ask for a re-queue.
Because I just don't want to cook on my team.
No, if you avoid someone, you have to re-queue it to implement.
If I could, I would.
Uh, my ma.
No, she is.
100%.
Because she's stuck with Cloak.
No matter what.
Because it's not meta.
But she's so easy to climb for those who can't game.
Because she's just game sense.
She's just literally game sense.
That's it.
But like, one trick.
Ignore the part where.
You have to swap off Cloak when it's not working.
That's the only thing that's wrong.
It's like rock.
The thing is, it's like, it's crazy.
I feel like for supports, there's only three one trick.
There's only two one tricks.
Cloak and Rocket.
And they're both characters that don't really require aim.
And if you, if they put on like any other character, they're like handless.
But like, if you have like a Luna main or an invisible woman main, they can easily play any other characters.
like we we they're cool they're cool now they're cool now um but if you literally put them off of their one tricks um they like they're just handless that's why i'm so i i i personally just hate cook one tricks and rocket one because they're so easily counterable but every other support player like if you put the Luna one trick I'm playing Adam because this is meta um you put Mantis Adam is really good I would play Ultron but we have a cloak and I do not want to play Ultron with known snowflake but you literally put you put Luna one trick on any other support she's okay she can play any other character decently if you put like an Invis or a Mantis they're all they're fine they can play any other support easily it's just it's literally cloaking rocket there are the problems Four,
three, two, one.
It's gonna slay.
Oh no, not hope.
Okay.
I'm going down.
Oh shit!
I dropped down.
I'm running hooks all over here.
All right.
Hope that's okay.
I didn't want to use...
Okay.
Watch out of my lock.
There you go.
You're five.
You're so healthy.
It's not you ping, though.
I'm not using my...
My shift?
Because there's no use.
Oh, at least they have a rocket.
You know?
At least they have a rocket.
A rocket...
I would say a rocket is better than the cloak at this point.
Like, right now.
There we go.
You're fine.
Don't worry.
This is why I saved my...
My thing.
Oh.
Oh, that sucks.
I mean, I have res, but I'm not res in here.
But I would say...
Oh.
Oh, no.
Now they have a venom.
God.
I'll play for res.
I gotta pay for res now.
Oh.
I guess now?
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
We run.
Oh, fuck, I fucked up.
That was too fast.
It's fine, I have ships.
We should really go push up though, where...
I am ready to put on a show.
Fuck it.
There we go.
We have to use this.
The only issue now?
Okay, yeah, that's the only issue now.
There we go.
Hello.
Oh, whoops, sorry, I didn't think she would hit that sleeve, you know?
Oh, I didn't think we would die there.
Oh,
we can't contest.
That sucks.
I don't think we can contest.
I thought it'd shift.
Ah, no.
That sucks.
Wait, did we ban Jeff?
We banned Jeff doing...
I think we banned Jeff, right?
I think I'll just go in this.
They have too many.
Ah, fuck.
That sucks.
Ah, I'll swap.
Mmm, actually.
Mmm.
Destiny awaits.
They've made it halfway.
Stop them!
Oh, okay.
If they cap the second point, I'll swap.
Because I don't think it's viable now.
Not this point, part of the point.
Alright, I hope they...
Hey guys!
Oh my god, okay, fine.
Fine.
I hope they...
Okay, we triple support all of it.
We triple support all of it.
Okay.
That sucks.
I can't believe we triple support.
spoiled it or double support all did oh that's so dumb uh actually i'll go this for peel yeah i you know he should have it's always mantis first it's always mantis first but i don't know why he didn't do mantis first uh um that's That's unlucky.
That's why I was like, oh, I should have avoided.
I should have avoided.
No matter what, it's Mantis first for that.
Are you okay there, Mantis?
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
I couldn't.
I was trying to...
Okay, that's fine.
I don't have push though.
That's not fine.
It's not as fine.
Good.
I need to save my push for the...
I need it.
Okay, that's fine.
All right
Okay, I fucked up.
Oh my god, I was trying to Yeah, oh no, oh my god, that's so unlucky.
He was just out of it Oh, I feel like I'm the only one looking at it like the Luna Okay, that's fine
Okay, that's not fine I could Oh That's so unlucky I don't give up so easily all right Sucks I knew I should have such a shit con to be honest.
I knew it.
I Knew I should have avoided I knew it
I had I felt it in my gut I
okay I felt it I felt it in my gut too yeah
we have any okay I'm gonna let them heal I'm gonna let them heal because we need we need the cocoa oh my god that's so close.
Okay, we got Cloak Alt.
That's good.
Oh, thank God they see nine.
Oh!
Venom, no, Venom's gonna be even stronger.
That's the worst part.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the fast he's gonna be even stronger.
And that's that's so much worse.
I'm so sad.
He's already So pete He's so intrusive
Yeah What the fuck
Oh, yeah, I forgot to fix my chat so you can look at you can look at the disappointment more I forgot I was supposed to be here bro That's cringe.
That's weird
I forgot to lower the chat so you can be you can see my disappointment
bro I'm just I'm bro taking in the DMs if you know this guy you can literally DM him you don't have to show me you're flirting I did not, I did not consent to this.
I didn't consent to seeing you two flirt.
Bro, he didn't even respond back.
He's like, please respond.
And she didn't even respond back.
That's so sad.
Jesus.
Bro, this guy, does this guy know how to play Naimore?
He's just throwing it.
He's literally throwing.
Oh, and then.
unlucky no way he gets out why does he get out of that in our zone
sucks running solo hug bro didn't the solo hug off work last time
what's on with me for fun one of the support i mean i mean i'll come over hello See?
It's me.
I'll be here.
Good luck.
Work one.
Guys, I don't know.
Guys.
I tried.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I knew I should have avoided.
I knew I should have restarted.
the queue i had that gut feeling that she was she was gonna ruin it
i think it's just the fact that we're running
like i can't oh first that's the thing get out of here Oh boy.
Good luck everyone.
We are not using Mantis Alt aggressively at all.
I think that's also the problem.
Like.
There we go.
We're like using it like defensively, but the whole point of, oh my god.
Just because I don't trust.
There we go.
Hello, can we...
It's fine.
I wanted to... Oh my god.
Jesus, Chris.
I hate my...
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
I...
I hate this.
I'm destroying it.
Am I having fun right now?
Oh my god.
I don't think I'm having fun anymore.
but i don't understand how come please oh please i just
okay at least we got that up and oh my god it's winnabah no stone hope don't hope it's don't hope hoping is for it never hope
never hope never hope
hello goodbye yeah thank you for the raid thank you thank you hello i am doom queuing for those who are wondering oh this is this is doom queue hours right now we're doing we are so oh my god oh my god we actually have actually have a diff we actually have two tanks that's crazy
we're just we're just zoomers oh thank god it's okay things are very rough right now i don't think we're gonna win this but we're gonna we got the spirit though we got the spirit and that's all that matters oh my god he definitely has all he's looking for it He's looking for it so hard right now and like I have to be aware There we go.
They fucked up.
They fucked up
Yeah Hello,
everyone, um there is a hawk on point.
Hello, everyone.
Hello, hello, there is still There we go.
There we go.
They have enough time to TP.
I'm pretty sure.
Do they?
Yes!
Thank a fucking guy.
Oh my- I don't know how he died.
This is hell.
I'll push cart.
Oh my god.
I don't have shield anymore.
Alright.
Alright, here I go.
I wait.
And then maybe.
That's good.
Maybe.
This was cut.
I'm still.
We use...
Match this on!
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
You...
Match this on!
We also use it.
I don't even know what the fuck is going on anymore.
what the fuck is going on what is this fight what the fuck is this fight right now this is a don't don't die don't die okay all right we have to oh my god we can kill him oh my god he's taking a nap
Guys, Venom on cart.
No more to go.
Oh my god.
Oh
my god, we did it.
Oh my god, dude, I had to use VC because no one cared.
No one fucking cared.
Did you see me and the cloak just fighting for a last on that goddamn Venom?
I'm like, Venom.
Oh my god, I can't deal with this.
I can't.
and then finally they all turn around they all freaking turn around i broke my silence i've had it i was done i broke my silence i
okay now the avoid will go in and then she's gonna fire me i can feel it it's this how it goes it's out well everyone thank you so much for the rate i hope you had a good stream those who don't know me my name is dokeeper and i usually stream on youtube but today i'm here because i'm trying to reset my sleep schedule and i've given up my top 500 guide for rivals so i'm doom queuing now i usually stream i usually play off stream for rivals when i'm like wanting to grind rank because i don't want to get distracted um so i can hyper focus but like it was bad i got to celestial 2 and then i literally need four games to like lock like because it's like celestial 2 was is the threshold and i got to celestial 2 and i needed three games to um secure it and then i lost seven games in a row and then like and then i got the rank to celestial the three and then and then i i was like it's over there's there's no more hope there's no more hope i just had to had to win three games
and i lost seven in a row and i gave up and now my goal today is that when i win i hope i lose someone's chance of also securing top 500 and if i lose i hope that i also fucked over someone else's chance to also secure top 500 and that's all i want in life that's all because if i can't get it no one can in my lobbies not taking everyone down i'm gatekeeping i'm the I'm the top 500 final boss I'm the final boss to the leaderboard I'm the EOMM demon that's me that gives someone then I hope I lose I hope I I I'm on the other team and then I take it away
Jesus that is a lot of insta locks That is everyone.
Oh, don't make me...
I'm playing...
I don't care.
I'm playing it with this.
Oh, I have to play Luna for the Spider-Man!
Oh!
I'm not...
I'm just thinking what time to walk dad.
My dog.
My dog's name is Joki Amberdosh.
So I call him dad for those who are new here.
But for those who are...
Someone was asking what are you.
So straight up.
I'm a variety streamer.
I stream whatever.
Oh yeah.
For those who missed the beginning of the stream, I got invited to a business trip event.
It's not TwitchCon.
So I will be gone at the end of the week and I'll be back on, I think, Wednesday.
I'll be back on Wednesday.
I think I'm leaving?
I want to say when I'm leaving.
But I'll be leaving at the end of the week and I'll be back on Wednesday.
It was so last minute.
Um, it was super last minute because like I literally booked my tickets this week It's like I don't twitch con is also next week, but it's not twitch con So I'll be going on business trip, uh, this week I think this year I'm trapped.
I'm proud of myself because this year I'm traveling more I'm like doing things were like, I guess like myself in terms of like going outside and enjoying life a bit more.
This year's my personal growth year.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
What troubles you saw?
Oh, just across all space and time and we're stuck in the middle.
Yeah, it's nothing big.
Oh, I'm so scared.
I'm still scared traveling.
As of.
Oh, wait.
We're going.
Okay, uh, Spider-Man.
I will always have the underlying fear.
Oh, they have Punisher.
Me no light.
Oh, man.
And they have Punisher.
I need it actually.
Jesus Christ.
wait where's our strange oh there he is i was like where the fuck is he oh my okay i thought that was
oh my god
okay good luck everyone
oh okay you can leave me i guess i
um this is gonna be hard i keep sleeping if you're in the fight this is gonna be a hard mantis with lunar healers is because like
there you go
oh my this is gonna be hard or because like we don't have we don't have an Emma why did we why did we not I need to know what did we ban we banned mag and not Emma oh my god these guys are fucking stupid bro there's like you can't save these people you can't save them are you there at some point that's it i'm going in we're using this aggressively okay we better be fucking okay i was gonna sit
have okay all right that's cool i was gonna say no emma is like a mandatory band and like it's always forge emma forge emma phoenix and then bonus is ultra and jeff uh okay i want to kill emma before
He's gonna be like, That's unlucky.
All right, let's.
Oh, I'm waiting this out.
Oh, whoa.
Slapped him for you.
Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
The battlefield ready again.
I was looking at him.
Oh my, oh my, Nia!
Oh, there's nowhere for me to go.
There's nowhere for me to go.
There's actual nowhere for me to go.
How?
What the fuck do you mean?
There's four people on point.
We can win this fighting.
We need another support.
I cannot do this.
Fuck you dead.
He's raised.
All right.
I have to use this.
He got kicked out.
I don't have any support.
I'm getting flanked right now.
There's nothing I can do.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
They went triple supporters.
Because I don't think any of these people are them.
We can win this, guys.
I'm like, no.
No, get me out of here again.
Yeah.
Why didn't we- why did we bat- who bat- I'm gonna look at the replay.
I need to know who bat mag.
Oh my god, it must have been the Spider-Man.
Oh my god, I swear to God if it was a Spider-Man.
I swear to God.
I'm forced on Luna duty only because we have a Spider-Man too.
And this would probably be good.
counters if you're player yeah oh my god okay appreciate it okay oh my god okay i wish i was seeing this player franklin and valor are gonna be so sad they missed this all right this poor guy has to solo tank this entire oh they have like they have like three two reses it's actually crazy they have two reses and everything too so it's like
Monkey flanking left.
Armed and dangerous.
Oh yeah.
Nice.
Not nice.
They have so many res.
This is actually crazy.
This is not winnable.
Oh, Rigsie, you want to play Wolverine here for this element?
What?
That's just rolling us.
I can't throw.
What?
I'm just playing to play.
Honestly, I don't know how long I'll be playing for.
I'm just playing because it's fun.
I'm still having fun.
But like, bro.
I can heal us.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, I would love to heal you yet.
Oh, that's sad.
Oh, that...
What?
Oh, there he is.
Adam.
She's one.
Adam one.
All right.
Bro.
Why?
Do you not care about your life?
Adam's gonna rest.
I'm born again.
Then you want save for him.
What?
Oh, we definitely...
Oh.
We definitely...
Yeah, we definitely did not need that.
Oh, that's awkward.
Thank you.
Bro.
What is this?
That is a fucking res beacon up there?
Bro.
That is a solid avoid.
What?
That bro.
What the fuck?
That's good.
I think he resists.
Oh no no he doesn't.
No he doesn't.
Oh.
Oh bro.
We don't even have friends.
That's our two DPS.
Oh no.
Oh,
that's unlucky.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I was trying to touch as much as possible.
No, I don't think we touching anything.
Weeeeee!
Yeah, I was like, our two DPS got picked instantly.
spot he got squished all right i'm gonna look i'm gonna the person who the person who banned mag i'm gonna avoid them i need to know i need to know who did it because i was tapped out who did this who did this
all right i don't know any of these people who's this guy
what is this guy don't make me search you up okay what is this guy
okay what did they play oh I played who is this guy who are you I'll accept it because he's top 500 right now hey if you're watching if you want to do a i'm i'm down
i see your top 500 right now i i see i see your i see your top 500 right now see
God, how much do you want to keep that top 500?
I can change that.
I'm going to accept it.
Fuck it.
I'll accept it.
Get out of there, buddy.
It would be a shame if something happened to your secure top 500.
Oh, it would be a shame indeed.
Oh, yeah, I was gonna watch the replay.
I need to know.
Who banned this?
Where are we at the...
Rigsie!
You fucking...
It was a inside jump!
It was a fucking...
It was a
fucking...
Rigsie, the moment...
The moment...
Oh, shit, sorry.
I cancelled match.
Wait, Riku.
Rik...
Req, I accidentally cancelled.
It was an inside job the entire time.
Oh, the betrayal!
Why did you batman?
It was a setup.
Traitor!
The entire time.
I thought I can't believe it I can't believe It do be like that It do be like that Your own kind Your own duo Fucking it up for everyone
It was me Rigsy Messed up That was so messed up actually was and hide your profile right now i need to know how close to you wait actually i can look at it actually okay three guys write this down for me so write this down for me in chat so i can copy and paste on the leaderboard i didn't know if he is top 500 security guys write this down for me i'm gonna search him up on the leaderboard because i think it's i'm pretty sure it's like
I I can't tell how many eyes are there how many you know thank you for the hundred pennies thank you thank you I got it okay I actually okay I need okay guys I need a tell me I'm pretty sure the the first one are like capital eyes and then it's l's guys write this down for me I need a no wait is that it okay let me see I don't know you just randomly okay i'm gonna look him up i need to know how secure is he oh he's not secure yet wait i don't think he is oh my god there's hope
there's still a chance i'm gonna wait until he's secure secure all right remember it remember it for me guys i'm gonna wait until he's secure secure before i ask if he wants to play all right
i don't know who he is he randomly added me so i was like okay i don't know if he maybe he's trying to avoid me was that i do bad badly no i didn't die as much okay no okay that's good
I was like, I didn't have, no, okay, he wasn't, I don't think he was trying to, he was trying to avoid me.
Because some people would accidentally, they would accidentally add people when they're trying to avoid them.
It was, I don't think that's an alt to count.
It's level 65.
That is way too high for an alt to count.
I do not think this is an alt.
Add note.
Unsecured top five.
Oh.
What is that?
No!
I wanted to get hurt.
Just so I remember.
I need to remember him.
I just wanted to be sure.
God intervened so that he could stop the note.
God was like, not to.
it.
No griefing.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
I trust my team to do the bans.
I'm not gonna worry about it.
Maybe I'll just do a Zatsudan.
I don't know.
I don't know what to stream today.
Like later on YouTube.
I'll just do a Zatsudan.
I feel like I definitely won't be able to stay up to play so I feel like I'd be way too tired to stream Silk Song later.
I'll just, like, I'll just do a normal Zastodon stream.
What if I stream more Rivals, but I need it to?
Unless...
Unless I just stream more Rivals, but it'll be on YouTube.
More Doom Q.
Ah, she took in...
Ah!
It's fine.
It's...
I love Marvel Rivals.
Bum, bum, bum.
Oh my god, it's here too.
Oh my god, I wish I could have.
I was attacked.
Finally, I don't like this map.
Keep you sane by watching me go fucking insane.
You're just like, at least it's not me.
But live vicariously through my doom queuing.
You're like, thank God it's not me that's doom queuing.
I get the same experience by just watching her.
The balance we need.
Three, two, one.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Is that a venom?
Oh, is that a...
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Hey, look at that.
Look at that.
Oh, look at that.
Oh boy!
Okay.
I can feel it.
Hey, I hope she heals me too.
Oh, thank god.
This is where I die.
Unless...
Okay.
That's fine.
I just...
Why is it always me when I have to play...
When I have to play Luna, I have to go through Venom Spider-Man.
It's always...
Oh my god.
Oh.
Let's go.
Let's fucking move forward.
You're fine, right?
You're so healthy.
There we go.
Did we stabilize?
Oh my god.
Oh My god.
Oh My oh Just forfeit.
I can't
There's there's nothing I can do there's nothing I don't I don't think we just need a bucky we we have we have this my man on my man on blade like like it's not oh my god I'm literally just out of it I
Things are going really well.
Devlin, thank you for the...
Like, it's fine.
If we forfeit, I understand.
I understand.
Thank you for the 10 gift and thumbs.
Thank you, thank you.
Like, there's nothing we can do.
I don't know if there is anything we can do
That's okay sometimes life is just like that We just have they have spider-man venom we have blades and like Sometimes it's just like that it's wow we won guys I'll win this first We won our first fight, guys!
We did it!
Oh, they're opening up!
Oh!
That's unlucky.
All right, I don't have a shield now, so good luck everyone.
All right, did we do it?
Well...
What happened?
What the fuck even happened?
What the fuck is...
What happened?
Bro, that was like 800 ults all at once.
I don't even know what happened.
Holy shit.
I think we just used every ult possible to win that fight.
A nice deep freeze.
All right, get ready for the Spider-Man.
You guys ready?
Oh my god.
He messed up.
There is a guy.
He actually messed up.
Oh my god, I don't know if they'll live.
I don't think he's...
Oh my god, he...
Where is he?
Say where did he go?
Yeah, I had a feeling he was he was fucking dead dead in there Oh, what the fuck
Oh shit, oh shit That's unlucky.
I thought I thought she was gonna alt first Oh, that's so bad That is so bad.
Our Invis did it all first.
I think it's time to go back to your one-trick, Angelou.
Why didn't our Invis?
Oh, she said me first.
Oh!
No.
You didn't say anything.
First time First time I heard was You first So I assume it's always you I didn't
always Love my powers Oh my god Apparently she's Steve was like You go Luna His VC isn't working
That suck Yeah Yeah, because I was waiting for...
...
It's the Edo Terrorist tab.
Oh, he's fucked up.
That sucked that, like, you know, he, uh, he was like, you go, oh, first.
Oh my god, he actually hit.
That actually sucked that, like, he wanted to coordinate up.
Oh my god, he pooped him, so I couldn't freeze him.
And it was when I was supposed to, oh, he wanted me to ult first.
How unlucky was that?
We could have actually full held that.
Like, not...
I don't know if we could have, but...
It was giving us a higher chance.
Goodbye.
It was nice knowing you all.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Hello!
Oh, yeah, we definitely could have held that.
Oh, yeah.
We would have held that.
We rotated our odds.
Oh.
I was 99.
That was unlucky.
That was 99 for all.
That's so unlucky.
Bad time.
He actually got me at 99.
98 or 90 not What the fuck?
I can be reckless now.
Oh, there he is
I don't know why I have to play tank enough of any player That's not making a whole lot of sense I hear him I hear him Yeah, don't mess with the amazing spider-man That's it, I'm locking Invis I'm locking in this.
I ain't playing.
I ain't playing Luna anymore.
I can't.
I'm not strong enough.
I'm not.
Goodbye, everyone.
Goodbye.
Hello, everyone.
Goodbye again.
just like you, ma'am.
I wish I could jump to high ground.
We're like, care in the world.
Wow.
That seems so fun.
I wish I also...
Oh, dragons out.
It's no longer...
oh my god he's so low too he's so low
oh my god the reload
he's opening it he's doing it
i would say fried seems to be really good at he seems to be really good at um Oh my god, he's actually won, dude.
That's the worst part.
Oh, no!
No!
Okay, it's fine.
That's unlucky.
That's...
That's actually so unlucky.
We all died.
There's a lost cause.
Yeah.
The top five OG is a lost cause we just dooming jesus christ where did i go
all right all right it's okay it's okay it's okay everything is okay everything is fine it's fine you know i'm just having a wonderful game with my just a wonderful game it's not winnable it's fine sometimes games just aren't winnable sometimes oh my god you fucking coward oh you don't want to get frozen you little bitch jesus christ 60 seconds of help
oh okay
okay um okay what the fuck what was this all what am i We should have forfeited.
I really, why am I spending my time?
Oh my god, why?
Why did we put ourselves through this, guys?
Why?
We could have forfeited this.
Why did we put ourselves through this?
This is absolute hell.
Right now, I'm going through hell.
It's like we make zero profit.
Okay, that's fine.
There you go.
I'm ready.
I'm dancing.
Yippee.
Yes, I'm having so much fun.
Oh, oh.
I want to just barring out everyone.
Yep.
Also, just living up on me playing time because you just live on DVL.
Why?
It would have been over.
They let us cap on purpose.
There's no way.
There's no way they like seriously just fucked up.
They're here to farm more stats off of us.
There's no way they would do this to me.
Like, I refuse to believe that.
Wow.
I refuse to believe that this happened.
There's no way, this is not real.
There's no, it's not real.
They're throwing for content.
I refuse, I refuse to believe that, that I have to play this so much longer.
Still got an edge.
Oh my god, why would they do this to me?
How is he still alive?
The current score is 3, 2, 3 Okay.
There's no way.
okay okay the torture continues the dream is alive i don't feel alive
oh i was just not fun against venom spider that's it that's it i have fun anything but this oh my god but venom spotter venom spotters is where i draw the line because i can do everything i can i can freeze the venom i can play everything correctly and then i still die i still die it doesn't matter That's cinematic.
Am I gonna get wrapped away?
Let's see.
Jesus Christ.
I need to reload, ma'am.
Ma'am, I gotta reload.
I gotta keep reloading.
Okay.
No.
Oh my god.
Oh no, we lost our strength.
No.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, no!
No, I refuse to believe.
Believing is... I've already believed too much.
I refuse...
The current score is...
Three.
Time to switch things out.
You can't live through that.
I...
That was...
That was a nuke.
The moon is a shine in darkness.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
How do I react to that?
How?
How do you react to that?
How do you...
There's no reaction.
There's actually...
I can't react.
to it they aim that my head they
even if i i don't think i can dodge that i i don't think it was possible to dodge that at all i don't think if i was uh i guess if i was group i feel like if i was further away but i was i was trying to get out of the tp there was a tp i think if i was with my team my team would have oh man i don't know we should i don't know when we went double tank it was pretty bad yeah i was literally the coughing baby i was just like oh okay i guess i'll die here today Oh
I think it's over Oh my god Um, oh
my god I just can't Oh,
I can't I can't guys.
I can't play Luna I can't I can't anymore Bro, I can't anymore I can't give me I can't do this anymore I'm not playing rocket I'm not doing this anymore I'm no don't worry I've got a rest it's your lucky day I live, I just don't work.
Um, I assume...
It's your lucky day.
It's your luck, it's your actual lucky day.
The next day survive.
Okay.
Oh.
It's fine.
We double support up, but it's fine.
We don't have support alts anymore, but it's okay.
Oh, wait.
Maybe.
I'll stay up here.
I don't think he's healing
okay I'm gonna let him heal
okay that's good that's good I have no idea what is going on but I do Oh my god, she destroyed my res.
She destroyed my res.
Oh my
This is not good
Sorry, I just couldn't play Luna again.
I couldn't I like that it was See the moment I swapped off Luna he swapped off Potter, man.
Because there was no more targets.
He couldn't do anything anymore.
I just couldn't.
It was too much.
I'm just not strong enough.
It's not a rain climb.
It's just a doom kill.
There's no such thing as climbing during a doom kill.
Alright, what was this guy's name?
I want to see if they won.
They hit their profile like a bitch.
Like a coward.
I want to know.
I'll just be like, who are you?
Who are you?
I don't even know what they added me.
They were the ones that added me.
Best first message ever.
They added me.
What do you mean?
I just want to know who they are.
I'm just existing.
You're a fan.
Mopko fat.
What?
Who?
What's Mopko fat?
What does that mean?
Mopko fat.
wait what does that even mean oh my god it's my is that good for something
okay mob co fat they have a tick tock oh my god they have a twitch
wait what Are they a real player?
Wait, are they?
Wait, are they an actual real player?
Wait, they think they have a Marvel Rivals.
I think they're a Marvel Rivals.
Oh my god, they're in the Marvel Rivals team.
Wait, are you in the Ignite?
The Ignite player?
I literally I was like Muff go fat
Oh my god They're in the They're in They're called their team's called aura farmer Nice
They're in They were in the Asia Oh my god this is their Alt account, then.
Then they don't care!
Wait, their alt account is level 65?
Jesus, wait, was it?
What was the level of their...
Their alt account is...
Bro, their alt account is four levels up below me.
What was it?
Level 65?
I don't remember.
Yeah, I literally looked up...
I, like, Googled it, and then it was like...
And they have a deadlock account, you know, because I love stalking, you guys.
I love...
He said...
Oh my god, I...
Oh my god!
I can't...
I'm still stuck in Luna jail.
There, he's in the aura of...
I don't know if he's...
Man, he man.
Wish.
GG, we got the biggest nib on grit you've ever seen.
That's a speck of knowledge.
Yes.
Because I was like, who is this cat?
Who's Mopko Fett?
I can't believe we will Mega Load him.
To be fair, I'm not well versed in the China Ignite teams.
I only know the...
I like their team name.
Their team name is ORA Farmer.
And it's the title ORA.
And he's wearing a hat.
Oh, yes.
Oh, it is!
He is.
He is in Ignite.
Guys, we who Mega Lel the Pearl.
To be fair, I have an excuse.
I don't know.
I don't know the China scene for Ignite as well.
I just know...
What's his name?
I just know two players.
I forgot their names.
But I do know two players.
I just forgot their names.
Okay, I guess I play...
Oh my god, I don't have to play.
Oh my god.
Thank the Lord.
I guess I have to play cloak
Ultra Mantis.
I would love to play Ultra Mantis, but if we can get I don't play Mantis though sadly I can play Mantis can someone play
Can someone play ultra?
It's time we can try this for long if it doesn't work.
I can search All right You're an ultra We can try that.
That bond is unbreakable.
Wait, I'll turn it open?
Oh my god, he talks like a European XQC.
No, they banned Sue, so they're gonna have an Angela.
Isn't he?
Sounds like a European XQC.
What?
Doesn't he?
He had it.
No, XQC is a French-Canadian.
It's different.
okay we got a pick one up guys oh yeah he does I can't get it out of my head now
oh my god
he's actually from France instead of fake
he's like a calmer a slightly calmer version of him which surprisingly it's we have XQC at home we have the authentic French XQC there you go I got you Luna why did you Don't worry, look at that!
Look at that!
There we go.
Excuse me.
I'll show you.
Alright.
I'll let you know.
They just switched the mag, right?
Okay.
All right, Luna you can all first.
Oh, they're going to the right side with all.
They're going to the right side with all.
Let's try and kill them, Zy.
I've got a pick and I look...
What the?
Oh, where did he come from?
What?
Holy shit!
Where is he?
Okay, okay, I got you.
Oh, where is the fuck?
This is XQC actually speaks English.
Wait, what is he doing awake at this time?
Oh, he got inspired, right?
Ocean hug, ocean hug.
I just realized the...
The Ignite, the China Ignite play.
Oh my god, I can bring another pro down.
That's an honor.
Oh, this is a lot.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Good luck, everyone.
Wait, Mike can die though.
Mike can die.
Oh, he doesn't.
He doesn't.
Actually, maybe.
I'm always far clear.
Okay.
Oh, get out, get out.
Nice, nice.
Push that one.
There we go.
Nice, nice.
By the way, Phoenix, Phoenix.
Hello.
Goodbye.
I didn't want to ult that, but it was scary.
It was getting scary.
Oh my god, I got the damage, bro.
We have no other triple support if all fails If all it fails he does oh my god.
We're so fucked.
We're so we're so fucked.
We're so fucked We are so alive.
We're so oh my god.
We're so alive.
We're so I don't know how we live that Holy fuck It's so over It's not over yet I don't like tripping.
You know, we couldn't see her, I think.
I'm pretty sure she's...
All I'm saying is if he has...
If that is an alt account, I want me to get rid of more alt accounts.
Rocket, rocket, right side.
Rocket, right side.
He's one, he's one, he's one.
Strange is pushing us behind.
Strange is pushing behind.
Oh, shit!
Wait.
Nice.
Alright, it's fine.
Honey's behind the floor.
Nice, baby.
Where were these games?
Where the fuck were these guys?
I'm coming back everyone.
Don't worry, the hero is here.
The hero is...
It's fine, it's fine.
She's so healthy.
He's so healthy.
There's a dude on the right side.
Oh, nice.
Goodbye.
Maybe I can get him on the last day.
Because I'm like, what time is it over there now?
What time is it?
Jesus, he's midnight.
Gamers don't sleep, though.
gamers don't sleep it's like what time is in asia nice after this game i'm only 25 games yeah wins in a row for rank one let's go what uh i wish you good luck with that who's this guy holy close yeah wait who is he dota 9 why is right who's who's dota not much
Like, when you really think about it, that's it.
It's really not that much like.
25 games.
I can't...
I can't stop imagining European XQC.
Yeah, I told you!
It is European XQC!
He sounds like...
But, like...
From Europe.
It's all I hear.
Yeah.
I just The buff is inside He's gonna be sitting at next time Here we go Weewee I am Groot We're walking, we're walking We're walking We're walking I am Groot I am Groot I am Groot I'm Groot Oh, oh, that's unfortunate.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I can recognize he needs a little bit of healing.
Good luck.
We don't know, right?
I think they don't.
Oh!
I saw him, they blew up the smoke and I was like, oh.
I should leave.
I should really leave now.
Okay, I should.
Emma is pushing us.
Emma's pushing us.
Emma behind.
Emma behind left side.
She's one.
I got close.
I only have one here.
Okay.
Is this winnable?
I just have one.
Oh shit!
Oh I lost it!
I lost it.
He got cancelled.
I got cancelled.
I don't know what by me.
I got cancelled by Phoenix.
Let's get into some good trouble.
Again!
That's unlucky.
I should.
I'm gonna go Mantis.
That's unlucky.
I can't really go.
I'm about to kill the Luna.
Yeah.
Oh, this is unlucky.
I will turn.
Clapping.
Oh my god.
I have to be in it.
Four, three, four, two, one.
My ult is over.
Go back.
Oh, I can't do anything.
I got kicked.
Oh My god, I have to I have to
I'm here.
Okay, nice
Nice Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, that was the code.
Oh my god, please.
This is scary.
Stop trying to cover the heels, everyone.
That's okay.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Lucky one, lucky one.
I, oh my.
Nice, nice, nice.
That's good.
Oh my god, the focus so high.
I can drag him.
I I'm just using here
Oh my god
It's fine.
It's just it's fine.
Just let me die It's fine Oh, he did it
Oh my god!
We were just trolling.
We were stagnant so badly for no reason.
We already had one fight in two minutes.
I had to focus so hard to stay alive.
Why was that game so hard?
I had to focus so hard.
I was just like, my brain was like fucking running on fumes for that match.
Oh my god.
to lock in jesus that's scary that's so fucking scary yeah because like we were running uh what was it the phoenix the phoenix was us up
all right i'm used to bathroom i gotta gotta pee i'll be right back
i'm back guys all right do we ask this guy to play and bring him down to the thing is if we play if we play in his elo and like if we play and like he gets in the gm lobby he loses more and i gain more
and so we can perfectly balance our elo
oh it's a win-win because i'm a gm lobby these that's evil i've already lost so much what well all right i'll play it i need to walk him in after this after one more yeah and you dragged them all down go to sleep we are getting evil oh do you want to do
Wait, are you top 500 right now on that account?
Okay.
Is that weird to ask?
Is that a weird question to ask?
Is that what that...
I need to know.
I just want to know, you know?
Is it...
Is it weird for me to ask?
What the fuck is my lobby?
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
All right, no save yourself.
Oh my oh my god
Who am I gonna vanish from this match?
Yeah, but Who are you ignite player?
Okay, are you?
Is this an alt account?
Okay, is it top 500?
What?
Which one's Necros?
This is Andrew and this is Necros?
Is that it?
Oh my god, I streamed so long.
That's Necros hours.
That's how long I've been streaming for it.
It's Necro's hours now.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
I'm in too deep, boys.
I'm in too deep now.
He's not even...
Is he even streaming?
Or did he just start stream?
He literally just started stream?
can fill, but I diff everyone in this lobby.
Ah!
God damn it.
GM the chill.
I don't even get anything from these lobbies.
The actual Magneto.
Wow.
Should I know who you are?
I don't even do you get it.
That's not true.
Necrows?
Are you talking about the other team?
Are you talking about the enemy team?
Yeah, I was like, he's not even live unless he's like warming up.
Oh my god, just realized we're playing fucking Torch.
Oh my god, they're running triple support.
Oh my god.
Yeah, you see him?
our fucking court yeah that's it yeah you can tell that he you can tell this is a higher elo lobby
oh my god i'm so low so low
this is not looking so good Oh, he's not.
They're not.
Okay, that's good.
Oh, my god, this is such a crit.
I think he, there's no way he doesn't have.
I can't.
Fucked up, fucked up, fucked up.
And now they are gonna have Lenovo.
Oh my god.
I thought...
Bro, I hate...
I hate shooting these torches.
That's why I didn't have my shield.
Okay, I have my ult though.
Oh my god, please.
Please live.
Oh my god.
I am ready to put on a show.
Yeah, I live.
Oh, that's so...
Let's see it.
Like, look at this!
Look at!
Look at his fucking pooping!
How do I do?
How do you...
I don't know what the fuck you're doing.
You kill the list
Like I don't know Kill the fucking point Oh my god There's a torch Just shoot him Stay key They have no TP, stay key Oh my Get off time Just give support please I don't know what you're doing Please just let me do time I'm doing my fine boy I'm doing fine No you're not Are you shooting the touch?
Are you shooting nothing?
What?
Oh my god, bro!
Let's get me out of here!
Bro, you can tell I have not...
Bro, I have not...
Bro, I have...
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, I am.
Oh my god, I'm freaking...
Jesus Christ.
I hate this.
I hate healing this.
This is apt.
I hate...
Oh no.
That's it.
Yeah, I can't.
I can't afford this game.
You can sleep.
Holy moly.
That is everybody.
Stop fighting!
Not really bothering me.
No, no, no, no, we can win this.
I'm not going to this guy.
Yeah, we have a kiddie pie, baby.
I'll do this.
It's fine.
Okay, I can go.
I can go.
Oh, what is going on?
Oh, why are we...
Oh, please!
There's a torch behind me!
Super Nova!
This is it.
I can't... I can't play.
I can't solo support this.
Don't make...
Stay in these.
Don't go walk in.
I don't really want us to stay in this.
I want support.
You're doing a lot of value.
Good job.
I'll patch you up.
Ooh, that felt nice.
Are we... Okay, okay, there we go.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
There's a human touch and strange on her back line.
Anyone willing to help?
Feeling fantastic.
I hate this.
Bro.
This is so rough.
This is actually, yeah, this is so rough.
This, this is so rough.
This is so rough.
Like, how am I gonna survive?
How do I survive this?
They have so much more pressure than I like how did Jeff realize this the Jeff is like wait a minute Why are you talking when you're on one fight?
Why you're talking like my torch is uh, I don't know constantly Why Like not really his fault No Bro there's a torch bomb I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to do.
No it's just it's it's time.
It's time to swap servers.
Can we save him?
It's fine.
Look how hard it is look how hard it is to heal this One oh my god Look how hard look at his movement Just kill him kill me Oh, no Like look at this movement Like at this How do I heal this as if it is
It's just
I'm just gonna save my shield for this guy I can't I legitimately I can't I can't actually heal him like look at this it's actual cancer like I need my Jeff to do the healing for him that it's not me
Like, what am I looking?
Holy shit.
Okay.
Oh my god, there he is.
Torch it balls, Taryn.
He's one of you.
What the?
Oh my god.
This is hell.
Oh
Okay Oh my god, I hope
Oh my god, I got hit here Nice
Probably above it.
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye Oh my god, it's two of us.
It's two of us.
I've a little bit i'm so all right can we even start a little bit we're picking way too long to be oh just the two of us time to switch things i feel like i'm getting hard bullied right now I...
Why did we leave Torch?
I hate playing.
Oh my god, I'm too...
Why are you still fighting?
You're so bad, bro.
You're Lord and Luna.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna play Luna.
I'm gonna curse.
Stop fighting, please.
Okay, I'll give him the thing and then your lucky rig is here or I will run you down Oh, don't care.
Run down, you fucking moron.
Come on.
Shut up.
You are legit fucking.
You are legit fucking illustrious, by the way, and you are fucking hard stuck.
Never get fucking one of a hole in your life.
You remember that.
you know in the game block each other go next oh my god let's keep it positive we got to see talk i guess and do we i have i guess what happened what happened this is i was curious one of you just thought remember i was nothing he's a bollywood star he's really a bollywood star i'm not getting disrespect from bollywood star i don't care
Combs and less yapping.
Oh my god, what's going on?
Shitting stain, shooting stain, shooting stain, shooting stain.
Shitting mag, shooting mag.
My car's on, my car's on.
Touching that backlight.
North right side, North right side.
Phoenix on top.
Okay.
Oh, dead.
Shitting mag, shooting mag, shooting mag.
You're all of you are fucking on HP.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
Jesus Christ Mike one Mike one Mike one one Hi, this is where I die.
Goodbye everyone.
It was great knowing you.
Goodbye Oh my god.
Oh my god.
That's very sad Oh, I didn't realize the portal was God.
I did not realize they just put the portal down.
That's a little embarrassing.
Are you serious?
He broke the wall broke and it hit me.
That's so unlucky.
using the walls covered too i'm so i guess i'll swap back to i think invis was less scary i think the the ping is definitely hurting me a lot right now here for sure Is there a one in the box?
Top one, top one, top one.
How do we load?
Oh my gosh, I had to use this.
Top one, top one, top one.
Oh, please.
This is one of those moments where...
Oh, stranger left.
Oh my the 160 ping is hurting me for real
Goodbye I froze them but he would I'm dead
Oh my god, get me outing!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this sucks.
This actually sucks.
Oh my god.
You know, I thought I'd be playing low yellow game, so I didn't work, I didn't, I didn't fucking care about i didn't care about ping but this this is torture this is actual torture and i'm oh dummy map no venom i can tell it was still it's the actual torture right now Okay,
last one, last one.
I'm gonna move my free bed.
What do I do?
Okay.
I just got here.
Hello, everyone.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
Okay.
I have 11 deaths, but I was heavily bullied.
I feel...
I feel like I'm getting heavily bullied right now.
I think this is it.
I think this is the last EU kill I'm playing.
This might be...
Don't, I'm not strong enough anymore.
Okay.
I am locking in.
I'm doing my best to lock in.
What?
You're too deep bro.
You're too deep, bro.
Why?
I don't know.
I'm gonna go.
By the eye of Agumon.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Okay, bye.
I'm just trying to stall.
Hello, everyone.
They have new supports.
I'm healing.
It's okay.
We have only Mantis heals.
Careful.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
It's absolutely fine.
Nice.
Like, it's fine.
It's okay.
follow you up to deep my route i need to go venom spot venom
oh my oh oh she couldn't hold the timing for that was so good oh my god
i'm gonna get eaten bro
that was hell that was absolute hell i i think i was i had to deal with so much bullshit there during that game like i felt like i was getting hard targeted I felt I felt I felt like I could not do anything we didn't have any support I'd lost 23 this was a this was an act this was Celestia 1 lobby what was I supposed to do I was fending for my fucking life I I swear to God I was fighting for my life there we had zero I was the only support player and like
and like I was fighting I was trying and then and then the nobody turned around for me for the torch all right wait oh do you want to do
we do it we go back to to NA.
We could go back to NA.
I don't think I want to do EU anymore after that.
Did you want to do a... Wait.
I'm sorry.
After that game, it was so fucked.
It was...
Oh yeah.
After, after, okay, I actually have to walk that, yeah.
But I gotta, I gotta walk my dog, go.
And I might stop, I know, and I think, okay, wait, I think I wanna stop EUQs after hell.
After that hell game.
I wanted to that game was terrible
no it wasn't that it was the fact that I was the only support player and and like my other support like I was getting hard focused by every single all there was as loon I should have just went in this I should have just went in this all right i'll go walk the doggo i'll be right back everybody let me put the text real quick wait that's no that's i mean that felt like it too um walking a doggo be right back is it this
there you go and then we'll have this here and then you guys get this all right there you go all right i'll be right back everyone
i am back did you guys enjoyed the show without me did you did everyone enjoyed the little show
oh why oh because i had to i had to be rb because i had to walk the dog Doggo has been walked.
Alright, give me a sec.
For the other guy.
Oh, he disappeared.
Forever.
Okay, I'm back.
Our victim left.
You can queue.
Unlucky.
The victim is gone.
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad, everyone.
We were so close.
He knew.
He knew my plan.
My third moderate.
I hate it.
My third moderate dies if I stream too long.
That's what I can't do, like, I don't know what's wrong with my third monitor.
Because sometimes it just dies.
I don't know what to do.
Like, there's no counter to it.
Oh, my match history is mega private.
So people won't know.
People won't know how much I've suffered.
It's just, like, it dies whenever, like, whenever, like, I stream too long.
but I personally think it's not long enough oh he got his new toy I bought this new toy for him new toy for dad and it has like five squeakers and he's destroyed all the squeakers except for one because there's like squeakers in like each section of this giant cat caterpillar toy and I bought it yesterday and he's destroyed all of them except for one.
Oh, he even got off line.
Oh, my God.
He got off.
He got off line.
I wrote, do you want to do him?
And he never even got off line.
He was online when I messaged him.
He ran far.
Far away.
He's gone.
God.
He's like, scatter.
I love him.
How far until you derink.
You gotta know.
Because if you derink, we can add third victim.
I'm...
Are you...
One game away?
To...
Gosh, gosh darn it.
Thank God.
That's...
Aww.
Oh.
Okay.
unlucky all right oh my god there's a diamond on which hero do you think you want to be today if we lose this we lose a lot because the enemy team has a diamond i think i want to go back to eu i you can add eu you can add eu back into the you.
This is definitely worse.
This is worse.
Hey, maybe Rixie, dodge and dodge now.
Let me be free.
I can't believe he ran away too late too late to back down now oh here we go it's
okay maybe we'll get more victims maybe we'll encounter more never back there is a diamond this might be the one lost that they're actually
yeah we when we get like 15 points or some shit is crazy life is just not fair who would have thought okay oh my god why do we have a spotty mess
oh my god why back at it again alright rixie does not want to derink into my my rank right now he's like he even picked a match this bro this guy never barely ever plays triple support and he's that desperate sounds like you have some pretty amazing friends he is He's not fucking around.
I didn't even see it.
Does anyone see if the diamond was a smurf or not?
Good with the levels.
Anyone see?
Because I didn't.
He's fighting where his life now.
It's like, no.
Don't do this.
Oh my god.
I don't know if that's our Angela.
Okay.
I was worried.
We should destroy these arcs.
Oh, Wigsie is not...
Never mind.
Oh my god.
I have to play in this.
Not out of...
Not because I want...
Oh my god, I have to play in this.
I...
Please!
I can't...
I can't play this.
I can't play...
I can't play that into that.
Oh my god.
In fact, I think I have to play Rocket.
That's like not the most ideal for me.
I cannot.
I am not playing Luna against that.
Guys, I am not.
I don't care.
I'm not playing Luna against whatever the shit I just saw.
Holy shit, what the fuck is this?
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
What?
How?
Thank god.
It's fine.
Oh shit, okay.
It's still fine.
This is this is I don't know how I died to that though.
I should not have died to Oh, it's gonna be like telling me like it's your friendly neighborhood spider-man Don't mess with the amazing spider-man and then we all ran away.
Oh my god Okay Where They will never know They would never know.
How would they know?
Was the diamond one and 11?
Wait, who's the diamond one?
This fucking hella has been in just the most random spots all game.
Get me out of here.
Get me...
Get...
What is this TP?
Get me...
We don't know.
They don't see this.
They don't know.
What am I playing?
Plus 15.
Dude, that's the worst part.
Dad's like, yeah.
What is happening?
What the fuck is happening?
I'm surviving.
I don't know what he's talking about.
I think he's just really excited.
Like, what the fuck?
We got two throws.
He's mad.
Little teeny thor, baby.
Survive.
I will always be playing.
What are you guys talking about?
I will always be playing rivals It sucks.
I think I'll be playing I have to play raccoon more for next season too Because he's like crazy fucking buff right now That's the worst part
if he dies then come where I got you what the fuck is going on everybody was so up there it is maybe they'll get the res they get the res no that's fine that's fine I don't know what's going what the fuck I wasn't throwing hello there is
There's so many TP!
Here we go!
This is real firepower!
Oh.
Goodbye.
Wait, where's Res?
Maybe we lost something.
What is going on?
Oh, what is going on?
See, this is why I do if I'm okay.
I will say if I was on any other support, I will not live Like oh my god Guys, please guys, can we not?
Guys, let's not.
Oh guys, guys Guys, hey, can we not play?
Yeah, hi is deep deep can we walk together as a team oh no there's so many dps can we walk together everyone oh my god is that something we are able to oh my god i hear
Okay.
This is five.
Guys.
Guys, please.
I don't know what to expect from my team The fact that they were able to cap 73% is concerning me.
Okay, it's okay.
I am happy that I was on the other side of it.
Oh my god!
me out of here holy there we go what the was the all right thank god i thank god i saw i i don't think i could have lived as any other support player i'll patch you up there was no way i was gonna live against a two four five dps and two of them were dive i i do not think it was would have been possible.
And one was apparently an Angela, too.
Oh, my God!
Get me out of here.
That's crazy.
I still have...
Yay!
She made it.
We...
Game, guys.
GG.
I bet I get plus 15 plus 15 this has to be there's no way this was not a real game it has to be a plus 15 game there's no way
oh my god plus eight I'm no no I'll take it I'm so good oh it's so delicious I take those.
Yum, yum, yum.
I'll, the joy, did you avoid the diamond player?
The rivals are such a kind master.
Yum, yum, yum.
I don't even know who was the diamond.
GM, okay, I'll do it.
I don't want him to be honest.
Okay, Grandmaster 1.
The jamming toasty.
Oh, wait.
I think he's a legit diamond player.
Oh, my God.
He is.
Wait, he is a legit...
Okay.
Wait.
I just avoided it.
Alright.
How could you tell it?
Jesus Christ That was a game How is the dooming going on?
Are you ranked?
Is that a good answer?
Oh, pizza's on
Let's see It's a guy turn So I can't fuck his game He's up.
Fuck his memes up, sadly.
He's been, he's been, he queues every day, six plus hours a day.
I mean, that's almost like me, but the difference is that he climbs.
I don't know.
Damn.
Six, actually, like, maybe like six to eight hours a day.
But he actually got to eternity.
He like was up and down.
Like, no, he...
Sometimes he is, because he plays like...
Fuck you, Blade.
Blade and Fantastic.
The support...
Yeah, support can only do so much.
Oh my god, wait, he's back online.
He's back.
He went on a walk.
too yeah why didn't he respond to the duo request he responded to everything else you think he knows like I'm not throwing I'm not he's just my aura I drag everyone down not my fault he knows I'm cursed
I don't know what you mean.
Look, even though I'm cursed, it's still a fun time for me.
We don't talk about that one match where...
Where I got, like, absolutely fucked.
We don't talk about that game.
That game was just a mess in general.
It was actually...
It was just, like, a roller coaster.
I got, like...
I...
heavily aggressed on.
Like, that was not a fair game whatsoever.
Jesus Christ, where they have two top 500 on you.
Why am I in these lobbies?
I'm just a little guy.
Please don't make me play.
Please don't make me play Luna.
I'm so done with Luna.
I'm trying to drag you down my Elo.
Why you no respawn?
Oh, man.
I don't like... I don't like Lunar and the cold water.
Lunar and current... Did you guys... Okay, that game where I got, like, ran out by four dive characters was not fun at all.
It was a trulia.
I sent... Yeah.
I sent you an invitation to become an Elo terrorist.
With me please respond I was shoved into a locker and you're like you're not coming out of spawn I'm like, please sir.
I just want to play the game
They wouldn't even let me leave the spawn door
Alright, here you go.
That's cool.
That's cool though finding out that other pro player Watch me I don't know why But They're not learning anything But that's cool I It's like Do they take enjoyment Out of my pain Like I don't know It's just For me when pro players watch me I'm like Why are you watching me I'm just like You're just like Watching me play rivals and getting like shit on by three times kid is like thank god that's not me like because they're definitely not learning they're not learning from me
enjoy my my suffering
they like to see me suffer what has victor gotten us into oh thank god oh wait i should have played I didn't realize I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, no, thank God.
Actually, that's good.
I went.
That's good that I went.
Okay, I didn't want to...
I don't have another push though.
I'm trying to like use... Oh, what the fuck?
That's unlucky.
That's so unlucky.
Oh no.
It's definitely harder to...
It's definitely harder to do a push because of the ping.
It's harder to control it.
I think if it was...
If I was playing any, I could do the push easier.
Jesus, I have to be aware.
There we go.
Got the push, guys!
I did it!
Oh my god.
Oh, I thought...
Oh.
You know, I thought he would.
I honestly thought he would.
Oh.
That is not good.
Hello.
Rise!
I timed it incorrectly.
Oh my god.
He's gonna do a Beyblade.
He's gonna do the Beyblade.
We gotta save her.
Oh my god!
It's okay.
I believe in her.
I sacrificed myself to heal the Luna.
Because I knew the Luna is European.
And so the ping is on her side I save her Because I knew she's actually from EU So ping is on her side Because I ain't killing anybody I was not killing her Wait what?
Oh my god The push went off of my This is why I fucked this Actually fuck this
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Okay, Jesus, I hate Beyblade.
Oh my god, what happened?
I got, she had ping advantage.
Look, all I'm saying, if this was, if you were on my territory, it oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god okay there there you go Where am I?
Oh shit!
Okay, okay.
He got somebody.
She's a beautiful creature.
Oh, my poor guy.
There we go.
That.
Oh, nice.
Hopefully.
Look, I lived though.
I lived.
We don't Don't talk about the Adam of note, but I live.
We didn't ask to be heroes, but we always answer the call.
This is why I like him this more.
Yeah, rest in peace, Adam.
The mag was like, where is she?
And then he's like, oh, there's someone that can't walk today.
He fucking knocked this shins out.
Play for us.
You can try and combo Phoenix if you want.
I consider playing significantly less painful video games.
Look, at least I don't play league.
There's always a true...
Look, I could always go lower when you're lucky.
No, absolutely.
Bro, he's just...
Bro, I'm...
Bro, I'm just...
Oh, crap.
My tiny little...
Okay, I'm break.
I broke it.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
I hope our Adam is somewhere very safe.
Oh, never mind.
He was absolutely not somewhere very...
Oh, very unfortunate.
Guys, he was not somewhere very safe.
Yeah, our Adam...
was, was, was not having it.
That's shit, bro.
Jesus, that was...
Do it.
I'm gonna open with your rock, right?
Oh, I didn't see you.
Don't be off.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Okay, okay, that was...
Hey, goodbye.
That, that, yeah.
That lag was crazy.
Yeah.
That was some crazy-ass lag right there.
I got to recharge my shield.
Oh my god, this is not good.
This is not good for me.
Why am I?
This one's saying it's so much harder.
It's definitely harder to push the Angela of this ping.
Oh my gosh, she's looking.
She's scouting.
She's like, where does she go?
Oh no, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Can you walk towards me and I'm not?
There we go.
It's okay, we're...
I feel safe.
I guess I'm by accident.
Okay.
All right, we got we saved.
That was very scary, guys.
That could have gone very wrong because I almost fucked up.
I almost killed someone.
You are nothing!
What?
Are you...
Okay.
That was scary.
We all just...
All of us were just looking at it.
We're like, what's going on?
Fine, fine, fine.
Look, we just...
There we go.
I can't hold our attention.
Is that one?
Is that canceling?
Okay, I cannot cancel again.
I'm working on the map.
It's working on this.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
I...
I don't know how much more do you want me to do there.
There we go.
It was to a certain top of this.
I like how it just like...
Look, we gotta...
We gotta make sure that...
I'm sure it doesn't hit me.
I'll just like, what's going on?
Enjoy the nerfs, buddy.
End of season, Doom queue.
Bro.
What?
Is this?
What's going on?
Bro.
Europeans.
You, you, you.
Are you okay?
Um, are you okay?
No, the Bucky is like, question mark, question mark, question mark.
He's trying to say the Bucky.
He's like, trying to say the Bucky.
The gamer words.
Not the Bucky saying the gamer word.
Try to call him the gamer word.
Yeah, probably news, right?
News censored, right?
Oh my god.
Are you okay over there?
This has been my history.
It's been pretty rough.
This one was the roughest.
No, no.
The roughest was the one where I lost seven games in a row.
That's gone now.
It's off the record.
It's gone now.
It doesn't exist anymore.
It never happened.
Oh yeah, nice.
I wish I could keep that, but I can't.
Ugh.
You get now kisses from mom.
I want kisses.
Hello.
Jeff is here.
Hello fellow roleplayers.
Hello.
Where are the other Jeffs?
Hello Jeffs.
Evil Jeffs.
Which one is hello?
Hey.
Whoa.
Hello.
Oh, you killed me.
Oh, my god.
That will be...
Poor Jack.
I was...
I was like...
What's the word?
Oh.
I was like the bystander, a victim.
No honor among just invisible woman.
I was like a victim.
I literally just walked over and got kicked.
Oh, I'm in the East Coast now.
I'm back at the East Coast, baby.
Back at any lobby.
Guys, I know I said I'm going to fix my sleep schedule, but I don't know if I'm going to make it.
I guess I'm scared.
I don't think I don't know if I'm going to make it.
I'm feeling it now.
I'm actually feeling it.
That's my Oshi.
this i can do this i need to fix it it's so bad i need to fix it before my business trip i really do why are you my pets what are our pets save what the are we for real
I'm rank one side Who are you
Cheap?
There's no The only Who's the rank one?
It was like Tap, right?
Cheaper tap?
We're banning Scylark in season four Why?
In season four No, we have two We have two play had a fucking spidey one-trick fucking forcing or flexing Loki and he played like shit so what does that have to do with silo because uh people people be thinking this shit is good
oh Luna jail I still think these heroes are good Luna jail time yeah yeah yeah I am lords La la la, Luna Dale, because I have to call Luna when I play with an Ultron.
No fun.
No fun for me.
He is Hela Dead.
Alright.
La la la.
I am Lord.
Alright.
Can you go pick right now?
Don't fuck a thing in.
Oh, yeah, he's dead, dead.
Oh my god, this is their dead take.
This is not a front line.
Bro.
Oh, bro.
Oh my god, the car.
The car is fucking the upright.
Where's our mantis?
Does she use this?
Oh, she's behind us.
I was gonna say, where did our mantis go?
Okay.
Oh, you got it.
Like, this is not a front line at all.
Alright, this is fine.
I just want to build up.
Alright, now I push.
Go!
Wait, he's not going.
Oh, I wanted to push.
Wait.
I don't know who this- Oh.
I was gonna say, what the fuck happened?
I don't think- wait, maybe?
Oh, he lives.
What the fuck is going on?
That's just you know, oh, oh Nice, oh my god the boy BC doesn't work.
I got kicked up.
I got kicked out of BC.
Oh my god.
Oh my god Where am I?
Okay, where am I?
Actually, where am I though
Okay, it's fine It's not fine.
It's not.
Okay, it's not fine anymore.
Oh, they're running.
Triples.
No chat.
DPS only.
That's a lie.
That's a fucking lie.
Punisher.
For who?
What was our DPS before?
Oh, it was Hella.
Okay.
That's it.
Oh, goodbye.
Hello.
Hey, we got a little staircase.
I have... okay.
Oh my god.
I'm not okay.
I am not...
I am not okay.
This is not good.
Because we're all so split up.
Guys, please.
Any chance I can start load.
Maybe.
I am not doing okay.
Bro, everyone needs help.
Oh my god.
Everyone needs help right now.
It's not just you.
You're not special.
everyone is struggling oh he's so dead
oh my god oh my god oh thank god we went in this thank god okay i can all the punishers i miss i miss when it was so easy because they had no fun line i missed that that was
okay you're welcome i saved your fucking life you're fucking welcome
jesus christ you're all crazy you're home in this wait where where is she Oh my!
Oh!
I've still got songs to sing.
Where did my Invis go?
Where did she go?
It's like I just don't exist to it.
There's no...
She's not a...
She's not a support player.
She disappeared.
Don't you hate it when they just suck ya?
At least she still has it though.
Okay, yeah, no, they're not like living that.
They should be going towards.
Okay, good luck everyone.
Okay, I guess I'll go inside.
Okay, good luck everybody.
Good luck everyone.
I see where my Invis was.
was I it's okay no no no it's okay it's okay it's okay I I don't matter in the grand scheme of things and I I know I I just I just I don't matter I'm just I'm not I'm not like if it's
okay I have accepted it she was going through her own crisis okay it's fine to switch things up including which side you're on I'm gonna snow like you guys are gonna need more than one who are you what the fuck are you I took it by by Vance arrived in like What is this?
Is this like in his own little reality in his head?
But he's him I'm like gonna look up this name and then he's also an ignite player from like I don't know from oh no this is N.A Like South America like I just don't know I just know N.A.
Ignite players and like a couple of EU
he's it's the rifton you don't know him it's the vibe right vibe that's a rifton my my dude
what were we playing what the fuck was our comp before the battle starts in five four three two two a man the legend rifton
use clap now just hello you guys can deal with it I'll deal with bottom don't worry I've got you Lopez number one siloed there I was like oh wait oh yeah they are he went from triple support a one support the two others support players were like no you know what fuck this I shall do damage now no more healing oh my god now oh my god what is this like how are two the two take players are like I like my rule the two take players are like I ain't swapping I bet you it's Like...
There's...
Jeez.
This is sad.
I deserve this.
Three games in a row where there were throwers.
Finally!
The Doom has balanced out!
Fucking finally!
The Doom has finally balanced!
Alright.
Surrender?
The E and OMM give us and take us.
You just need five.
Who is the six?
Who who is the other person?
No, I live.
At least let me farm stats.
Oh, shit.
I sit still.
Bro.
Anyone streaming on your team?
I just want to know, you know?
I want to know what they're saying!
Yeah!
We did it!
Okay, we...
Yeah, I'm back to Celestia.
Let's go.
I got three, throw it, three, three.
Oh, never mind.
Never, that's my team.
That doesn't count.
Yay, we're back at Celestia.
Yay, plus 17.
Yeah, that felt like a plus 17 game.
Why is she up so early?
That's so funny.
That you said I'm up so early.
Amy, why am I up the entire day?
Yay.
Almost C2.
Hmm.
I don't...
I don't know if I like that.
I don't like...
I don't know.
I like that.
Rigsie securing top 500.
Hmm.
All I'm saying is I feel like if one...
Oh, if someone is securing top 500 in my...
group you gotta share you gotta share the love because if you don't i hope you i hope you miss it very much sharing is caring exactly the doki tax exactly look guys if i play for another 13 hours then maybe there is hope
oh guys maybe in 13 hours i can have me i can secure it yes my business is at the end of the week though i'll still be here for a bit until the end of the week okay flag celestial now i'm back babe if we win
game then I'll be I'll have more points than I did when I started the stream when I started the stream I think it was like zero wait no I already have more points when compared to oh my god we forgot I think we forgot to avoid people oh oh no we didn't you didn't avoid anyone did you I
saw ya boy.
Oh no.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm still in Celestia.
Uh...
Yeah, let's get the torch out.
Even we lose.
I'll still be in Celestial, guys.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Maybe someone will throw on the enemy team again, too.
Yeah, you need N in top 500.
It doesn't matter.
I touched top 500, like, several times.
Name more.
Oh, because we have Yaboy.
It was a Hulk one trick.
We have Yaboy.
the hawk one trick it's fine hope we have name more oh my god oh can you play a different thing it's yeah boy i want to three support you if they're diving yeah boy do you play mark or strange because i might run that will be fair i think yeah boy
Okay Oh Oh, okay Yeah, no, he is I think A boy is a hook only Play No, no, stay back, stay back, stay back Oh, well Yeah I mean, this is a good group map, but like You need a shield tank to play Magruder Honestly, they're gonna play a what?
One night, I gotta kill you.
All right.
He... Oh, they have a Hulk too.
Hulk v.
Hulk!
Let's go!
Let's just hope they don't run triple support.
They're running triple support.
Yes, crazy calm.
I'm pissed.
I don't know.
Venom.
Okay.
Oh, wait, they're not!
They're not!
Oh my god, they're not.
I just see they're just running Jeff.
They're just running Jeff.
Let's go.
They're running Jeff Jeff is good though.
Jeff is good.
Not gonna lie.
Jeff is good, but like it's not triple support Jeff Which is what I was scared about.
It's just regular Jeff
It's just regular Jeff and regular Jeff is less scary
Oh my god.
Oh nice.
She alive.
Oh shit, what the fuck happened here?
Okay, maybe a little too much.
Okay, I'll let her... Oh, never mind.
I'll let her heal.
But I got it.
Alright.
Okay.
I would like her to heal so she can...
You can tell I'm not healing much because, like, I just want her to build up.
Because there's no reason for me.
For, like, she just needs a...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
That's fine.
Yay!
I told you, it was fine.
There we go.
i wish i could do what you do strange big situation weren't wrong or good right now so it's okay and a half oh no oh no oh no triple support oh dar one weakness oh no some are coming up enough i don't have anything Oh, no!
Oh, no!
Where is she?
No!
Our one weakness.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
We're fine.
That was my bad.
I had no more shields.
Okay
All right, now we don't have to Oh my god Yeah, bucky now Oh my god, please Oh my god, please How did I die?
Oh, I He went for me He went for me this Hore, a fucking course He went for me please please live please i'm coming back
there you go
this is a little
hello oh my god where i got you covered okay it's fine oh my god it's not fine
Oh my god, it's still...
I'm trying my...
Bro, she's...
I think our...
Okay, I was gonna say, what was our mag doing?
I...
Okay.
It's... I think our mag semi-dc no our mag is dc there's no what is our mag doing what is our i just i don't understand he's just standing there tito seven bro watch this is our mag okay okay no he's okay he's okay i he's just or a part of me bro let's just standing there menacingly.
Go ahead and take it with a three-gifted cells.
Thank you.
I was so confused.
I was like, is he okay?
I'll again, bro, do you not see the guy just pummeling you?
He's just standing there.
We didn't ask to be heroes, but we always answer the call.
Or a dynamics or something.
Okay.
That was crazy.
That was... I was very concerned.
Are you solo queuing?
That's right.
That's me!
He's talking about me.
I was gonna ask you to do it.
Yo, you wanna do it with me?
Damn!
Bro,
he said he ain't a real homie, by the way.
That guy's not a homie.
Because he was like, yeah.
Like, he didn't care.
That guy, that guy ain't real.
That guy ain't a real homie.
See, if it's a real homie, he would be like, nah, bro.
Bros before hoes, you know?
Oh, the widow death goes crazy.
So, like, all I'm saying is that he ain't a real bro.
A real bro wouldn't let that happen.
Imagine.
Oh, he's dead.
You have way too many ads on Twitch.
I don't even run ads.
I don't even, guys, I don't even run ads.
I think I have the automated ads, which is like on automatically, like, where it's just like on automatically, but I don't run ads myself.
That last one.
Now we can keep going.
that one was the last one.
Yeah, it's just Twitch beating Twitch.
Who's this Daryl 999 person?
Yeah, it's on Twitch's side.
It's on my side.
Oh.
843.
860.
Oh, he's getting closer.
Too many wins.
Too yellow.
I don't know the, Darren.
Thank God we had a Mac there.
Thank fucking God.
Also, Broken Bond.
They give it a five gifted souls.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, they need some more gray.
Fire Niels.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Yay.
We ain't stopping yet.
I never said one more.
stopping?
Okay, avoid his three.
Who said we're stopping?
Hello, Jeff is here.
Wait, do I have my big head?
I don't.
Oh, I have sniff.
Okay, wait, that's a good emo material right there.
Oh, wait, are people fighting?
Hello?
Hello, everyone.
My God, I Okay, goodbye, everyone.
Wait, who are?
Annie, hey guys, thank you for the five gift and subs.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Hello, Annie.
Wait.
Where are the...
Where are the ladies?
Hello.
Wait, whoa!
Whoa!
What did I do?
All I did was ask Where are the ladies?
That ain't a crime.
That's not a crime to ask where the ladies are.
If that's a crime, then I don't want to be right.
Hello.
Oh, hey.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
I want to do an emote.
Come over here.
Come on.
Don't run away.
Come over here.
Come on, why are you running?
Why are you?
What?
What he left?
Hello.
Stop running away.
Why are you so scared?
Sniff.
What is...
You're out of a quick sniff.
Oh my god, it's EUQs.
Okay, if we lose this, I'm out.
I'm actually...
I'm running on fumes right now.
I don't think I can keep going.
If we lose this, I'm actually out.
I am running on fumes.
Guys, I don't think there's going to be a stream today.
I think this week would be a will be like no schedules This might be a no schedule week
Gainer is a pro player Is he?
Alright let's check it out
Gainer Marvel Rivals What team?
Oh he is Oh OG seed.
I don't know what team that is.
But he is!
The right heroes could make all the difference.
Okay.
Oh, please don't.
Please don't make me play Luna.
Not on EU ping.
It's fine.
That's fine.
Maybe I will.
Maybe I'll do a late night stream on YouTube.
And it'll just be rival.
Just be...
Who knows?
I'll think about it.
This is a bit bad because we don't have a lot of heals.
I don't know.
I'll figure it out.
I'll figure it out later.
Oh, Jay, thank you for the five.
Give the sauce.
Thank you.
What if the night stream is?
rivals like I'm like the final gatekeeping all the people that try to last minute secure top 500 and I'm like hello everybody I am the final boss I am the final boss hello the late night grinders trying to secure top 500 for 24 hours left it would be such a shame if some oh my god it's a widow i'm scared okay i got guys i might have to focus up now is that widow oh what you caught the sniper did i hear that correctly
i hear venom wouldn't hear you
Okay.
Oh my god.
I am trying.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Holy shit.
That guy got up so fast.
And I'm like, get out of here.
That vault now.
Oh, fuck.
I'm fucking scared.
That's fine.
Oh, it's mellow.
Okay.
Okay, it's mellow.
Never mind.
Now, that guy, I know.
He's also a pro, isn't he?
Oh, wait, it's Etsy, too.
Wait, what the fuck?
What lobby am I in?
What the fuck lobby am I in right now?
now bro what bro i'm just i i feel bad now bro all these guys are clearly trying their heart out right now
i am ready to put on a show you want nothing
oh it got canceled okay a round tap oh that sucks that sucks for me that actually sucks for me oh it's not Melio oh I thought it was Melio never mind JK JK I was thinking about someone else I was thinking about someone I mean he's building up really fucking I thought it was Melio.
It started with an M.
So I didn't remember this is EU.
Because I got prediction.
Which is very...
Oh.
Which is
very...
Okay, our Mantis is hitting everything.
No.
Holy fuck.
He is...
He is hitting everything.
Everything is crazy All right We hunger I'm a little scared though.
Oh my god
Oh strange strange strange buddy Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
It's okay We're five We're so far
I'm Okay It's time It's boom time Oh my god I messed up I'm scared I am so I'm so scared
Oh my god I Where is that strange Hey
Okay, the thing is, the strain definitely has a...
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, I have to pay attention, but...
Can you heal me like a little bit?
Thank you.
Oh my god, he wants to ult so badly, I can tell.
He just wants to do it!
Okay, he's dead.
Alright, I guess he's not ulting.
I can tell.
He's just begging to get to ult right now.
Raccoon.
They're TPing.
There's no way.
There's no...
They unleashed the Ashanti's power?
Did he do it?
Oh my god, he still has an ulted, thank god.
Thank god we won the RNG.
Please, please, please, please, please!
Are you serious?
I saved your life!
Mantis!
I saved your life, please respond.
Please respond
You deserve it You fucking deserved it You Okay baby Maybe it was fucked up I let her die like that But all I'm saying You deserved it You absolutely Holy fuck it's okay My team can live just About heals for one second
I'm sending a message Y'all Y'all so fake Time to switch things up Including which side we're on We would have won regardless if our mantis lives or not But I just thought that mantis and I Should have the same amount of deaths Because one of my deaths was definitely not supposed to happen happen.
And if she gets that plus one, I should get that plus one too.
Yes, maybe I could have saved her if I ulted.
But maybe she could have saved me when she, I don't know, turned around and gave me a leap when I went, I need healing.
That's all I'm going to say.
Hmm?
That's...
The world's just like that.
Unfortunate.
Not my fault.
Not my fault the world is like this.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
Hello, everybody.
Okay.
Um, go in.
Oh, it's stupid.
Oh, we're tipping, we're tipping, we're tipping.
PP?
Oh.
There you go.
Oh my god, bro, that poor...
Oh my god.
Lucky one, I swear.
Lucky one.
It's okay, I didn't want to be alive.
It's okay.
She lives!
The matches lives?
Okay.
That's fine.
That's okay.
Also, you don't have to push the card.
You see that it says auto.
So you can technically fight with your team for... Jesus Christ.
Who gets ult so fast?
Our our venom is crazy.
I do not want to play against this venom I would rather I honestly I would be fine.
He dodging him He does not seem fun to play against
Oh my god.
Oh my god You're so lucky you're so lucky.
I I I want to win I saved your life.
Hello, can we- can we kill this guy?
Okay, there we go.
Nice, look at this guy.
I- every time I play versus you, hello.
Hey guys.
Yay!
He ran away!
All right, yay!
Also attacker.
Thank you for the gifting us so.
Thank you.
Yay.
What is this feeling?
Winning?
What is that?
Is this...
Joy?
you mean points can sometimes go up
wow oh what other in so like Diren father look at that Diren sent me a friend request because i was like do you want to do it
oh shit is he it's all right he's not at top 500 yet damn five wooden streaks said okay like i don't know how but to be fair three of those games were literally back to back to back like throw like enemy team had throwers like eo mm is actually It was on my side that those three like for some reason I don't know how I've just it's just finally my time It was my time The game was like We drew your name from the lottery Congratulations I'm like Me
Me?
Oh!
It's okay.
I'll stop when we lose.
And it could be any moment.
It's just like Gamba.
For now.
Ow.
Hello everybody.
Hello women.
I'm sorry!
He just smelled so good!
It's not my voice!
It smells so good!
Oh, he doesn't know.
He doesn't.
Ah!
It's so cute.
It's the bouncing game.
Get out of here!
How is I supposed to know it wasn't allowed?
I just... I'm just... I'm just a...
A shark darling!
What can I do?
I'm just like fad.
I'm fad from the club now.
I'm so sad they banned me from the club after one mistake how was I supposed to know it was a mistake huh how was I supposed to know I'm just a little guy don't make me angry don't make me angry I will play this game if you make me angry oh my god it's his girl it's his girl oh my god Wait,
how come they can do that?
Bro!
Oh my god, his name is Predator.
Oh my god, wait.
Which hero do you think you're gonna be in?
I just realized.
I'm not the type who faced quietly into the battleground.
Oh, it's dope.
Now, who are I going to be in this?
What do you mean?
Bye now!
Alright, stream ends.
We end when we lose.
It could be this game.
I hope it is.
I'm running on fumes right now.
I'm not supposed to be...
I didn't... I don't know, it does not feel like seven...
Not eight hours.
It really does not feel like eight hours for me.
Like, time passed by so fast when I play Rivals.
It really does.
I don't know how.
But thanks for cheering me up.
I had, like, you know, when I found out, you know, that while I, like, gave up the grind, I was so sad.
But definitely streaming this has...
Oh, you're such a whore.
You really are.
You're such a tort taking my Invis.
Fuck you.
Unless you're a pro, then like, that's understandable.
You can have her.
But if you're not, fuck you.
Hope we lose.
Okay, nah, I don't hope we lose.
In case, like, I get bad.
I do not actively throw.
But, like, if it does happen, I won't be sad about it.
If it does happen.
it I won't be sad about it 30 seconds before you attack get ready um the mantias they give the hundred biddies thank you thank you I really appreciate it no but you should know magnetism doesn't work on super cool materials guess what I can all right here we go here
we go
oh my god there is like a mantis over there
wait are they running triple no they're not okay
bro this sucks this sucks this this this sucks looking at this sucks i am phoenix I don't even like looking at this right now.
Oh my god, this sucks.
I hate this.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, we're fine.
We're not fine anymore.
It's fine.
I'm still fine.
I don't.
them.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, this... I... Where... Oh no.
Oh no.
What's going on?
What's this?
Where's my... Okay, there
what's going on what's i don't know what happened
okay here you go this is what i'm saying guys this sucks they have they have two dive takes oh my god i missed it okay we oh my god i'm trying i really have
Okay, we don't care
We don't care We don't care
Please when will it end When will it end oh my god this is hell this is hell it doesn't end that's the secret they're running triple support aren't they they're running triple support i fucking knew it i felt that adam touched me and i was like it's over all right already not fun wait
is that him he's okay I'll try my I have to reload so if something happens to him I'm so sorry oh my god please wait no please stop this please please stop oh my god no oh no oh we're okay we're okay
oh my god please let me save your life
please how many more
oh my god i saved your life you're welcome oh my please
okay i'm dead i did everything i Oh my god.
This is hell.
I hate.
Oh my god.
Triple support.
The beta might.
It's so bad.
I hate it.
I hate playing against it.
And I hate playing with it.
There's no happiness for triple support.
I don't even think you can be happy.
I don't think you could be happy even playing it I legitimately think if we have triple support this would be so easy well not easy yet but this would be not as bad there you go
oh my god please this is so hard is this what do you mean?
we are undefeatable
what do you mean?
how am I do you not see the hell that's a crazy how that's such a crazy statement oh my I can't believe yeah I can't believe he said that I I can't believe he said that I that I I can't believe I I can't believe that came out of his fucking mouth
okay I'm dead I'm dead
okay it's over he said how am I am I not getting healed all right why are you how am I always dead in front of you and I was like do you not see the absolute hell that we had to go through what did I do what I'll give you guys stop wasting ulti and like actually press it before people talk and we went by the way.
They damaged boosted venom!
They asked!
You guys and then like I go in and you guys are backpedaling and then you guys press Q up and you guys go back.
We're getting Dovan.
I'm not damaged.
Yeah, yeah, so like when you have a support ulti, right, you can walk up with your team and play with your team so that I don't have to run across the map to come save you.
We are playing up in our team.
Oh no, no, no.
I have Luno.
I'm seeing my Luno all the way back.
We press Q and then we run up with Q instead of walking up.
I have been marking venom every single time.
you guys are sitting so far back that we just never push up oh i played by our luna so i don't know yeah walk up really i i what you know no no no just for you just for you we're gonna play inside our team okay like inside our team so if they dive us two stall tanks right so when they're playing that comp they're just gonna jump in you sit there i'm gonna play right here i'm gonna play right here you sit there doing that we're just gonna lose okay okay that's why we have a That you guys don't walk up you guys sit back and then you guys use it when like and then the beast guy is Complaining the beast guys complain that I alt it for nothing and then the and then the Bucky is complaining that I wasn't all thing like
Like what what do you want?
Holy shit Oh my god!
I...
Being real bro.
Oh!
Holy shit!
And then the other fucking guy is complaining that I did all did for nothing!
And then this guy!
That's crazy!
That's actually great!
Our stranger's on point.
Bye-bye.
there's a phenomenal support that was great okay that's crazy and then they are running a triple support well ulca can come over here now oh my god all right
What?
Like, I'm like, which is what is the right answer?
Which is the right answer?
Like, oh, the other guy's like, why did you all?
And then this guy's like, why did you all sooner?
I'm like, what do you want?
What do you want from me?
I all and then I don't all and then I should all and then I should.
He can die.
Cap can die.
Okay.
Matty's side side.
Matty's on my ass.
Holy shit.
I didn't come with my syringe.
Now he's complaining about...
We killed...
We killed them.
mental and i can alter it and now they're completing a book mark for you
like i don't i don't know who is right and who is in red
that's my bad i'm not hitting yeah i see the windows she's not doing anything it's okay okay there you go i've 84 bro just wants to come play honestly yeah can you take damage so we can come you know don't fight
yeah there's a cap there 21.
i can kill this i'm ready to put on a show We're still here.
Oh my god.
You have to swap exchange.
You have to swap exchange when you die.
Swap exchange please.
Swap exchange.
Okay.
TP, TP, TP, jump, jump!
Don't see no, don't see no.
Thanks a lot.
Hello?
There it is.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping.
I'm hoping.
I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping, I'm hoping.
My whole being...
I'm still helping
Oh my god, why did you need them to me?
Why did you I?
Why?
I'm helping I'm helping I'm helping I'm helping I'm helping I'm helping I'm assisting I'm I'm still Don't you know
You didn't get help.
Oh,
my God.
I actually...
You guys are asking not pushing Q or Blaine.
Who are you talking about?
Another Evan.
What?
I actually fucking...
I fucking clutched that for my team!
Oh my, are you serious?
Oh, good, good.
I actually fucking clutched that so hard.
Holy shit.
Holy fuck.
Average boosted E, girl.
Does that, hiding behind, bro, hiding behind an alt account name for this shit.
shit you say oh my god fucking coward actual barcode fucking coward suck suck my fucking balls no she's he's talking about her because she's the one that used her mic and so he's talking shit about her yeah that's what a goddamn losing oh my god and literally me and the me and the i fucking did so much during that fight i had two res's for that fight and i lived throughout it no barcode is like such a common alt account it's such a it's an incredible common alt account name in me i'm salty for nothing
oh my god that's crazy it's actually crazy no that guy is different my guy is offline my part code cat was offline this guy this of course he's hiding he limited his profile to i think they must be dude actually oh i can't tell they both limited it i think those two are doing because they're i don't know actually i'm not sure because this guy was like why did you all and then the other guy was like why why why didn't you all so actually i don't know because they were both they were both like like fighting each other because giving me conflicting things they're like why did you all and then they was like why didn't you all and i'm like i don't know what do you want for me Why do you?
Oh, it's this guy.
He's a pure offline.
Look at the fucking coward he is.
That's crazy.
Oh, but I helped.
Wait, actually, that must have been crazy.
What did that look like?
What did that?
Yeah, you can appear offline.
What did that look like on my own?
Okay.
That's me.
I'm hoping.
Recap.
Oh, wait.
How do I move this?
This looks so dumb.
Not gonna lie.
It must have looked so fucking dumb.
I was like, no!
Why did you explode?
And then he gave up.
And then I'm like, yay!
Yay!
And then I got another See, look at that.
I did that.
And then I got back on point because I didn't want to see that.
And then I climbed back.
Look at me go.
That's crazy.
That's actually I did not deserve.
I'm just surprised I won that.
Chiru, do you think you want to be today?
Okay.
Oh, we have a raccoon now.
I got two reses off.
I got
two reses.
I didn't get one.
You don't want to ban Ultron first.
Rocket just won 1v9.
I didn't avoid anything.
Oh no, that's Rigsie.
You still complain when we win.
You're just low E low.
Holy shit.
If this guy is a pro, if this guy is a pro, he's going to be so embarrassed knowing that this shit was out broadcast.
And seeing everybody in my chat blaming him.
Weak-ass mental.
No, pro players have fucking weak mental.
They have such...
That's why, like, you know, like so many pro players and rank grinders have such...
Like, including me.
Get off rocket.
Bro!
We got the thrower.
Let him just let him.
Just let him play.
It's still winnable.
Wait, are you complaining about rocket?
Get ready.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
What a game to end on.
Okay, they swapped it.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Rocket is actually...
I think Rocket is...
Rocket is actually better than Cloak.
Rocket is actually... Oh my god.
Bro, this guy's fucking stupid.
Rocket is better than Cloak.
Holy shit.
Are you fucking stupid?
I would rather have a rocket than a Cloak.
I...
Yeah.
Like, you're actually fucking stupid.
If you...
Oh my god.
They have a Black Widow.
I literally...
I'm not playing Cloak with magic door.
Yeah, Luna's welcome.
No.
Luna's even worse.
yeah well he picked he's only five i don't know it's actually bad if you think about it bro rocket is so much better than what is he i will do a headshot when you could just pick rocker you just have shot what do you mean i would rather have a rocket than a cook are you fucking stupid okay widow and spider back
oh my god they play like so careful too
wait wait oh my god i i can't hear no i'm not i was walking through
there's no fucking shot okay nice she heals on side if possible it's nice all good Oh my gosh!
And Doki doesn't avoid me, also.
Oh my god.
What the f- Oh, you're into that loser who always tries to be on top 500 and never makes it.
I remember you now.
Who?
Okay, they're up top.
Every season, real game.
Okay, they have captain.
You play rock.
Because you're bad at the game and lucky.
What the f- Because everyone is standing up the game.
What is going on?
Oh my god!
Doki can die.
We are undefeatable!
Captain one, nice!
Okay, the mantis drop.
Help our phoenix.
Nice.
I'm trying my best.
Oh, yes.
Oh my god.
Okay, three or four people have copied over here.
Spider-Man coming right side.
Coming?
Come back?
Are you Spider-Man or are you?
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man!
Buddy!
Please, please, please, please!
Oh!
I shot him here.
I thought he was gonna ult!
These runes.
Who's ult?
Okay, I'm ulting for you.
Let's not press the Pro.
I don't give up so easily.
I thought the Rock is gonna ult.
See how I'm pointing his mind looks good.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I just made every single ulti except the...
call it by the obviously i was literally just waiting for i'm not gonna peek right now bro i'm literally trying so hard to not peek right i'm gonna touch regular oh
hey i got luna i i got both of you
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
I support all of this.
Nigel's alone here with me.
There's one.
Yeah.
Why?
What?
No, you are slow shit.
Look at cap.
Bro, no one's shooting you.
The cap is jumping around, just stalling and you press Q.
Like, you cannot be real.
What?
Bro, okay, this rocket was pretty stupid for doing that.
Like, he was pretty stupid for that.
He did not have to up that.
He actually did not.
Where's my rocket?
Where is my rocket?
Oh my.
I
Okay, okay, it's okay It's okay Cap one cap one cap one Your powers are mine Yeah, we forced that hero Careful, be careful Michael Okay Okay Okay One
Man Yeah, y'all just down point and be safe, okay?
They should be down both healers.
Oh my god, couldn't get out.
She has this.
Maybe it's fighting, fighting one.
Fighting one, fighting one.
Cap half.
Guys, guys, just can't just be right.
Oh, this is unlucky.
Oh my god, stop fucking again.
Holy shit.
Very close.
Fighting one.
Be careful.
What are you looking at?
I'm going to kill back three people, please.
one cup cup cup cup cup oh my god please please
i can't live
oh my god
i can't live he's there bro strange one i actually can't live
oh man yo get me out my back line is horrendous Okay
He keeps running away from me
He keeps running away from me.
I can't play with him
No, it's just this guy's an asshole After all these years, this guy's an actual asshole Let me out this is one I'll just have to feel more, I guess, so I don't know.
Oh, my support to our actual AI.
I was a portal.
I feel you guys.
I stopped their ult, and somehow we still just can't play the game.
Like, it's all...
I pick up a healer.
I stopped their ult, and somehow you guys are just not pressing Q.
What?
I guess we're really good at the game.
It's because our rocket's getting up.
I was waiting for our rocket to ult.
They're actually talented.
Can you tell...
I'm just going to...
Can you tell our rocket to ult first?
I've just been waiting for him, and he holds it.
And he holds it.
and somehow we lose the fight because my background is not even worth one eating bro this guy is actually so fucking cringe i told you pro like if he's pro or if he's a high ranker they have the weakest fucking mental it's actually this is all they have this is actually all they have in life but you say nothing useful bro this is all they have in life
I saved my back plan.
I killed his back plan and somehow we lose the fight because my future actually.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
These guys, this guy.
Yeah, he has to be so shit at the end so much.
He can't.
It's actually, I'll play one more.
I'll play one more.
I get it.
You're trying to boost the images, but like the game is not winnable.
Holy shit.
You're thinking about, you say nothing useful.
Oh my god.
No, brother, get on mag.
I promise you.
Message the devs about this guy too.
I don't think he cares about this account anyway.
But I can message the devs about this account.
About it.
And show them the...
I'm not trying to play all day.
I'm trying to win the 8 times in a row.
I don't know.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
That's fucking crazy.
Just wait, we should keep dodged this.
This guy is so fucking cringe.
He actually is.
He actually is so cringe.
You play solo, you're still behind him probably.
Holy shit.
I never said anything to this guy.
What the?
What the fuck?
That's not that deep.
It's been about this guy.
I'll just message devs about this guy.
I didn't even fucking say shit.
Oh, maybe he's watching stream.
Guys, say shit about this guy.
Maybe he's watching the stream.
Give us your thoughts about this guy.
Tell him about how he's gonna amount to nothing.
Because this is the only thing he has.
Being high, Elo is the only thing he has.
He is making zero money playing this game
Bro shower dude bro shower
Bro keeps yapping small pee-pee energy right there Bro, I don't even think he's he has ever had a girlfriend this guy is like sexist as hell.
There's no one A girl would ever let him fuck her.
He would have to pay her to fuck her.
All he has is...
That's the wildest thing.
All he has is this game.
That's crazy.
He dodged this.
I'll report this guy to the...
Nah, just cue this.
dodge.
It's easier.
Because he'll just try his ass out.
His ass out.
If he sees us.
That's crazy.
Report player.
Negative behavior.
Throwing.
Um.
Was throwing.
A game.
That was.
winnable and was throwing game swapped to be oh my god and i'm like the number one streamer and robber i was right now what a loser actually
yeah okay and then report player text chat abuse uh hate speech uh wait when uh wait is there not text chat voice chat abuse okay hate speech abusive language um flaming teammates for no reason there you go actually embarrassing himself live on stream okay and i'll grab his uid too um um i'll message the devs right now hi um can i I report someone because I have devs that help me ban people if or like I give them like suspension or something if they harass me on stream because I don't fucking prompt any of this is it possible to look over a guy that was yeah
I message them about it that's why they're private profile because they know actual fucking weirdo actual weirdo never even fucking said anything to this guy you know what's crazy oh i think it's because like if i when i queue up maybe if he knows me from like if he knows me actually from other me playing with other pros he must have not said shit because he knows the pros will recognize his voice.
I'll just send the voice clip over.
Because, like, he was like, oh, like, he kept going at it at me.
And, like, being like, oh, trying to get boosted or whatever.
And I was like, what?
I think maybe.
If he does know who I am, I can just send this clip to some of my pro friends.
Like, do you recognize his voice?
This guy's being a fucking asshole.
Yeah.
It's like, I've never had someone that go went that hardcore on me before.
I was just like, whoa.
Are you okay, buddy?
Like, bro, does your life really suck that much that you feel like something by flaming random people online?
Like, so he might know me because I play with, like, I play with, like, two pros sometimes, off stream.
And then he doesn't want to say shit when I'm with them.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, you can kill.
Yeah, no, that's what I'm saying.
These guys have...
I mean, I have, like, weak mental.
Because when I...
Like I said, I was, like, really sad.
When I...
I was really sad when I was, like, when I couldn't make it.
Because I was so close.
But, like, I would never say anything in...
I would never say anything in a public chat because like you know that's like that's just too far you know I would just say it to myself yeah he picked a fight with four supports yeah or maybe he got dropped I don't know maybe this guy got dropped from a team and he fucking can't even get on a pro team or some shit
maybe he got teams get dropped for taxes no players get dropped for toxicity um well most majority of them unless you're a really really good player then they'll just you know pretend that never happened that's usually it usually they do but unless they're really really really good then like they pretend it never happened It'll be like,
it got investigated.
Don't worry, an investigation is happening.
And then nothing comes out of it.
I'm not like saying it's Marvel Rivals, but it's like overall, like any esport, it's always like that.
They're like really, unless, unless, unless it's the really bad one, unless they do a really, really bad thing.
Because like, you know, there were some Overwatch League pros.
like disappeared because they did a really really bad thing but if it's like minor-ish like not as that bad then like usually they'll just pretend it didn't happen
yeah it's actually yeah but no i've been in playing rank for so long uh i've been playing rank for so long that like i know that these people have the weakest as hell oh my gosh wait why this is not okay this is i wrote we should have just we should have just q dodged because what the is this average la
what the there were gm players knew it i knew i should have just q dash
i should have so much energy after that
i i can keep going now after that that gave me so much energy
anger actually fueled me holy like i i i that's not my second one it's my third win you'll
need a top match team to win this one i'm luna snow Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
Yeah, no, anger is most definitely a good motivator.
100%.
Alright, this is...
Wait, am I Luna?
Did I accidentally pick Luna?
Wait, I don't want to play Luna.
Okay.
I don't want to play Luna.
Fuck.
Okay, I might actually...
I was thinking about playing Luna.
just so i can give rigsy a snowflake i think i have to fuck okay all right no i have to give it for the snowflake i don't want to but
four three two one all you need to do is capture the mission area got it
Jesus, he almost died.
Oh my god, not the fucking Namur.
It's Namur.
Namur.
Hulk time.
My favorite.
Oh yay!
Yay!
They're in it.
Oh.
Are you serious?
Jeff, please.
All right, I'm watching this.
Okay, that's my bedroom.
Okay, yeah, you're fucking good.
Are you serious?
Okay.
It's fine.
I had no clap, so like...
I had no...
Look, I had no
They're not portaling?
Oh, they're not.
That's interesting.
What the fuck?
I swear I heard...
Okay, there it is.
I was like, what was that sound?
Okay, remember...
Oh, I'm sorry, buddy.
Oh, my...
I'm not using anything.
I'm not.
There's no way I'm wasting out here.
Like, it's spawned.
It's the third lady.
They wasted up.
It's literally spawn.
Oh, that's unlucky.
He did stagger, though.
That one was not good.
That was not good that he staggered there.
It was almost okay until he started staggering.
Okay, the thing is, I have no clap, so if he...
I am ready to put on a show.
Alright, if he does all of this, I will have to...
Because I don't have clap.
Oh, this sucks.
Oh my god.
They're gonna...
Oh.
Nice.
Uh.
That was very scary.
Not gonna lie.
Wait.
Oh my god.
I'm...
The fucking dragon turtle lagged me.
All right, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Okay, this guy most definitely has health ball, and I'm scared.
There it is.
Oh, nice.
Oh, not nice.
Oh, don't.
Oh, oh, I'm okay.
Not okay.
I'm not okay.
It's okay.
We cap point.
I was not okay, but like, it's okay.
That's all that matters.
Like, is he still there?
Okay, he's not there anymore.
That's good.
Whoa!
Not good.
No longer good.
It's okay, it's okay.
You think they got it?
Oh shit!
Um, there's an idiot!
That's fine.
My life doesn't matter.
My...
My life...
it's okay my life doesn't matter in the long scheme of things it's okay all right let's go oh we're dead oh my gosh I ulted before before he did that too i'm so sad i'm so sad he altered he altered it before oh my god i altered it and then he presses as well at the same time too that makes me so sad that actually makes me so sad i was like trying to build my ult charge too no i i should just died with it but i he he he fucking weighted that's the thing this guy waited so i didn't know i i waited too well i waited as in like i was trying to oh my god oh my god it's fine
i wonder if i should just play in this but oh my That's crazy Everyone's taking
Oh my god, bro.
There's so many odds I can't live
Okay, we can they can combo now What So you jump in when the
Okay, I have a little too.
Jesus Christ.
Is he alive?
Oh, he's not alive.
Okay.
I'm just gonna use this.
Is that right?
Oh.
I'm hurt.
Okay.
Oh my god, I have to reload.
Oh my god, please!
I had to reload.
Jesus Christ, I'm trying so hard to focus.
I don't want clap.
That's the scary part.
I don't have clap.
Okay, I don't need a clap.
I don't need a clap.
What's the occasion?
I'm trying to set my sleep schedule.
And also, like, I like playing right.
I like streaming rivals.
It's fun.
Including which side you're on.
Also, the, like, that loser.
That loser reignited my adrenaline.
I was tired, but I'm not tired anymore.
hey um organ thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you infinite thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you i'm trying to fix my sleep schedule because i need to fix it before my business trip because i'm still being a na i'm not like flying overseas or anything because then you know my fucked up sleep schedule would be perfect if i was flying overseas but i'll still be an na so i'm trying to fix it before before my business trip because i have to be awake in the morning
but yeah like i'm trying also that i think i'm getting better at handling like assholes in rank because in the past when i used to uh when i wasn't a streamer and i had like you know assholes it's why i don't use voice chat anymore too i don't use voice chat anymore because like I got back then in Overwatch there was not a lot of female high rank players and people were so fucking mean and like I would like cry every time I get flame but like I think I think I'm getting better at it I think it helps that I make money doing this streaming thing and I know they don't so like they're being paid nothing to be assholes Please.
Oh my god.
So it helps a lot knowing that, I guess.
And it does help a lot.
Okay.
So I think, I think that's character development.
I don't know.
Come on, come on.
Oh my god.
I don't even have somewhere else yet.
What the fuck?
Okay, we wrapped it.
Goodbye, everybody.
Goodbye.
That's unlucky.
I had...
Oh.
What?
Oh, it's too late.
And that's a bit late.
Okay.
I had...
Why?
I'm sorry.
I had up.
I wasn't the one that's supposed to TP.
Oh, they're dumb.
They're actually dumb.
Never mind.
I actually got my team killed.
Where are we supposed to go?
Like, down here?
Aw, no.
Oh
This sucks Like can we contest?
Why are we contesting?
I'm so confused
Oh my god, why did everyone leave me?
Everyone just left me I'm so confused.
Okay, I'm coming back now.
I was like, hey, guys.
Are we all fighting?
Okay.
I was like, where is everyone going?
Like, we let them push so much.
Why?
I was so confused.
Everyone, they were pushing so much for no reason.
Um, they're just gonna use the cops.
I'm boned now, which I am a little scared about.
Oh.
Oh, we're dead.
We're dead.
Oh, we're so...
We're so dead.
They use everything.
I don't know why we all got that.
It's fine.
We just reset.
We're so dead.
That's crazy that they use.
Okay, thanks.
I'm touching.
Oh,
please!
I can't play Luna.
I'm playing Luna into this.
I just can't play Luna into this.
It's not worth it.
It's so hard to...
Like, nobody's peeling for me.
Swap a little bit of drift.
it's just too high I feel that I need
I'm not getting any peel
holy shit what is peeling um if If I'm getting doved by someone, I have no one to...
No one's covering me.
So that...
I literally have no...
I have no cover.
I have just the combo.
So like, I have 11 deaths because I literally...
Nobody is like covering me.
Like...
There's no reason for me to ult it.
We can just contest.
We can contest maybe.
Only two.
Yeah, I have ult though.
I can ult this year.
We're coming.
Oh, you're a bit sad.
I didn't go in, was it?
Alright, let's just grab this.
There we are.
Now we got that big up.
The only concern is that we got stacked for...
Please.
Okay, see, that's what I'm saying.
Oh my god, that's much better.
Holy shit, it's much better playing Invist than Luna against this.
That was Ashley's story.
hard for no fucking reason
oh man i couldn't it's fine i have a lot oh i have all here oh i'll die
I'll catch you up.
That's much better.
What?
Oh my god.
That's so unlucky.
That's so unlucky for me.
I'm so sad.
I threw that.
I actually, I didn't, I couldn't see the, I didn't see the, um, I actually threw that too.
That makes me so sad.
Oh my god.
that was my bad wait a day I didn't I didn't see the they got their root number combo time to switch things up including which side you're on I couldn't see the outline you'll need a top-notch team to win this one
okay That's unlucky.
Yeah, no, I...
I threw that last fight.
The last fight, I say I threw it.
Because, like, I didn't...
I couldn't see the whale outline.
Yeah, it's called Animal Crossing.
That's why I have 14 deaths there.
I literally...
I couldn't see the outline of the whale.
If I knew where the whale is, I wouldn't have done that.
But I didn't.
That sucks.
That was my bad.
I would admit that I fucked that up.
Is there a way?
It's because it's blue.
And the ending area is blue too.
Unless I played in like really fucking shitty graphics.
But like I don't like that.
Yeah.
Alright.
I don't think that's our tree by the way.
Don't worry everyone, I got my second win.
I can keep playing.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh no!
We just got...
Oh, we just got Ultron up too.
That's unlucky.
We're coming back.
Just live.
I'm reload.
Please, please, please, please, please.
I got two.
I got three.
Oh, it's Jeff.
You're losing.
Oh my god.
I hate playing Luna.
This is Luna.
It's not fun.
It's not fun anymore.
more it's not fun it makes me so sad
played right side of countries okay right side skylock on the left watch out i don't have to be center stage oh my god i think I think this is where oh my god I'm lag I'm like fucking teleporting everywhere I'm actually just teleporting I I hate playing her she's just miserable she's split up but Don't Lexi 9.
They're so, it's so miserable.
I'm sorry.
I didn't want to die.
I knew I would die if I went there.
No, I gotta go for the rush.
Jeff, you could have...
You would have made it.
maybe yeah no not maybe i tp'd after you walked past one and i still made it but with no one to touch if you had tp the son of me you would have made it and someone could have touched like me yeah like i made the split decision to try to use my heart because maybe she should have already stayed light but she should have gone down and then i should have just taken the gun for car i made a mistake it's okay
oh my god do you want to go no more side and i'll go ultron here
winnable but you want me on them all I don't know if I'm better than you in them all this is it's like it's just I it's just like Luna right now relies on the team to make sure she doesn't die so like if my other support and my team doesn't appeal for me or like you know make sure i'm alive then i'm i'm like the most easily killed person in this entire team uh because of the fact that they can just walk up to me and my only defense is my freeze and so it's it's hell it's like i get dove non-stop but like i also have to win every 1v1 if i do have a 1v1 i need to win every 1v1 if i'm And like,
that is impossible for me, especially because I'm playing EU Pings right now.
So it's even scarier just because of the fact...
Oh my god, like right now.
Oh my god, this is so hard Because they want Because we're doing triple support With Ultra So I have to play Luna
Are you serious?
Oh, they used it, they used it, nice Wait, oh we used it I can't build up Wait, why did we use up?
I have 19 that's how fucking like I want to die playing this character I in this current meta like I'm technically I am I am I am dying oh my god why are we up
last pick oh my god look get me up get me up pocket man
oh my god i hate i hate playing luna i and the thing is they're making it even worse to play luna season because in I playing Luna playing Luna against that cop actually made me want to uninstall life in game in game holy death in game in game
so the thing is it's gonna be even more miserable to play Luna next season because they're buffing uh they're buffing um venom and they're making a daredevil comes into play and apparently daredevil is a stronger iron fist so it's like oh do you want it you don't live You don't fucking live until you're tired unless your entire team is actually babysitting you and you know in the rank environment That is impossible.
That's why I fucking hate playing Luna
Okay, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you.
Thank you
What's the win?
We're actually up 60 points I don't know which is that was a plus 16 game to Jesus Christ.
I felt Jesus.
That was a plus 16 points game.
That's crazy.
Parappa, thank you for gifting a tier 1 sub to Aurora.
Yeah, because it was a GM game.
The thing is, Luna is already very fucking strong.
That's the thing.
She is very strong.
um so like you can't really buff her because like she already has so much you know she already has like a lot of util but it's just she's miserable to play against that she is just so fucking miserable i don't understand why people can't i i in my i not my i i um what's I'm like very
I don't know what's the word Like pros who can play support and deal with that In a pro environment Because it must not be fun If you're a support You know a pro support player Dealing with that in an actual Like team environment Yeah I respect yeah I respect the pro support players that could do this every day by the way every day i this is why i'm a variety streamer i i don't understand how how they can do that oh yeah and another thing where i'm like pro players have the weakest mental like you know like when when they lose they would like post this tweet and be like i'm sorry i failed you um like i want to quit i'm i'm going to quit now and then it's like one loss so So I understand.
I understand because it like hurts, you know, you're like you made your fans Disappointed, you know, like I understand that, but it's like They like go like the most emo shit ever like on Twitter too.
It's like so fucking emo Please don't no, please I I don't want to I don't want to really
like when when they when when the people go extra emo they like change their profile they change their profile picture to like a black image and then like put like a quote or something as the twitter header or like the twitter description i've seen a pro player that did that like i don't remember which game it was but they lost a they they lost like a like like um a tournament and And then one of the players changed it to that.
I don't remember which esport it was.
I just was like, bro, you have so many more turns.
Bro.
What do you want to play, Ash?
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
Can I ammo a new mag?
Uh, yeah, you can ammo.
Why do we have bad venom though?
Fuck.
Who banned Venom?
Who was it?
Aww.
I don't...
I was so ready to play in this.
I was so fucking ready.
Yeah, strong together.
It's
just been thrust into darkness and overrun.
Alright, here we go.
Battle starts in 5, 4, 3, 2, Can you break bridge, Mag?
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
Mag, can you break bridge?
I don't think Mag...
Guys, I don't think Mag is breaking the bridge, guys.
I don't think he's doing it.
I don't know why.
Oh, let's hope I hear a Angela!
Oh, is that an Angela?
What the fuck?
Did he...
Oh, shit.
Okay
He didn't she didn't push him in time Oh Oh
We all Someone needs a snowball in the face A shortcut for space Thomas have been this.
I'll let him build it.
Alright, here ya.
Three, two, one, my old is over.
Oh, this is bad.
This is so bad for me.
Alright.
I was not able to build all at all.
That's unlucky.
Thing.
Okay.
Alright, at least I have ult now.
Yeah, that Phoenix built ult charge off of us so fast.
It's crazy.
Oh, nice.
Oh, maybe she'll build another.
one let's find out it's time to fight okay i vote now i know it's this emma as well so i'm just gonna make sure i don't peek here i have that issue in uh during like east coast lobbies jesus christ thank god during east coast lobbies where like i would have this is i hate it made me so mad it was during like uh it was like uh during my rank grind i'm playing invis or like luna and i would have like 60 to 80 ping i have 60 and 80 ping in east coast and it would play the animation will play but it didn't but then like it cancels because like the stuff and then so okay nice so like i wouldn't it wouldn't go off but i had the animation playing that was the worst part i had the animation playing but it didn't go off because of ping which pisses me off because we lost the game because of it because it was like final fight and everything
Please, please, please, please, please, oh my god.
I needed heals here.
Oh, I'm looking.
Oh my god.
There was nothing I could do.
I didn't have clap.
I'm just not...
My Invis is sucking up all the heals.
So I can't build it.
She's sucking it all up.
I don't know what else to do.
Please.
I am ready to put on a show.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Invis, invis.
Oh!
It's just, I'm just gonna give, I'm gonna give Invis the heals.
It's just unlucky because...
Because she's sucking up all the heals, I can't build my ult fast enough so it's actually really detrimental for me don't worry I'm coming back everyone like like right now she's taking all the heals but she has all and I need the heal ult charge that's something like I'd hire you though people more conscious of like other support players are more conscious about when they're like oh oh i have alt now i should heal less so my other support can get her alt charge too but they did not do that and i'm like i guess i got like i'm at 57 let oh that's unlucky yeah
only 60 seconds it should also be like a conscious thing like i wouldn't have to comment if like
it shouldn't oh that's unlucky that's unlucky what the fuck oh my god this sucks
like the thing is i shouldn't have to comment when she should be aware of it especially in this Because this is like,
uh...
Jesus Christ.
I'll be using more as a...
Wait.
Oh my god.
Oh my, it's not fine.
It was...
It was not fine in the end.
It was not fine.
I think we need triple support at this point I have to go raccoon so we can get the res off oh we could like I don't think one angle is worth your playing thing always bad good there I mean so you can press your fucking button on top of the star level no okay I guess and just keep any white feather holes then that's also pretty fun oh my god why are they fighting you can also just play around this i don't i don't understand who he's yelling at i why did i not avoid prisms after next to his in bar what is he at oh rush is man don't worry i don't be the single tier list of this guy oh no rush apparently does this when he's mad he throws when he's mad and he thinks the game is not winnable i was told about this he would go squirrel girl i mean why is he playing eu cues too to be fair why is he here
that's what i'm saying weak ass mental
actually weak ass mental the battle starts in five fucking your entire ego is like, whether a win or a loss in a game.
Which is true, me too.
But, like, I just cry.
I'm really happy.
Squirrel Girl was never a meta.
What the fuck are you guys on about?
I don't remember Squirrel Girl being meta.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, we can walk forward to a team.
We have a pick.
I don't understand why.
What the?
Where am I?
Oh my god.
All time.
What do you want me to do?
I mean, you're not.
I'm literally watching both mine and my back.
These people are like not moving.
It's also like evident by your, your old guard.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's not like you should do.
You're harmless.
It's whatever.
You don't have to hostage.
It's just because you're, just because your hand is.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Why are you saying all this?
kind of cold whoa guys this is the end of season bro you're hot taking me for no reason i i would let you guys know right now off stream and not like nine eight dps right i look for that again so like i don't even wipe enough you don't touch your support i i will say off stream Maybe you shouldn't have brings your friends.
Maybe you should not bring this your friends.
Can you answer me?
Yes!
Offstream?
I've never had so many people yelling at each other.
Like...
This stream alone has had the most...
Arguments.
I'm here for you.
Okay.
I swear, this is the most...
I've...
Offstream, when I was doing the grind, offstream, I haven't had these arguments at all.
It's crazy.
Is that...
It's actually wild.
These people are so angry.
They really want to secure your top 500.
They're so angry.
They're so mad.
Oh my god.
Why are you so mad?
I don't understand.
Does your mommy not hug you?
I'm sorry.
Oh, maybe you're...
Sorry, bro.
Hello, I hide now.
I'm sorry, bro.
Do you not have a mama?
Like, I know mommy issues are also very common too in like, pro play, but like, bro, it's okay.
You'll find your kitten soon.
No, it is apparently, yes, it's, oh my, it is very common.
I'm just dead, I don't know.
I should have let these down more this game.
It's just unfortunate.
Don't worry, we don't find their...
kid in one day i believe i'm not beating
avoiding human argument on
i'm going to look at your profile okay
please don't break you why are you asking permission like a dog if you're a private profile never queue up again because you can't even argue because you have no idea why would I listen to a man what you're talking about like you're so third world that this is the way you speak holy shit
It's quite embarrassing Like you have to be flustered Opening your mouth And being this sophisticated You and four Just speak the exact same way
Oh my god Wait You need some Because it feels like your man Is not making your life Better Oh, you guys try to say he's gay, too?
He's like, he needs to get dick?
Oh, my God, he needs dick.
That's what he's trying to say.
He needs to get laid and get some dick of his ass, I guess.
You love men, too.
Why are you projecting love men?
This makes sense since you're incapable of thinking for yourself with your attitude.
You can't be a straight bed.
Like, we're gonna stay single.
Pathetic that you act like that.
Or leave the closet.
I don't know.
Both are bed maybe they should just kiss each other.
Bro, is this flirting?
Am I actually, is this yaoi?
Oh my god.
Enemies to lovers.
I think my favorite one.
Why would I listen to a man?
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
I used to find you a Pia for that.
Holy shit.
all right i'm back that was crazy that was actually oh yeah am i supposed to avoid somebody oh oh give me five minutes okay i'm back that was fucking crazy
it was such a that was actually insane like what the fuck what the fuck was that
Holy shit.
Actually insane.
Like, they should just like, they should just hook up.
This is like, I can feel the sexual tension from these two.
Like, you love men too.
Why are you projecting love ma-
They were so strong.
I was not...
Oh, and you get water.
I finished my water.
Give me a sec.
I'll finish my water.
Bro, I'm getting this for free too.
I'm getting paid.
With my...
I'm getting paid to get this content for free?
Oh, wait, no, not free.
But they're paying me to get this content.
I've never seen two people more perfect for each other.
I get paid a Doomcute?
No.
That's just...
Oh, what lifestyle?
It's just, unfortunately, a lifestyle at this point.
Like...
You're paying my mental for the entertainment.
That's so true.
But yay!
Oh.
Yay, free content.
Alright.
I'm actually losing steam though so whatever happens next game I'm calling it I don't care we win or lose I'm actually losing steam now yeah that I think after the P after using the bathroom oh shit wait this is a real game friends or not friends yeah that that like that was good that was actually good hello role play or not role play oh role play hello gentlemen are you whoa whoa i'm sorry what oh my god sorry for interrupting your special time sorry i'll guess i'll watch right Oh my,
let's break up.
I love my daily soap.
No, look, look, wait, I was joking.
I break up live.
Oh my god.
this is crazy from one to another oh no he killed the love of his life i'm not what he's using me as a meat shield now
guys i think i mean do you guys expect anything different this game is filled with gooner shit this game do you really everyone here is a goddamn freak this game is filled with the shit ever.
Like, like, look at all these skits.
Like, look at this.
Look at...
Oh, that's sad.
Yeah, after...
25.
I didn't like you.
But, like, after that fucking last game, oh my god, all my energy was gone.
All that adrenaline I got.
from the loser disappeared because I had a good time when, like, we lost, but like their EU is so wild.
EU really is.
Maybe like end of season is wild.
I swear to God.
I swear to God, like when I was off stream, when I was playing like for like four to five hours off stream, nobody was fighting each other.
Like, it was like kumbaya.
but it was like four to five hours before i streamed it was like kumbaya like i didn't know what he talked or like everyone was just chill like that
and then i started stream and i swear i've been getting arguments like every other game every every other game it's been a wild argument
banish from this match
no not just eu but i've been having these it was been happening in na as well like i've been having some weird ass fucking conversations in na the
universe knew i needed content more content what would i do with all this content i'm so my god i'm so full bro i just wanted to make people lose 500.
That's all I wanted to do.
That's not that toxic.
I'm gonna try my best to stay up the rest of the day.
Ah.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
At least I don't have to play Luna.
I really don't want to play Luna.
Alright, I'm ready.
Ba-da-da-ba-ba-da.
All right, last game.
Okay, I should say that.
This is LG for me.
And then maybe, like, tonight, I can drag down the other pro player we befri- Well, I don't know if I can say befriended.
Maybe I can drag down the other pro-player.
Maybe I will stream arrivals.
Because I didn't want to stream.
for rivals i'm having a great time i'm actually having such a good time i'm happy i'm having such a good time i don't know i just like dang i just like playing rivals and i like streaming i just like make numbers ha they're going triple support
oh i fucked up their jump there you go you're welcome you're welcome That's right.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
I want to say that it might not be winnable long term.
Okay.
Because they have.
Like, yeah, we are.
Okay, I won't.
I'm not dooming.
I won't doom.
I won't doom, guys.
Boom.
It could be winnable.
It's just when I see it.
When I see triple support, it makes me so sad.
Where is it?
What the fuck?
I think she'll be fine.
It's just Emma.
Bum bum bum.
I just get scared when I play against, when I play against triple support.
Because long term wise, triple support is scary long term.
Oh yeah, do you guys know that they're never gonna make villains into, they're never gonna put villains in, um, even though I'm like, because like I would say it, hella and Loki.
I thought Loki are villains, but they said they're never going to put Doom in Marvel Rivals because they think like...
Um...
Okay, this is bad because...
Okay, I don't know if you saw that pull I did.
That pull?
Oh my god, that was insane.
Because they see Ultron as like an anti-hero.
That pull, they were going to use it to block the Strange Owl.
And I pulled him away from it.
What the?
This is bad because I used a pull and they have all...
That's why it's bad.
I'm Didge.
It's fine.
My Luna has Alt soon.
And she's not going to get ulted.
She got ulted.
I'll fight for my family until the end.
She got ulted, guys.
I remember reading that they're not planning on ever making Doom like an actual playable character.
Maybe they'll change that later.
I definitely remember reading about it.
Okay, but Loki...
Okay.
he's hot he has pretty privilege and you know it yeah that's interesting yeah I was gonna I got yeah
see this is what I mean long-term wise the moment they stabilize and alt rotate like it's different Jesse
And all it takes is just alt rotations You can just I need to save my ult for either Strain
Okay Alright
Oh that sucks We got kicked out There's a shark behind me There you are Oh
That sucks literally all we need is triple support
Yeah, he's just trolling he's just joking Is what I mean the moment the moment um We get stuck in a certain area is literally just alt rotations And it's so tilty That's why triple support will always be like better Because like yeah yeah we were like fucking we were fucking on that first fight but they stabilized now oh luck everybody what what what okay i don't like that yeah yeah they're running for it
Oh, what happened?
I have it now.
Okay, I got it just in time.
Thank God.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I got the Luna.
Alright.
It's okay.
I got the Luna.
I gotta think now.
I don't know.
The Luna ult was a little, like, scary, but everything is okay now.
I'll let the Luna build her ult.
Oh!
I have to, like, focus up there.
This is why I hate triple support, man.
Oh, my God.
I fucking hate triple support so much.
Oh!
It's just...
Not fun!
There we go.
See?
See, look at that.
Oh, goodbye.
Also, goodbye.
Oh, he's gonna do that.
Fucking...
God damn it.
Goodbye, everyone.
Goodbye, everybody.
I can die, maybe.
We win that.
Me and...
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
We win those!
I don't know what I did, but let's go!
I don't even know how we won that.
What the fuck?
That was crazy.
We win those!
Here's the Wolverine.
I think he's fine, right?
There we go.
I don't think he knows, is he?
Shit If it works it works I'll take this
Bro fuck this
Goodbye, I'm fine with him go away That's fucking hilarious fucking idiot
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the Let's go Yes, yeah, please Get away from the point Fucking take it with you You think I care
That's crazy That mag was fucking crazy
That's wild Just can't play bro all
right no matter what happens jesus sorry i just noticed just i just noticed
my eyes finally looked down guys i'm too busy healing i can't looking good all the time don't worry oh where
I'm trying to game, okay?
Sometimes I just don't notice it.
Okay.
I didn't want to drop down, but if they're all going to drop down, I guess we're going to drop down.
Oh, Jesus.
I hope you're healing the other tank, then.
Because I have to keep your ass up.
there you go i built that up so oh my god this is where i might fucking get wait what what oh this is just you and i okay um i think we might i'm just gonna yeah i saw that point this guy definitely plays she he does the exploit so what he does he does like there's a group There's a Jeff exploit that you can do.
Alright.
Here you go.
There you go.
Hello.
I swapped just in case.
But like, I think I should swap.
Whoops.
It's too late.
We're committed now.
We're in it for the long haul.
There's a Jeff exploit where you can stay, like, up top forever.
Okay.
It's too late.
We're here now.
This is where we live.
It's considered an exploit.
It's not like an actual...
Like, it's actually considered an exploit.
Bro, how...
Bro, what is... You are such a freak.
You're actually a fucking freak right now.
Holy shit!
Okay, I might as well.
I'm gonna go die on this point.
this is where i die this is where i die because i don't want to play her
all right that was unfortunate i didn't realize we would have won that fight so fast i should have swapped the invis too that's 100 percent
jesus mean wise oh my god
Okay.
Nice.
You saw how all of us just was like, goodbye, Luna.
We're all like, goodbye, good luck, Luna.
We don't sit here.
We didn't even try and, like, push up.
We don't just sit there.
I'm going to let Luna heal.
Oh, never mind.
I'm not gonna...
There ya go.
I know.
Nice.
I'll let Luna heal now.
This is what I mean.
I'm conscious about my Luna.
Shark Rathai?
I'll give him.
Okay.
What are you doing?
Hello?
You don't have your ult.
I'm trying to let you build your ult right now.
Okay, now she should have her ult so I can heal now.
I know she's gonna build it here.
Okay.
They can't hold a vault.
Um, this is a lot of us.
I'm dead.
That was a lot.
I'll just say it.
That was a lot of ults.
Oh my god, go Luna, go skate fast.
Okay, but our other guy is so fucking...
Should I keep your walk when I get up?
I think we can walk.
I think we should walk.
Yeah, we'll walk.
Oh no, that's bad.
That was like so many fucking alts, so that's crazy.
These guys really hate it.
But let me build up, let me build up, let me build up.
Come on.
I'm almost there.
Come on, almost there.
I have it.
Oh my god.
Please, please.
Can I feed me just a little bit?
Can I?
Hey.
Hello.
Thank you.
I'm feeding you.
I'm feeding you so much.
Oh, me first.
I have me first.
I'll see if I can dunk those.
Oh, no.
Maybe I'll save it for Luna.
I don't know.
They should have Wolf, or Shrain's up again.
Yeah, yeah, he's walking, I can tell.
Oh Maya.
Nice.
Oh, I got caught.
I am ready to put on a show.
We're gonna have him.
I'm almost back.
No!
He's strange!
I'll take me that whore!
That whore!
Oh my god.
Goodbye.
Oh, leave me.
The Wombo combo!
The thing is, if I push the strange away, If I push the strange away, I would still get hit.
I still can't do jack shit about it.
Because...
What about me?
Um...
Oh my.
Upper strange.
I still can't do anything about it because the fucking...
He was just gonna fucking slam dunk me anyway.
Because I have to get out of Envis to get slam dunked.
Both behind us now.
Yeah, he has a...
He has a...
He's way...
Oh my god, I don't like...
I don't want to stand near him.
That's the worst part.
I think we should die on cart, shouldn't we?
Oh, we should have died on cart.
We should not have just backed up.
This is like scary now.
Oh.
What happened to ulting the...
What happened?
What happened to Ulti?
Oh my god.
She didn't.
Do that one thing.
He didn't.
I knew it.
You know what happened?
Three, two, three.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
I was like, why did we all back up?
Just die on point.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
That's unlucky.
That's so unlucky.
Yeah, the last two push.
The last two push was so many mistakes.
Yeah, I was so confused.
Why did we do that?
We could have, like...
Oh, we got random...
Like, she held her alt for no reason.
She could have used that alt to save...
I'm just gonna need the wolf permapane.
The...
They could have used that ult to save us from getting picked.
Because they were greedy and was like, I'll use my ult for Wove.
I'll use my ult for Wove.
We still died.
They used the ult for Wove, but two of us still died.
Because I could have built up.
That's the thing.
Make sure you could have done that.
And then I could have built my ult for Wove.
That's the thing.
why I felt like I felt like it was just really dumb that we held that just either we die on card and then we regroup together because like they were just free-firing us we should have just died on card together then there's no I have to use this I told you guys it's triple support I I had a feeling I had I had a feeling I was like it's triple support it's always There you go.
At least I saved him.
He just can't jump when he's supposed to.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh no.
Wait.
I don't even know who he took.
I don't know if I'll get it.
You're gonna have to let me build all of you want me to get it.
Because I don't know if I'm gonna get it, guys.
We'll find us.
He's gonna hold everything.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
How's this?
Oh, my god, again.
Again!
Alright.
Let's hope I don't die.
All right.
All right, let's hope you actually get it.
That's unlucky.
I'm ready to put on a show.
I can't believe we
Oh, we got out of point That's unlucky Time to switch things up That's unlucky It's fine, the Wolverine Fuck you was gonna kill me
That's unlucky Yeah um no arm do you have an emmon in for a leg i don't i don't it's one of those three oh probably a thing then i guess i guess you gotta be stroking it to be considered touching that's crazy
dodged that sharky.
He thought I was there.
Did you see that?
He would try to eat me.
And then we all split up for some fucking reason.
That was bad.
That was bad that we all split up there.
Oh.
It's gonna be hard.
Try not to be too nervous.
The battle starts in five.
Four, three, One!
Here they come!
There's some room.
Oh, it's fine.
Oh, thank you.
Only 60 seconds left.
We always do.
We'll go top.
I have to drop them dropping in too.
Jesus Christ.
I'm trying not to give...
Back, back, back, back, back, back.
Back, back, back.
Okay, I have it.
Oh my.
I'm just gonna play it on point.
Because I wanna...
That's fine.
I got...
I stalled it.
I wanted to stall it as much as I can.
Also did not think he got three.
I did not realize he got three.
No, he wasn't targeting me.
He got three people and I didn't even realize he did that.
They have
Wait, we lost Oh no, we don't have anything now We are committing so much Yeah, we committed so much
I want to go rocket here
Do I go rocket?
taking you spawn in jpn we gotta find your meme when this jet holds so that i can page you guys out go behind us go behind us
what why why did
you fade why did you fade why didn't you fade what did you do with emma and starlord i think we're just like completely wasted on nothing why did you
I just saw him take that
bro he's like don't worry I'll fade and he just stared at the mask that that was that was my LG though I said no matter what happens this was my LG I know that was such a sad ending though I know it was it was a sad ending but we have to call it there yeah but what if he lied
I don't know it'll be better I don't know if the next game will be better chat there's no we don't know that fine I won't end on the loss if I do rank I do rank chat doesn't want me to end on a loss Okay, we go again.
Alright, fine.
Because it was very disappointing.
I knew it.
I knew it, too.
I fucking knew it.
I knew that game was going to be a loss.
Because they went triple support and we did it.
Needs a sec.
Maybe none of us said that.
I can scroll up.
Don't end on a bad one.
That was a rough end.
One more?
You got one more in you.
Come on.
Don't end on a loss.
But what if Nana queued up till we win?
There's only one way to find it.
What do you stop selective reading?
I literally, I just, it's like one out of, of three, I would see that you're getting not the one guy.
She is lame.
This is a group effort.
You are a collective, okay?
If one dragoon told me that it wasn't one, okay?
They are representative of you.
That's fine.
I don't mind playing one more.
That made me angry.
I knew it too.
We literally just needed.
I'm thinking should I have?
I'm thinking like oh what if I kept my invisible alt there?
But like how was I supposed to know he got three of us?
You know?
I didn't realize he got three of us so I'm like oh maybe if I kept my invisible alt there maybe we could have won.
But then I'm like thinking like it's still a maybe.
It was just a lot of mistakes.
Because I wanted to I used it there To stall the point So we could I used it there So we could stall the point And touch the cart That's the only reason why I did it And I think I think we almost couldn't touch the cart So maybe I did do the right thing Because My team was able to touch the cart After that but we did lost the invisible from it it just sucked the last two the last two like we like we got snowballed during the last half
which is unfortunate but it is what it is it is what it is
I'm just waiting for Riggs to queue us up you know what we have to do while we wait
I don't want to beat.
I don't even know what emotes I have on my characters.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, no, I don't know.
I don't know what emotes I have.
Good time.
Oh, yo, does someone order a dancer?
Whoa.
Hey, girls.
Are you ready to...
Oh, wait.
I should stand here.
This is my stage.
Bum-bum.
Whoa.
yeah that's right why is it that yeah whoa whoa give me a sec let me regen real quick i gotta regen here i got my own stage give me a sec this is whoa eat aske fast whoa that is wrong
you can bite but nothing else that is wrong jeff that is absolutely wrong jeff bad bad dog
i don't know
he's locked in i'm his one-man show poor america yo cap he's just he's just enjoying the view okay
you like this sir oh shit turn around oh you're right don't worry let me don't worry sir i got what you oh oh shit he's like get away i paid for this service bum bum but wait what happened to the captain but he disappeared oh my there we go he's back he's gone he did not like that bum bum bum bum bum bum
Did I pass, sir?
Did I pass the test, mister?
Oh, he likes the front view, guys.
He doesn't want the back view, chat.
He's here for the front.
Oh, my God.
He's here to protect me.
Look at that.
He's like, no shooting that merchandise.
Whoa!
He's a boob man.
You know how they're layered in?
Are you an ass man or a boob man?
You can tell he's a boob man.
Moto Moto likes you.
Oh, nice.
Spider-Man, yeah, he was goon.
He goon.
Bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom.
I'm not the type who fades.
Okay.
Less bad.
I was like, oh.
But now it's less bad.
It wasn't very good when I first loaded it in.
Alright, here we go.
Cannon, honestly.
Oh man, I'm actually really running on three of them.
Okay, whatever happens to this game, I'm out.
I'm actually out.
I'm out, out, chat.
LG, for real.
This is real LG.
No more fake...
That's not...
No more fake LG.
Also, like, I'm most likely...
I just end stream and then I disappear.
No rain.
Because I'm too tired to figure out who to rain.
I'll just...
I'll be like, disappear!
Disperse!
Find your...
What?
Why did he play it?
Oh.
Find the one you want to watch next.
Oh, Snuffy's streaming?
Alright, Snuffy.
Is she still streaming after?
I'm ready.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
This is a...
Okay.
Okay, this cop.
Alright, whatever happens happens.
I'm actually running on fumes.
So whatever happens happens.
It is what it is.
Now I'm ready.
raid.
I'm going to raid Snuffy after.
No, this cop absolutely looks fucking terrible, but that's okay.
That's okay.
That means Rigsby is not closer to top 500, too.
Because I'm pretty sure he deranged.
I swear that, God, if I see a...
If I see triple support, I swear that I'm going to be very angry daddy's angry oh man this sucks i for those who don't know um this map is fucking terrible because it's so laggy
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god i'm so scared i'm so scared
my team.
What happened to my team?
Okay.
Thank God.
That's okay.
We don't have, they have still have support outs, but that's it.
All right.
That's five.
That's my serve game game.
probably vc band again i wouldn't doubt it if he's vc band oh my god okay he might have got i he hasn't been talking to me i'm his duo but yeah i just realized his name at all i think he just should have said yes to it i just realized his name that wow what he didn't even say nothing that
Oh, no.
Good luck.
There was nothing.
Oh, the map's moving.
My body is being transported.
Oh, they wasted that.
That's good.
Oh, no, it's because we used Scylla.
I mean, it's still a waste.
I think it's...
No.
God, yeah, but this map is known to cost huge $4.
Rain drops.
That's...
What?
Oh, did he get...
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh.
That's unlucky.
He didn't say anything that crazy.
And then literally, so it was like, has he said he's theirs yet?
Can we stop staggering, please?
My fault, my fault.
That's crazy.
Guys, I think he has said something crazy.
He's in it.
Okay.
Bro,
bro, there's no way.
Like, how do you...
Oh, my God.
god okay okay that's unlucky that's very unlucky i think it's also because he's oh my god okay
that oh we just don't have baba for it i think all right this is actually lg though even we don't win this i'm too tired to keep going i'm mad Like,
we're running.
This is a weird-ass duo, too.
This is a weird-ass duo because we are running.
They're duoed as, like, Groot and an Iron Fist, yo.
Oh, I.
TPS time for me.
no maybe no silk song i don't think i can i don't think i can make it i don't think so family still comes i think it's over for me i really do guys i don't think i'm fixing my sleep schedule i really don't okay i think i just end up streaming where rivals i was trying to fix my sleep schedule also like it's been fun Oh no,
I said that this week will be like no schedule week.
Because I did get last minute invited to a business trip.
So like it would be awkward putting out schedule because I'd be gone at the end of the week till Wednesday.
Persia's day?
I like how we still don't have time.
triple support which is very scary or like you know a mag it would be nice to have a mag you know that would be pretty cool just a little bit I guess I guess not that cool now that I think about it okay I'm sorry you were not gonna live Like, there was no way.
There was no way.
It's just unlucky.
We just got...
We get like...
We got all the players...
Like, this is...
See, E-O-M-M-Giveth and E-O-M-T-E-Theth.
We got...
We got all the players...
Oh my gosh, I should have stopped.
I should...
I should have stopped really.
All the players that play the most niche characters...
Combined into one team.
Like we have a group player and then the iron fist is dueled with a group one trick And then we have the spider-man player So it's like there's no winning We literally we have the all the niche players to get it So there's there's oh my god Oh my god The fucking thing changed
Like, I was trying, the fucking, the map changed so I couldn't jump to the high ground.
That was so fucked.
That was actually so fucked.
I was trying to jump to that high ground area.
No, this is, it's actually the most unlucky.
It give if and it take it.
guys all right I gamba too hard it's like I got the 666 you know I got the 666 guys I
don't think I'm building this up Victories are worth celebrating.
Hey.
Ha, miss.
Ha, you're so bad.
Oh, shit.
He was not.
Oh, my God.
He was farming our Groot.
He was not missing.
Oh, my God.
Guys, he wasn't missing, guys.
He was just...
Hey, guys.
Cool.
Like, I don't know what we could do to fix that.
Like, I...
Do you know what would a triple support?
Oh my god, you play strange.
Why do you do this to yourself?
You're trying to tell me that you actually play other characters, but oh my god But you just chose not to
like that's crazy i literally told you to avoid serbian serbian freak down you you get bro and this guy no bro i mean like one trick's gotta stick together you know like maybe okay i'm it's fine i'm i'm i did get my seventh win from this but I need a stop I know I'm gonna get so tight I need a stop I I got see him swapped it strange willingly made me realize that he had a choice and he decided not to that's that's crazy this guy
Oh my god, he's- he's having- oh my god.
Bro, what?!
Bro!
Okay, I was gonna say, this guy- this guy!
Okay, I- I go sleep.
GG's, I'm done.
Yeah, me too.
Yeah.
No, I'm good.
I think that was my sign.
But I still had a great time.
I had a great time streaming today.
You guys always cheer me up and everything.
Maybe I'll do another grind later today.
Maybe.
Maybe not on YouTube.
Maybe I'll do on Twitch.
I'll do another grind later today on Twitch.
Or just not grind.
I think grind is not the right word.
I'll do another Edo Terrorism Day later today.
and then I don't know have more people fucking embarrassed themselves on my stream but thank you all for coming I had a fun time streaming guys really cheering me up a lot because you know I was feeling really down so thank you guys it does mean a lot for those who are new here my name is Doki Bird I use the stream variety on YouTube so please check me out there I do guerrilla streams.
I do random streams on Twitch.
So like today, I just really felt like streaming rivals.
And that's why I was there.
So yeah, please check me out on YouTube.
And if you want to know whenever I stream on Twitch, check me out, follow me on Twitter.
Everyone support me via other means.
Please check out my merch.
It does help out a lot.
Thank you all for the bitties, for the donations, for the subscriptions, for the subs, everything.
All those.
Thank you all.
Hope you had a fun time watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around.
to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed guys you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye